Really.
Yeah, I yeah, I really.
Yeah.
Screen read this folder.
No, you forgot.
And send over that hardware.
They sent over the hardware.
It's all for fast launch,
so that way they don't have to take it's
all.
I'll put the budget in there for sure,
even though it's probably,
but just for you to make sure I don't
need to add to you know, so.
Everything, whether that's not really.
All right,
we're out thinking it's something,
so I'm just gonna leave it,
but I'll send it over to the review.
Did you hear that one about the breakout
in here also for budget MGX MGX 25/17/13.
I'm going to, when I send over,
I'll have a budget in there to show we
have to cover the hardware. Oh, OK,
I'm sorry. Yes. OK, I got you. Yep.
I'm gonna follow that up with the
hardware.
And that'll follow up in that e-mail when
I send over for for you guys. Yeah,
I'll show you the the numbers to show
that you can purchase the the hard drive.
Thank you, Sir. Yes, Sir.
Got it.
40,000, 40,000, $40,
000 and you're telling me that's all.
Well, there's a whole truck, 45,
000 lbs process, but that's the only raw.
OK, that looks like, yeah,
you should all that.
Good work. The other stuff,
it's process still, like it's tagged.
It's that's already process. It's not,
it's not good. It's a big 3000, you know.
What is the time?
And here is the the that's what the 16,
000 tons and has a story of 27 and 27.
Yeah, I'm just talking .6 to start.
So we're almost 27 and 28, 29. Yeah,
I think I see something. But yeah, well,
Rob was asking like, how can I build this?
I don't know.
I Yeah, so.
Right.
Also having a free time and forward on a
scare package. So we're you know,
it's the AEH and people are supposed to.
I don't think they need ASAP,
but it's all.
Which approved.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're supposed to start the next week for
the next. Yes, Sir.
So.
Yes, there is.
All the minutes.
Now, is that the beginning or?
Oh, OK, well, I have a pretty. Yeah,
I can.
I can get that facilitated for sure.
John and Jack this morning.
They're asking how's we've been working.
No,
that's all I'm saying from the person to
the chair, John. John's now Jerry Jerry,
Jerry is the way to do.
I do.
You know how you mentioned you can use it.
I'm actually writing them up. He said.
Oh yeah, he said.
What we'll initiate it early is he posted
it to the job, but don't post it under.
I mean, well,
we need a special code built in that we
can use on each job. So we can say, OK,
standby time or whatever you want to
think about this.
And so I left again and we said, yeah,
we can do that. Yeah.
So that's what I'm writing in the front
now because I talked to Jim to clear,
Jimmy and Jerry.
Yeah,
we need to just adjust the government
funding to go together.
I got to Jimmy and that's what we should
do. Yeah, you know,
to keep the people paid, but let's try to.
And that way it would affect all of our.
Training, welding, layout,
and all the other stuff that we can still,
yeah, absolutely separate,
put it in and be creative.
That makes perfect change.
Yeah, yeah. Um, if there's any files,
I can give you some runtime if anything.
Uh, but if it's just those, let me know.
Oh.
Uh, for every set of screeners, uh,
we we're at 4545 minutes to present.
Uh, 20 foot sections.
And that's what we think.
And that's how she like.
Just if you get that sort of.
Or 20/30 section. OK, great.
So that's a good error in 20-3 Cortana
response. Yeah, so.
All right. Thank you, Sir.
I think something like.
Yeah, it's like.
We shouldn't. I hear your.
I think it's just like people who saw.
That's Mark. And now I'm here.
Russell Floyd. How are you?
Nice to meet you. Nice to meet you. Hi,
Gavin. Nice to meet you as well.
Good. Brian, Barry. Sorry, I'm sorry.
Needing to wrap your board chairments.
I guess that's a. What's that?
I would give you the purchasing. Oh,
there you go. Yeah,
give me for our training purposes.
Give them a quick contact.
But my team does all the purchasing.
I need to make sure that the new
procurement guy.
Awesome. He's the guy. He's really.
It's good.
Been doing it for quite a few years. So,
so, yeah, yeah,
we got some good context in the valley.
And that's a lot of, obviously, right?
Yeah, it's 71 days.
So there's 7000 non-existent,
portions of it.
He also shares the same thing about it.
I said I see what you have and don't have,
and I said so you're going young.
Most kind of the stuff is already seen
before the Jerry's talking.
I mostly they will have prices done there
and then that's what they're saying.
The the only way I said it is that if you
don't have anybody's service subject or
the time distribution or you don't build
it, you don't have to. That's it. OK, OK,
I'll send that to you.
I think one of the people that we met you.
I don't know.
They have three team lives and they're
also nasty in their tons.
So that's what we're going to do
visibility over.
You need the whole capacity.
You need to do 93 tons a day.
Yard. Yeah,
it's like 81 days and that's mean every
single significant chart.
We've got some contacts like that.
We have Friedman.
A plate of Semi Rd.
uh that trucking direct out of the middle
to June at two 4846 cents a high profit
word versus standards.
I found the proposal.
I couldn't find the estimate,
so it's you know it's not on the server.
But I but I've left is reach out 20
minutes.
So did you know like see if you're
working? How do we? I haven't got.
I got it.
I can have set some goals for the
projects themselves.
Estimate.
They really don't want to get a great
home. You see, have you?
OK.
I've got an opinion here,
but Cheryl's support,
but that advice I have at least suggested
when they tell me like, respond or use it.
So there's a there's an attribution that
you should have information. It's kind of,
you know, it's OK. I didn't say, hey,
when I'm thinking we're going to all this
trouble with tech one wise all our
details.
Yeah, and they said, oh, no,
they'll send us page.
Have you hit the list? I just said, OK,
that's good. Yeah, we like that new stuff.
Nothing. We can't.
I would say in our region we're not
really as of right now obviously to be
nice to have that look ahead decision for
the job has to face so much.
So you guys can really hear about stock
basement.
I just want to see behind the curb to see
how to figure that's like OK,
that's what we need.
Honest.
I didn't see the results,
so I should have.
I haven't launched it yet and I haven't.
I don't know. I didn't want to find it.
We're going to be able to say last year,
but you get to see how we can see other
things.
So you're going to work with something
like that.
You're already going to look at the smoke.
Yeah, they get to the so it works. Yeah,
the default that they gave me from the
test.
So it works. Yeah,
I mean you can work fine.
I'll see if the accident is a good
program. It should be capacity.
We've heard this and the one they
installed the chat again. He's done.
He's done the minimum. Yeah,
he does all of uh, it's.
Uh, well required. Um,
you can work together.
I need to take this over, guys.
I just popped in. By the way, I apologize.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
I think the recording be answered as good
things. Slide's changing.
So we're all curious to hear if that's
changing the line, the line, yeah.
China. It's a good word, yeah.
OK, I'll take it. It's like, it's like,
it's right.
And then it's time to come back out and
come back out. Well, dude, it's,
it's appreciate that. Take care, guys.
Please see you then.
Thank you. Thank you.
I felt bad when everyone was looking for
you and like, look,
I'll just take you over there until you
try. What was the guy's name? He got me.
I don't think you got really good. Huge.
Yeah, you think.
I don't hear anything guys.
They're from, yeah, one's brand new. So.
So that's the guy that replaced the other
guy. Yes, that's the guy. Yes. Yeah,
they were looking for as well.
We're not really people,
at least over here. Well,
I think these guys are coming in new guy,
right? And then they're aligning systems.
So I think with all these acquisitions,
I think they've got.
Bunches of assistance,
they were throwing word stratus.
They they have.
So they've been doing that right here and
we don't give us decisions like there's
no.
So there's there's talk about we're going
to have a procurement department and then
it's just like, oh, you do procurement,
OK, I will speak to you.
Event site this this one established.
Do we have people will be buying stuff in
the negotiation,
but they're not true purchasing people.
You know those bad stuff.
What are you talking about, man?
I pulled out a true purchasing person in
there.
Well, I was wondering, you know,
there's the right amount of controls,
not too much, not too little. Yeah,
because otherwise you end up blocking the
system up. What we were trying to do is.
Pool all of our purchasing for all the
different shops together so that we could.
Uh, take advantage of, you know,
purchasing power. It is.
They define power around the country.
Yeah,
we're we're trying to deal with our
consumables. We're working on a deal.
We're talking to air gas.
That's just something over there.
Yeah, like, I don't know. I mean, we.
They gave us the veterinarian system,
so we basically put the local building
shops out of business because all we were
a huge buyer.
It was Sunday with master agreements and.
Getting stuff like that,
things slowly going down.
The thing is that they're dealing with
local sales members and they didn't want
it to be.
Stop.
This town.
Must be.
It is. Yeah, there it is. Yeah,
I woke it up at 4:00 from the
notification for PPL. Thanks.
Uh, yeah,
maybe the early Saturday or the late
Saturday.
All right.
I have a question about the we're making
adjustments like you guys were doing
yesterday, the parameters you asked me.
Is there any part of log or saying, hey,
we're increasing the change recently?
No, there's not any law, so we're sure.
Here's what it was. Here's what it is.
But then you can lock the estimates up so
they don't change.
There's not a law that tells me what what
changes. Can you dump them?
Can you dump the old settings? Yeah.
So without the old settings, yeah, yeah,
you can set up,
you can set up a different shop and it
will well some some things are
differentiate by shop like the hours and
stuff differentiate by shop we built.
New shopping here,
but some structure that would that would
not.
Stay the same in one work. In other words,
they're the same across all shops.
But yes,
you could export out all of the settings
if you wanted to and then when you have
them,
if you need bring them back in later,
what you do, I think.
I mean, luckily only Gavin can do it,
right?
So he's he's the master of that domain.
You know, we start changing a lot.
Absolutely. We start.
Last week or something?
Yeah, yeah.
So with the lighting changes they made,
the only thing that was meeting some
adjustment or discussion where it finds
something to be.
I need to fit in the well the size of it.
Yeah,
because we are at least and even the the
size of the rates, we increase it.
We're all in this.
Um, but well,
that should be that way anyways.
And then the changes are made to the
plate processing,
adjusting the speed and then also putting
the parameters full parameters in the
plates. I was told that that should have.
Through main estimated one day when we
did it.
So that side of things and that's some of
the changes to they think that they're
using that how the buckets roll up 60 to
7% of the time we're using all that data
is the same as it was before. OK,
it shouldn't have you in a different
visual format.
All right,
so and and if I can even table that,
I think they should give it 100.
They know that also these guys use their
efforts. It's not up here, right?
It's not too.
And then as Ricky is saying what you have,
so.
And we really needed to get back so we
can all the time. You know, you can only.
It would be nice.
So.
My guess is the electrical portion of it
again is going to be in the afternoon
since Julie's not here this morning,
probably in some stuff to take care of it.
But looking at our agenda,
we have meeting development
implementation.
This.
It isn't for this one of the outside of
the outside of the of this area.
However with Part B in that section with
coatings shipping receiving fully adopted
go.
So we we could call in Paul Perez or
Angelo get them here and then also I'm
gonna record this so I don't think you
can so I can watch this back after
because technically he's the.
Codings coordinator as well.
So I'm guessing he'll be facilitating
some of the coding stuff that bringing
Chris Pena in here so that we can kind of
go over the process of go what these guys
are going to be seeing when they're out
there with the shippers and then the
codings aspect to kind of.
At least cover this task.
I think that's really all we can do
because those set up and it's a fully
functioning system at this point.
The implementation side of it's just us
getting equipment in the guy's hands and
saying this is the law, follow it or.
The questions, you know what is go?
What software's go? That's part of it.
So it's just the right version of it.
So you can do.
So it's just a module PowerPoint. Yeah,
I'm looking at it like a template version.
I'm looking at it like the input. Yeah,
no,
that's where you're getting this further.
I was trying to. I was trying. John,
we've got a big class order coming
tomorrow.
I'm gonna be snack central back here.
Can you send me your number here?
Tell me your cart when we get chats,
please.
Yeah, I need to re up my name.
I need to get a block installed first,
so it could be wrong. Yeah, the OK,
so do I need to start getting a shipping
memory? Yeah.
If you want to reach out to them,
you guys have the people that are gonna
use it. Yes,
you want to do the go training on.
It's on these guys.
Do we have any tablets that we can tell
him to bring? Do you want any? Yeah, yeah,
possible. Hey, yeah, this is my car.
When we're back, we sit down.
You go over the.
We have to go through each tablet.
I got 17 tablets or something to go there.
OK, I mean it should be.
I've got a big charging station off the
list. OK, yeah,
we can we can sign everybody.
But I'll I'll share that.
I don't know if you have the volume.
It's not fast to account, but you know,
Martin's regular, I open weeks, you know,
where he looks like they're having some
issues back to the.
Yeah, that's good to copy right there.
You definitely have two phones before us.
I I usually don't go much more to 100,
but yeah, I try to.
Usually it's about a month,
month and a half. So last time,
three days, I'm sorry.
It's a 24 up there. Oh,
that's good snacks. Yeah.
And then you go and you open one guy's
door and he's got like a freaking grain
of friction snacks in there.
So I think we're doing pretty good.
I mean, the shop doesn't.
Yeah.
That's my stuff.
You're going to get my ability to order
this stuff taken away from you, so.
Yeah, it's so of these guys in here.
I'm gonna take a quick look at my
invoices.
Because I've got a weather.
Yeah, nice.
Thanks so much.
I can't expect this next week,
always going to be down to, but we were.
We're going to pull that vacuum and
replaced two type top teeth. Yeah,
and then we got to continue.
Thank you.
I guess we probably have to get it next
week. Um,
we have to run the work that I will do,
which week this week.
So I think that was starting today.
So I must say that's the issue.
Speed live. Do we have light bulbs coming?
Oh, no,
not the ones that you're familiar with.
The local workshop for the expansion.
Yeah,
we're going to give Kate a credit of
coupons they gave us for a field job
through a light bulb.
It was such a pain in the *** to get,
you know,
they just gave it to us for free and I
was like,
what's the issue with credit sometime in
the future? Yeah,
we we had some things that we were
painting for them. So we kind of,
I went through, we took pictures,
we're seeing all the caveats to it and I
hope it's something that we can look at.
This coming year. Oh,
I think Jeff's gonna take.
That'd be. That'd be awesome.
I think it's probably fits this a lot
better.
Anyone wants to get out of everything
that's not the pressure. Oh, really? OK,
they're not trying.
They're doing it without feeling.
They're just ******* all their customers
off.
That's why most of us here later.
There's lessons, you know,
satisfy your customers.
I forgot it. Yeah,
it went through the whole structure.
It's Andy's gonna show you.
We should have found a fast way to search
it. What is it like to search it?
I would leave it.
I have somebody to get the results.
Yeah, it's definitely.
I don't think it's on the it's actually
Microsoft.
You know the number,
but it seems like that.
It's fine, but fast.
Thank you for joining us. Chris, Chris,
I know we've run into each other a couple
of times. What's that?
And then it's gonna be in the PDF,
so you can do one for the columns.
But then it's still loading.
I don't want to keep down on my computer
if you want to.
Third,
I was pulling up a couple of our reports
from with that statement show kind of
some of the reports that we pull where we
should be projects. What's this?
I hear you guys using the term like or
something?
HoloLens. Yes,
and this is our this is our HoloLens.
So essentially we load up an IT model in
the new fast station and then we overlay
the model over our built assemblies to
see if anything's off.
We've got our lines where it needs to be.
And and is that a visual check or does
like a program like Navisworks do a
comparison?
This is the visual check and when you use
the HoloLens,
it's within a 60th of an inch,
but you have to pick it up or it picks it
up and warns you.
It picks it up so so identification
markers.
We put these magnets that will pull it as
a reference point and then we pull the
correct model correspondence for this and
we'll overlay it,
make sure it's still and then it takes
about 5 minutes to do a very intricate
beam.
And this is just one of our quality
checks that we are now encompassing over
the last really heavy last year and a
half. Do you have the layout? Yes,
you can. Yes.
So do you need layout with it?
We have not gotten that far yet.
We do have some.
Restriction, I would say,
with us being open shop because sometimes
one of these the sun is in your way,
you know, but.
We we use this before we call our our QC
guy just to do a our QA you know on our
side for our leads.
That's part of our our process in the
show.
I've seen some people using it in videos
as layout tool, yes.
But the holidays was discontinued. Yeah,
Microsoft discontinued. Um, they're 26,
but they no longer manufacture those,
but they are trying to incorporate either
Meta or another uh.
Provider. Yeah, like,
I know Apple's gonna be coming out with
their own version. Yeah,
so we're working with that station on in
that regard.
So do I think this is the last one,
but I think there's some third party
people that do this as well.
Is it common to use it? Yes.
Oh no people that do like optical layout.
I am not not for layout.
That's that's not common.
I don't know that I've ever seen it for
layout versus just you see personally,
but I'll see it again.
Eventually it will come on,
so I see something. OK.
I think,
I think it was there to have that $2500
license to get involved or pull the
trigger on whatever. So yeah, I mean,
I think the HoloLens was almost toward
him. Yeah, it's pretty wild. Yeah,
that one was the.
Very,
very trusting of us to put that hourly
employee in the shop, yeah.
The process has done pretty good and
we've we've gotten to the point where.
We're getting the IFCS we need from all
our internal, internal detailers.
So we want to send them inside the file
here so so that we can find that
definitely is nice to have when the
customer requests it.
OK.
I will get this.
I I thought so.
And the cell honesty chart.
This is what EPM Go looks like when you
pull it up in your tablet.
Also be your sign in screen.
You'll end up coming in here.
Sign in with your ID.
It's gonna ask you to do a pass key and
so let me skip this one more time.
So this is what the mainstream is going
to look like with us using a format that
we're using at this point.
Most of everything you need will be in
the word packages portion.
We just need to make sure codings is on
the same page with their codings only
projects of creating the work package for
what they have going to the floor.
I don't see any reason why they wouldn't
use the exact same process flow that that
we're doing.
Uh,
I also got the experiment here at the
time you'll see to get.
Spill.
You know,
so you can go into the work packages,
just so you can see what this looks like.
So as it sits right now,
you'll have your work package.
Per project,
per area of work and then also sometimes
you'll see per project, per area of work,
per facility.
This is where we can really get down to
the nitty gritty of this is what needs to
be come from first, this is the middle.
This is the follow and we can schedule
those kind of things out and assign
priority based upon what should be
addressed first. With that being said,
when you go into this work package,
you can access all of the assemblies that
are associated in there.
You can get your drawings.
This information isn't going to be
practical for you guys,
but this piece tracking is what's going
to be relevant for you guys because
you're going to be using the piece
tracking system in this to mark off your
guys stuff.
We didn't set up any inspections that are
tied to the project,
so you would need to be able to see the
inspection that the current can't set up
enough for service truck in that module.
You'd have to go back onto the home
screen and go to.
Company line inspections and then do a
surface front inspection from that module
in the future.
I'm guessing potentially we will be
adding coatings inspections on a project
basis.
So in that instance you would then need.
Be able to access them from this specific
check box production status.
This is where if you guys have an
appointees only project, if it's simple,
it's going to have prep and prime.
If it's complex, it's going to have prep,
prime.
Intermediate code,
finished code and then we can expand on
that further as you guys do get on a more
complex system of tracking the the
inbetweens.
I I I don't know what the extent.
I mean not not too pretty for the coding
set of things.
I mean you have a five code system.
I can go in here and quickly create a
route that additional stations and adjust
and get you guys the ability to piece
track each section of what you're going
for and then also.
The ability to create load lists and in
the shipping side of lists.
So work packages are going to be super
helpful for keeping one guy in one place
with all the data where it needs to be
having full visibility, your job number,
your area, work start date, due dates and.
Where it is.
So this project doesn't have the piece
tracking associated with it,
but I will go in here just to kind of
show you what this looks like for this
project.
This one's going to be catered to fab.
Actually this one doesn't have.
Some options on so I forgot I adjusted
some of our way to the fabrication routes
that have that in there.
So this is going to be the screen that
one of your painters is going to have up
and or one of your prep guys is going to
have up.
And when he grabs a batch of work, 15,
seven days that he's taken over into the
blast area,
he'll have this screen up on his tablet,
he'll go into this ad bats portion,
he'll go in here.
And when he's got everything ready to go,
he's going to get coming here and hit
start.
Then he can go start blasting all of this
stuff and once he has all of those
assemblies done, then he can come in here,
hit stop and then go to update and first.
Yeah.
It's.
That's would be if all of those pieces
are there, yes.
So hit the start at the beginning of it,
update Max quantity.
Now if we wanted to be really regular,
just to ensure that you guys have the
total count of what you're going for
instead of doing the Max quantity.
And you go in there and go line by line.
OK, I've got two of these, four of these,
four of these, four of these,
and one of these.
And then from there you would click
update and then this would get you.
If we go to production status at two
points and see in the area.
Hit the 2nd button over on the on the
variety.
Yeah.
Yes.
So now we will see all of those items
that we just completed.
That's fine enough in the prep portion.
So from that then it would go into its
next area.
So you could go back in your production
tracking.
And.
Just did it right.
They were it says production tracking,
so and then you're going to prime,
going to add batch and you would follow
that same process, hit start.
The biggest thing that we're going to
want to confirm.
Is when we want that start button to be
hit.
Is it when an operator comes over with a
stack of everything that's full out of
glass and it's still on a pallet before
you guys put it up on some horses or if
it's?
Once it's on the soft horse and staged
out, everything's ready to go.
Paint gun is ready to go,
primer is ready to rock.
Then you hit start and then start
painting and then once you're done
painting, then hit stop.
So that's one discussion that we'll have
to have with Mo on.
And if he's trying to capture the full
scale of his process in each of these
categories,
or if he's trying to capture the nitty
gritty of this is what it takes to blast
handling is going to be in between.
And then this is what it's going to take
the pain. Everything else is in between.
So, so I guess a question for you.
I know I've seen a lot of different when
they're setting up their machine for this
job.
Are there any go?
So that's one thing we want to make sure
with Moe,
if that's something that he wants
included in this portion,
because I think that would be relevant,
especially in the in the time. Yeah,
they're popular mixing their pay,
you know, again.
And then the second part would be would,
you know,
because our our spray man has a botman
who's mixing his paint,
who's folding his line,
who's checking it for him.
So they both like they both would have a
different tablet they can go.
So, so it'll be one guy.
The way that our estimates currently set
up that our factor is factored with two
guys assisting in every portion of the
work that you guys are talking about.
So with this tracking.
The assumption is going to be that there
is,
so you will be able to do that the in the
next version, like I said,
in 2026 you got both guys,
that's all going to breakdown and keep.
Now I mean theoretically,
does there one guy could be?
He could process to agree the piece and
then another guy process to agree the
piece and now you capture both their
times. Yep. Um.
So yeah, when we process it for that.
So but this is the higher level over the
entirety of what's included in the work
package or the sequence on the block.
You can do individual tracking online
items and track your hours as such.
Per piece and so you can switch to
part-timers and each one will have its
own if you have a very complex assembly
and a lot of those relatively similar
complex assemblies.
You can time studies on individual items
like W&
W with those big columns and say, well,
at the start of the project we were doing
one column in 30 minutes.
By the end of the project we were doing
one column in one and kind of.
Get an average.
So next time you guys bid it,
you can shoot it right in the middle and
have have the middle ground be able to
take the numbers and everything so.
So that's that's one of the main things.
So work packaging is super helpful having
the the transparency or transparency of
can I forget to share the screen.
And the transparency of everything in
place. Now assuming this function,
the work package isn't set up and you
guys are trying to.
You're you're at this screen.
You don't have the work packages set up.
You got the project number in sequence.
You can go into the projects portion and
then filter for your project.
We'll do 6145.
Then you can open the project and you'll
see that a lot of this information is
very similar to what's in the in the work
package, but this is on project scale,
so with this being said.
If it's a really big project,
then you're going to have to go into your
filters up in the top here,
build it for the sequencing log that you
guys have on the floor that you're trying
to code,
and then you can go through the same
exact process here.
That's just why we're packaging so little
easier for the guys less thinking.
We did the filtering in the front end so
that you guys have transparency of what's
gonna come out to you in batches in any
case, so.
Hear me.
It's fine.
OK. So,
so that's the biggest thing is with this,
we've got a bunch of devices that we're
going to be assigned to your guys and
this is what we have set up in the system
that law wants to use going forward that
everyone on this property is going.
To be using for tracking purposes.
So anything that touches the fabrication
shop in coatings,
me and Helen will be set up in the way
that you guys are going to see it based
upon coating spec,
anything that's coatings only.
That will be essentially managed by Emily
and depending you maybe mode,
but something that you guys will have
this available to you so that we can get
percentage completion.
Where you basically have to be the
process.
So then if if something's in there,
we've got multiple jobs in there and if
every guy's entering these in within a
few minutes of them getting it completed,
you can be at your best.
You know, hey, I just got a phone call.
Yeah, it's like we're 50% complete.
I'm trying to prime and perhaps 100%
completed.
Prime is 50% complete right now because
as soon as these guys mark this off,
it's instantly updated on.
Production in your computer version and
you can reference that immediately.
So that'll that'll save you from having a
pop on a golf cart,
run out there and physically check
exactly what's going on.
It should give you a good high level view
of.
As long as you guys are holding your guys
to, once this is done,
it's not a at the end of the day.
I'm gonna go get all these updated,
get it done.
You have a tablet right there.
You're ready to go.
I can tell you the ones that say I'll
just wait for the end of the day.
It's never right. It's never right.
So this is on the read live.
How's the how's the?
Otterbox. You swap it out.
As long as they never come around. Sure.
Yeah.
And that'll get you on there because it's
our first go around with it.
So it's still unforeseen.
I know we've got everything's covered by.
Whatever it's going to be covered nursery,
but as long as they have covered over the
screen and there's within a case,
it's going to be recycling these cases
every six months or so.
And it's a touch screen. It's an iPad,
you know, so they'll have,
they'll have the capabilities and I'm
pretty sure the one who looked at it,
that's not looked into. So yeah.
So you'll get it completely discovered at
some point and they'll they'll learn to
play. OK,
flip it over so the screen's not up or
whatever.
Maybe don't use the screen and have the
little keyboard thing so you can throw
keyboards away. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Mark can see and use the stylus here.
You have 18 hands, uses as.
So this is the main function of trying to
get you Privy to this because I'm sure
they're probably going to be having you
push this to the guys if you have any
questions or anything along.
The process of us pushing this out and
making this our set in stone goal.
Always available, Al's always available.
This is a very user-friendly interface.
So once your guys are used to the this is
where I go from this.
This is where I go from this.
There's really only two or three areas
that are logging this.
And you can use what you use.
So what does it start?
We have all of the tablets,
so it's pretty much just gonna be either
Monday next week or Friday next week.
We're gonna assign devices to people and
say.
This is what you're gonna do.
Or you can run somewhere else to look.
I'm using for a GMLSVI or no.
Don't believe so, so.
So that'll be you'll also be a a pushing
factor on this and if we need to do a
separate meeting just with me and all of
you coding guys,
once we get devices and do the sand,
we can go over that and just do a once
over and make sure everyone's on the same
page.
Um,
but pretty simple process and then kinda
tailing back into why these work packages
are super helpful. Um.
Going into here,
especially with your side,
I know they tend to have you QC things
sometimes.
So from here you can access all of your
drawings if you need.
For anything you guys are working on,
can come in here and pull up the specific
drawing file for which you need and
you'll have about everything.
So if you guys do need to reference it,
you can really.
It looks like it's up there. Yeah,
this is like,
I'll have to double check around.
It would be right.
See where it's at the latest. Yes,
there would be a PDF right under there.
Hit the drawing list and get back there.
You'll see right there to the very left,
it's blind,
but next to the 101 on the floor there
would be low PDF right there that would
not the girl.
Is that a physical link that somebody has
to set or how does that.
Yeah, yeah, essential.
So I'll make sure with all of our updates
that all of our directors are set up for
this still and that everything's where
everything needs to be because he's this
one was clearly work and Magnus is the
drive student in the work on the initial.
He probably didn't get a request to file
and it was a kiss file and they're
probably working on it in.
I can see the there and then the rev
zeros. So yeah,
it looks like some of them said your owns
are in years designed your owns.
And and the same with the dogs. Yeah, so,
so I'll take a look at this on the end.
This would be where you guys would
reference the drawings and you could pull
all that up.
We don't have any inspection set up for
for 20 stuff in here, but.
For the inspection that we did set up for
Moe while he was in here is in this
general inspection staff.
In here you can go in and test that with
paint for surface carp inspection and
this one.
We ended up doing one test one.
Essentially you're going here shop
location.
You can select use the inspector and
you'll select your job number.
You can select whatever prep system
you're doing.
You can type in your profile.
Pass or fail any specific notes.
If you end up clicking add file,
it'll generally prompt you to take a
picture.
If there if you need to fail and you
wanted to take a picture,
you could take a picture of the fail
attached to this inspection report.
And then submit this.
So this this is on record and whether it
be associated with the job number,
you can go into my inspection reports,
different job numbers and pull a report
that breaks down all the inspections for
projects,
specific projects and get that reporting
put together.
Stop.
This would be,
this would be where you would access that.
So you can always look up here and this
will bring you back to your home screen.
But this is that was kind of the the main
function that I was trying to show you
this in the future potentially they might
have us add you guys in the phone
tracking.
Um, I don't know how that's going to work.
I I don't think you guys are still using
the temp workers and whatnot and you
could add into their time differently. Uh,
all of our shop has been invested.
So do you think the temp workers should
still work or?
That being the case more likely probably
won't have you guys there in time
tracking through here.
This is that doesn't that doesn't drive
as easily down the road if we do venture
into that the time tracking module we can
go over that.
So your main functions will be projects
and work packages and you can access any
of all of what you need from there to be
able to do your piece tracking,
check production statuses and.
Yeah, I'll,
I'll take a look and see and make sure
you have a archive to go log in and sign
to be sure. But yeah,
you should be able to. Yeah, it's.
So it's not the only thing I have access
to this tech. OK, so yeah,
this this you can access right when you
go back to your desk.
You can also pull this up on your phone,
the meeting tablet as long as you have.
This domain,
then you can access that any point.
So it would be really nice to find a way
to set a filter for work packages for
these guys.
I would say sure we need a job to just
carry the stat way the organization of it
would be just to apply to them.
I mean the first thought is to the group,
the group things,
but I'm not sure how you can use the
group,
the group builders if you want to see the
group builders.
Right now, um.
The most prevalent group in there is
phone cranes because we get so many phone
crane jobs. Yeah,
we group all our phone crane jobs
together loosely.
We tend to get a lot of job numbers for
that specific customer.
So it's kind of a customer on a customer
basis.
So you're using both of these group,
those group deals, yeah, but yeah,
we must,
because otherwise if they're looking for
a problem and you didn't see all the fast
stuff that that may not apply.
So who's responsible for setting up to
make sure that codings just see?
See what coding needs to employee by
employee basis. It's just filtering.
So I guess what I'm saying is when I saw
earlier on and kind of like 101101 twice,
make sure that it only shows up once and
it's just relevant to the codings.
Work. So the PC,
the ones that control that's in this
drawing index,
and essentially with that being Rev A and
one with being Rev 0,
if there's a Rev A in there,
they cannot access that.
It'll show you know that there is a rev
in the system and it'll show drawing log
wise,
but it will only let you access the most
current.
The issue with that one I need to check
and see if if our directories are linked.
And make sure that because we have had
connection issues between our database
and ETM both the plans.
I get to call the KC inspector all the
time. Hey,
what's going on and it's between exterior
customer giving us just file doing a
different style.
The important drawings not going to be a
law appropriately or.
The directory not being set up correctly,
so we need data that isn't actually got
something to do with it.
Some of the drawings anywhere on any jobs,
every time you know they're going to see
if you see the drawings.
We we set up the global default
directories.
There was a map there I was generally not
a thing on the server.
Server and so this goes off the on the
server.
So if it's looking for a R drive on the
server,
it's really like the C drive on the
server, then it's not going to see it.
That might be something we have to fix.
Yeah, I wanted to work that.
I'll be on the, the, the,
it might be something we have to. Yeah,
this project ran all the way through.
Oh,
that's probably just one of the lines of
this Mac drive. Yeah, on the server,
probably it's not the Mac drive on the
server. Yeah, I need to use the,
I mean the full pack.
We can do it instead of our use the
computer name, slash, whatever.
So I'll make note of that so that I can
get that fixed.
And you've been signing that should be
receiving will use this as well, yes.
And then somebody sets their packages up
separately, separately.
Their portion will have nothing to do
with packages.
Their portion will be packages because
they'll be shipping some items out,
but their portion will be material
receiving as well as generating roadless
and trucking roads.
So you guys will have the tablet out
there. If a load comes in,
you can pull up the purchase order.
See what items are on the quantities.
You can mark it perceived as it comes in
and then all back to business can go in
and attach the PDS.
So you'll have your your bill of lading
and you'll say one HSS.
You'll manually type the key number in
there, click receive.
And as long as Paul has been received,
he can then attach all of those PDFS to
associate all of the seat numbers so that
we can still do our tracks.
So it'll all be preset. Yeah,
every purchase order that we issue gives
them a list of of what they're needed and
they also get which there should be some
orders now.
Will our shop paint be tracked the same
way through here?
I think they're working towards issuing
tech appeals for the paint,
but that unfortunately we haven't really
discussed.
We don't really have anything broke out
in the inventory or anything in the size
database for paint.
So that one's kind of a territory at this
point.
Talking about the track basically look
where you have it,
you know how we get down to the.
Yeah.
So we did our list of BO and duplicated
it into SEVA and then we break down the
items in there,
which is incredibly relevant for our
steel purchases because then it goes in
our inventory, past remnants and incoming.
However, with the paint portion,
there's no there's no paint specs that
broke out in there and it would almost
have to be put in there with live item.
If we don't always be getting 5 gallon
pails of this paint spec, then you can go.
5 gallon bill,
5 solids and then Frank to see Sherman
Williams and then you could go into a
purchase order,
align that bio item in there and quantify
that and say we're using 5 five gallon
pills.
Then we could do that.
But if you guys are,
you would be limited to the point of we
use 11 gallon of this,
five gallon of that,
and we have 4 gallons of there's no way
to quantify that.
I know some of your guard needs come in.
Larger side,
it's not anything that's better to know.
Yeah,
that's what what a bunch of guys doing
this,
which would be easy to be set up in shape
or something,
but what what they typically end up doing
is let's say I have.
As I pull one out of storage and bring it
into the work area,
I'm going to TFSP and so I know I've got
four in storage.
You might still have one full one that
I'm not starting using,
but you know what you got in storage
versus what happened to the loose rather
than.
Rather than having to try upshot
furniture down,
track barrel by barrel and and generally
what the rest of it. Yeah,
that's certainly something we would do
and definitely would be.
A quite simple process to do so.
So let's say that you got one piece,
there's going to be a 1010 everything.
Yep, Yep. So you can download it in.
If you got 8 and you got 12,
you just type in quantity 8 and your
vitamin will say 20,
it'll say quantity 8 and then the total
quantity goes from 12 or whatever your
difference is and then you will just go.
Go back in there and you can receive a
whole line item or you can receive a
portion of the line item that's always do
the full. Yeah,
so which I can I can show you.
I just have to confirm that you can go on
in because you're willing to do that.
We can do so.
We just need to get two lines.
That'll be a part of our it'll probably
be Friday next week.
We'll assign to everybody in the
beginning of the week.
I'll go through with our team,
get a list of guys that need to be on the
PM that don't have ways to visit signage,
and we'll get all that set up and then
try to get a discipline 105 everyone's in
the interim.
Receiving, shipping and status marking.
You guys shouldn't have to do any of that.
You guys' time tracking is your question
and everything.
So that's all that's all a separate
instance.
I think you guys aren't willing to miss
that.
So unless somebody in the management
specifically requests that they want your
time back into the in Tekla,
I would think you guys have come in.
We do our contracting in here for the
shop side because of that all kinds of
our production jobs and.
And tracking everything for hours and use
to begin some projects.
So you guys have your own separate
projects.
It wouldn't zero in a few minutes coming
entering time.
I guess everybody has their own.
We're very good. So proper wise,
they're temp employees.
We don't pay them through Vista.
They're their own separate entity.
Every other guy is pretty much salary at
that point.
It's the exception of probably Richie.
And he's manually entering his hours in
the in the Vista like most of the other
guys.
Me and Alan don't try time through Tekla.
She's pretty much the only people who are
using the time tracking in Tekla is
production employees.
I definitely think it's something that we
can have a bigger discussion and go out
and incorporated you guys.
The individuals,
because that's one thing that this does
show is all the additional types of
shipping hours that go to the labor
bucket.
These guys are Vista that actually go to
the labor bucket.
So it gives you us a portion pulling up
the Vista.
This number doesn't align with the final,
right,
with everyone else at the time or so.
I think it's where we need to go,
but currently right now when we've done
it, it's multiple systems.
We can sound like nobody here can
actually know what all the data is going
to see in four different places, right,
I guess.
Stop.
But Kendall,
I will show you what your against this
portion will look like. Yeah, I mean,
I don't see why a lot.
They'd have to be easier in there.
The question is if,
but if it's sounds like a majority of the
hours you're going with it, yeah,
the majority of the hours in the only the
only areas where it would be.
Um.
Or we create additional work.
It's adding the projects that don't ever
see production.
All the production employees are all
production jobs, shipping, receivable,
get random requests,
different oddball things where they're
just taking something in,
taking something out.
So then we would have to add all the jobs
in there so that they have the ability.
Need to track minutes.
Same thing with codings. Codings, however,
are being a little bit more prevalent
because they're trying to do the tracking.
Um shifts kind of the the the rear in
between the of that because they're
really.
Shipping over the whole day and it's not,
it's not tied to a specific job is what
I'm hearing.
It's just a false that it's just you go
spread and today you may have about six
jobs and tomorrow you may have about one
jobs.
It's just spread out over all the jobs.
Is that how it's just the overhead
accounts?
Are you guys putting in two jobs now?
Now they're going to two jobs.
Two jobs in local. Yeah,
but it's increasing.
We're talking in the last couple months.
Historically,
it was just a blanket overhead and it was
distributed to whoever that job's in
charge. I'll see you all. OK,
so for your guys unfortunate in this
inventory module.
So when you open the inventory module,
you'll have all of these options
available for you.
You guys probably haven't immediately
move or take them stock at this immediate
point.
Once Christie puts his plan together,
then we put lines in the yard and then
we've got bin locations and we've got
everything.
That's where your removal function is
going to be incredibly useful if you guys
move one project to a new radio because
if a bigger project came in and the
availability here is going to be better
and you want to move and shuffle things
around if you move something on here.
Update the inventory location when the
saw operators at the saw that inventory
location updates on their cut list and
they can see where the steel was at at
that point.
So in the future that will function will
be super helpful.
Once we have a very good plan in place
for what's going to be dedicated to
coatings,
what's going to be wear for steel,
because they are doing rows,
bins and everything,
we want everything to be very.
And so for now, the move function,
we have our old categories for what I had
originally knocked out and they are,
that's borderline relevant.
So the take from stop portion that you
guys shouldn't really have to use.
That would be more prevalent in line.
So a field guy came in,
found a six foot or 8 foot piece of
material.
He verified that he can take it and
confirmed with us that it's not allocated
to a project.
You could then go to the take and stock,
find that six foot piece.
It take from stock.
That should also give you the option to
load it onto the load or just directly
yank it out of the system,
but it's not going to tracking anymore
and they take it load it up and it's.
So,
so handling is a function that you guys
track. Who does the handling?
Is it chipping and receiving or is it
welders? It's multiple facets.
It's my saw operators picking it up from
the yard,
picking out the saw and they're
classified as handling.
And then vice versa.
If the fabric is original material into
the the the shop run on the stall,
then that's classified as happening,
but it's not the shipping perceiving also.
So that's all shop happening. It does not.
It starts to give any trouble with there
that will be applied to.
OK.
And we're usually two weeks behind Vista,
so I don't get a full synopsis of their
time until end of the month, you know,
but so you guys have a lot of guys
trained to drive for us.
It's they should agree to.
So moving on to the next category of load,
this would be we're in a free build on
load list.
You can take that load portion and
physically load the items on to the truck
against the four levels prebuilt to the
system.
So we can go in here and kind of show you.
What we have here?
So if we throw like a whole thing on one
load list,
they can then go in and add each member
as they're loading it on the truck. Yeah.
And that would that then build a separate
load list now for that? Yeah, that I mean,
that's for you.
Truck will be on the truck and there's a
check box there on the bottom left hand
corner called load on the side.
You uncheck that and the system says OK,
you created a plan.
Then they come by saying loaded,
loaded that piece, loaded that piece,
loaded that.
Now this right here is one of the in the
actual inventory of their trucks.
So that's like I said,
nobody got this for a quarter angle.
I can select that and it doesn't all,
removes the inventory of the job. Yeah,
I'm ready to be in the shipping portion
of the project to the loading.
If you if you prove what it holds like
you're talking about, which is not always.
Not always.
If you touch, yes, I'm talking late,
but it'll be something, right? But well,
you got assemblies that have wonky,
you know,
figurations and they just don't line up
the way, you know? Yep. Yeah,
they might work, but you know,
they might have some sticking out or.
Or it's too tall, so you have to pull.
But if you do that,
I highly suggest you start using the
shipping gallon here.
It's about pre-building a truck next
Friday, right?
Then I usually try everybody in the
organization and the guys at the yard to
say.
I don't care about what shift a few weeks
from the matter, but what shift tomorrow?
I see, I see the load on the calendar.
I pull it up, nothing on my list.
I'm loading it up, getting loaded, loaded,
loaded,
loaded forward and so it works off the
calendar which gives you.
A lot more information, so it's really,
really nice.
So I think if you want scheduling the
work.
I mean,
shipping is going to need to be part of
it. Yeah. I mean,
we would have such a massive backlog that
we're, you know, shipping guys everywhere.
We just didn't have the resources to all
the trucks, yeah.
So so here in the inventory in the
receiving portion of it.
This is where you see your receiver.
You can see your PO volume here.
This will reference all your POS what's
included on it and then this is where you
can you can.
On your quantities,
type in your heat number and then click
receive down below.
That will receive in four with that heat
number. And then once you do that,
the three remaining will still be up
there.
You can enter that heat number received
and then when Bob was back to Peter and
Paul, can we run?
No, you're good. So on the load side,
I I'm just going to pick from stock.
If it's not going on the list and they're
just taking it from the yard and it's
going, then take it from stock,
we'll pull it from from the inventory.
Loads where you can visibly load
inventory in the RML load and ship that
out.
Receive is where you go in and this is
where incoming steel.
You'll have transparency of that show.
And the materials that are coming in in
by purchase order and you can receive
those items in and click receive down
below.
This will be updated in real time of this
item came in.
This is the heat number and then the
operator instantly knows at the stop, hey,
this is here,
this is received in and I just need to
find out where it is and once we
establish the bin locations and the grid
line in the yard and where things are
going to be.
Then you guys can add in.
So like here you can assign your location
and then your section location and then
that'll update on the average that was in
this area and then they know.
Hey,
this just came in the availability to
folks from the Minnesota to the South or
they're going to get on the 4th.
They're going to arrive over there and
start eating that stuff behind the foot.
So do the handling guys that are the shop
guys that are moving things.
Define the location where they put things
in the system.
So if they have not done rent, not rent,
let's just say finished good comes out
back complete.
It's sitting out in the yard somewhere,
but there's.
Handling guy from the shop did it.
There's no,
there's no complete fabrication location
storage.
So how does the shipping guy know where
we go and get it?
Everything that's complete in production
before the coatings that's stationed in
the center area of the shops and anything
that is complete on the coatings.
Get staged in a completion area in the
center of the yard in the middle back.
These are saying basically you've got a
dedicated with orchid process areas for
each. Yeah,
essentially in between the two shots,
that's.
Either completion from fab and and
they're going out to the field and then
coatings and then anything that's
complete in between the steel yard,
the current steel yard and coatings is
completely ready to go along the trail.
How do you prevent addiction jobs?
Um, brief text.
I was gonna say it's the the 5 pieces,
which every you know if it's a large
sequence or coder lot, we'll do uh,
ribbon identification.
But typically we have all our data tags
that we'll have from our QC that shows
job sequence log piece mark.
And then they're going through based off
of the list that these guys put together
and you'll want for one day.
We're taking 10 piece of over.
We only get 9 and then we'll go ahead and
see if they're doing this.
I mean, the facility is small.
I'm used to working on four acres,
so I guess it doesn't really get lost
here, right? Yeah, that's not nice.
We're seeing, you know,
a piece of plate falls off the pallet and
trying to face it,
but it's black for sure.
So this inventory module,
this is the home screen.
Inventory risk is where you're going to
go for moving things,
taking things from stock, loading things,
loading raw steel onto trucks and
receiving steel.
So that will be the main governing
portion of your report job as a shipping
and receiving personnel.
In addition to that,
you'll also have this work packages
portion, work packages projects.
Anything that's pointing out of us from
the bath shop is going to have a work
package,
so that's probably a better place for you
to look and see that it's going to be
broken up in the way we format our work
packages to how we want it to come out of
production and the way it comes out of
production is how we want it shipped.
So that would be your best reference is
to go into work packages.
Have we shipped every loads for the
landowner yet? No,
we have to watch it a month. OK,
so I'll hold them now because I prebuilt
all of the loads for that one.
So we have all of our work packages in
here.
You'll click into your sequence and then
down here in your shipping category is
where you can reference.
Anything associated for build loads in
this.
So we can see here that we've got one
load, load 19 that's not started yet.
We can click into this load and this
would be where you can make the
designation of.
Removing adding additional that are in
blood, but unless we're in blue.
Then you just check which ones you can
load. OK,
so here or if you needed to remove it
from the load because some items not
gonna fit.
If you remove this from the load because
it's not gonna fit,
my computer will update with what didn't
ship.
And then when you guys mark the ship,
it updates everything and we'll put it
back and I can reassign it to a new load
and then we can have a transparent
tracking of what went out,
what didn't go out and what's where. Well,
I'm going to send a lot.
It's like you know some piece of that
ship right? Where the hell is that?
And you're looking for B none.
Hit the little heartbeat symbol over
there, whatever that symbol is.
That tells you all the stations as
opposed to builders.
So you have this building to see. OK,
well, everything's been fed up.
Two of them have been welded.
You know exactly where to get it figured
out. Yeah, this has got **** tomorrow.
Is it going to get done or not? You know,
if you run the whole shop,
you can kind of at this same time that
you're trying to find the calories like
any.
Looking for because it could be a W 8 by
28 with three clips or with five clips.
So you're then just reference. Well,
I'm just saying it's the shipping guys
are always told to go load the trucks,
but unless the order is consolidated by
somebody that either dedicates an area or
whatever, the shipping guys don't.
There's so much that you guys are moving.
But they don't really know exactly what
the piece looks like.
There's lots of pieces that look really
similar.
So and then you get the model piece on
the wrong trucks. I mean,
I see that just happened more than I'd
like to. Yeah, these parts.
Yeah,
that'd be another area where these work
packages are really helpful is if they're
in here and they're trying to look at
everything.
Once I figure out why are the lines
connected at this point,
I'll get to the bottom of that before the
end of this week.
But they can always pull this up and have
a very clear reference.
I'm looking for a B5,
I'll shoot at 60 foot long.
This thing should stand out.
So I'm up here and then.
And then they can go right back to their
shipping and and then go back into their
globe. OK, Yep,
I have B9 and and this will show the
length,
but it's only going to show the length of
the main number. So if the main.
Member is spliced with the subpart to add
to your total length.
That might not always be the exact. Yeah,
so. So that is.
Helpful to a certain sense,
but once you start getting on the really
big stuff,
unless the main member is specifically
detailed out as that full length and we
run it as a splice package in here,
we keep that raw length the folio for
this one.
The detail package anticipated a spice,
so the main number was actually a sub
portion of your full length.
So there is a way for us to leave a main
number at a full length and create a
spice package and slice the parts
together and keep that main number length
that way.
So it won't always be like this. So,
so it'll be project by project basis,
but then your.
Best reference is gonna be referencing so
which you can pull up all these different
things.
You guys will have visibility tunes in
here and and you guys can see by area of
work and everything.
What's required drawings and you can go.
Back to your.
Back to your overview, assemblies,
material status,
shipping status and let's see what they.
Dashboards.
I'm gonna go to our shipping calendar.
This is what Ricky was referencing
earlier. Whenever we recreate globe lists,
we have all of them on here.
So all of the line number ones I had on
here and then once we figured out Chad
made a seat request to have all 327 tons
delivered in one week.
I grabbed them,
dragged them into the new day because
they're already built in there.
Everything's where it needed to be.
So I just started dragging, reorganizing.
But if you guys are in here and you know
something's not going to ship.
If this bring the bring the level up,
hit the paint bug and bring up the legend.
So the orange ones are in progress.
Blue is essential,
but you can see the 0% at the bottom.
That's 0% says pieces that are planned
for that. Nothing's been loaded yet.
So whereas the orange one there is 100%
loaded and then you got green,
which is it's already shipped in red that
was supposed to ship.
For some reason.
So that's why I didn't mark it though.
So and then from here,
you know tomorrow's the 12,
everything's scheduled,
nothing's been loaded,
nothing's been confirmed.
You can go in here, reschedule.
Push the Saturday if you needed to push
it to Monday and then if you go in here,
this will populate back down here and and
then the the visibility will all be there
for for everybody involved on or do it
the sexy way, but not there to be great.
And it said, it's right,
who's allowed to be study?
Up the issue.
Thank you.
So.
Yeah, it's something like that.
And that would be just the process.
So this would be nice for.
I don't know how you get communication.
Hey, what's going on tomorrow?
What's going on the next day?
What's going on Monday?
This,
this will be a good communication home
for that. You know exactly what it is,
what it's supposed to do.
How do the field guys know what's coming?
They use this calendar.
OK.
So on this specifically we'll set up
during our kickoff,
we schedule the current date that was
expected by the build forwarder customer.
If there are any changes,
the build foreman or project manager for
that job will reach out between the
shipping manager and the customer.
Um, it accelerates it. Of course,
we have to make sure that we're on par
with that together.
Are they talking to you,
the field construction guy?
Like if we're still at the back,
talking to you,
they'll they'll talk to Paul to schedule
push,
but if it's an accelerated adjustment
forward or inward,
then they'll communicate with us to see
if we need a wrap for him.
9 times out of 10 recently,
if they just communicate with Paul,
I hit our original schedule.
If you pushed it out, you know my point,
did I make the suggestion?
These guys are just in the demo,
but you're you know what you know.
You're quick.
Their their heads spilled around.
What's your question? You know,
that's what I said should question.
Yeah, that's great.
Yeah,
it's most people are kind of like me,
a listing my hands,
like I can watch you do it. And I'm like,
OK, let me play that and then I'll,
I'll get it right, you know,
so it might be. So you say you get it.
So.
Yes.
Security number.
Right.
So.
And then I will get you.
I'll make sure that you have.
And probably going to see when you give
me all set up this.
See if it was.
It says it's not like the next.
My best.
So see this.
I can use one that's came today.
I don't need support.
No, I am an Android guy.
Yeah, it was testy things, super helpful,
but it was really long when I got an
iPhone. Yeah,
it was absolutely the bane of my
existence.
I have.
I have the current PDA on the left side
of the username and password and that's
it. So yeah,
I actually have never turned it on.
I think it was white parent off.
So now you're in my.
So that's what you're going to be like
when you get in there inventory.
And we'll see.
So here you can go to your job number.
You can Scroll down.
I got it's like it's hilarious. Well,
you got you got.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it's filter and value list if you type
them. Yeah. What's that?
That'd be that'd be the job, right? Yeah.
So now, now that you have your filter set,
you need the accident filter.
You'll see right there that's cleaning,
right?
Unless you want your invention or any
other information.
If you want to start the DOW,
you can raise that.
I'm not sure what, but yeah, no,
it was just like the guys that are
painting.
And then push your key. See that back.
If you were to receive the four or 5-10
line items and they were all going to say,
well,
let's say build blanket and you could hit
build blanket here that doesn't offer two
line items rather than you have to type
10 different items.
So see the same material comes in and it
has the same sign.
Just go ahead and automatically put that
already in there. So when I locked in,
I just pushed that and it goes to there.
Yeah, you would.
You would just selected all the line
items,
put your heat number in because they're
unique for a lot, yeah.
And then when you come to batch in it,
get the build blade and get the build
blade here rather than on each line line.
OK.
And that does it for all the lot of those
shares.
So and then I can switch that up every
time. Yep, Yep.
And then now it's slow down receipt.
Those is gone.
They don't hear the like if you have a PO
part of what you see today,
then when you come back in tomorrow,
they're see what's left.
That's it. Yep.
And then when they're down the line,
once we figure out the movie and all that,
then we'll be important to detail on that.
Yeah.
Once you guys start getting deeper into
that,
then you can go into your move tab and
then implement it in here.
We can go ahead and make an update.
Locations.
So here's the I believe that the bottom
is at the moment and the missing label.
Just your location, your section location.
So in that same receiving portion,
you'll be able to assign the location.
So if you already know and we got,
we got all that steel,
it's going to go right here.
Here's my bin, here's my section.
You can go in, receive it,
and it'll go right into that portion.
You know that's not going to be in the
boom, so if you can't do it,
nothing like that.
Right now we don't have big rock out on
there. So for any of this, all right,
I started using that. Oh yeah,
we're all obviously along with yourself.
I got to get him logging.
So early part of next week plans to get
tablets to all the questions that we
needed and by Friday of next week I'm
going to take a list of who has EPM bill
logins and purchasing the license.
That's the average.
The trick reports can be clonings because
they're kind of personal.
They don't have to do like we did with
the shop originally,
but when we got to D3 create an e-mail
for them and then give them their
audience still.
So that's what we learned now.
So low portion is where you would load
material that's in the yard or somebody
had a wall and stick or say somebody
would call him and go ahead and shipping
or or just load it.
So let's take a line for example.
You have that one load that we're looking
at really that still has to go.
I need a 8 by 8 by half. You go in there,
you filter for 8 by 1/2 and you go,
actually there's a 15 foot piece out here
with that work. You can go in there,
grab the.
That piece and added to that list right
back there.
So when you're gonna ship out that load,
you have load built and it's an admin. OK,
that's what that portion's for.
I'll be using this as well too. Yeah,
yeah,
that'll be in in instances where the
field guys, hey, I need this.
That's what you would do.
So that's taking it out of our stock and
putting it up for the months. OK,
the stock portion here,
that's where I feel that comes in.
I need the six foot run here in our
convention system.
So if it's under 6 foot,
it's very good scrap.
And they don't have to be allowed,
they just want to take it.
You can look in there,
see what jobs associated with CDD number
jobs, see that it's available as a budget.
You can grab that,
remove it from the system and send them
on board.
OK.
And then I'm going to say the power
received is for bothering the building.
It's been received outside. Yeah,
so since it's been received all the
building there now,
scanning is on the PR number and the dash.
OK,
so what the nice thing about this is what
should be happening with this is if if
you get calls all day about, hey,
we received this, can we get that,
tell them to shut up and you're looking
in the system because you updated, right?
Yeah, I mean, and honestly,
that's the way it should happen.
This should be the communication told to
everybody.
They shouldn't have to come to you to
figure that out, right? Look, you know,
so by the time they call,
we will get around to your day.
They could have figured it out, right?
Yeah.
So that's really what should be happening.
So it should be our helping guide with it
being real time.
It's as soon as you click enter on that
his purchase order in there no longer.
And he can pull that.
I've shown him how to pull the overview
material or expected material.
He can repull that expected material
report for the day if he'd like.
Because everyone's interested. OK,
so but then from here for you to go to,
put it right on your name and packages
and then go down and then I just said
it's.
Yeah,
so right there you have the same
transparency of the filters.
You got to flip my job number,
filter my work pack,
my job number and then get yourself down
to this is what I know I have to what
I've been told shipping this day and then
you can get to work.
I think here we go.
If you have the excellent filter portion,
say you just one right in the first one,
2.0661, that's sitting in your home loop.
Yeah, those are already 100% production.
So I think put in the new portion there.
That'll bring you into this one, yeah,
and we click on. Yeah, yeah, I know that.
I'm going to.
This will bring you into the main page of
that. So you can see what's coming.
As you Scroll down,
you see those options will.
Top take you to tabs of portion in there.
So you'll be in that shipping with the
portion of the bottom.
So if you click on that,
then it'll take you to the shipping
portion and you'll see for that work
package.
What's been planned?
That's already shipped, you already know.
And if you put that little block on the
cluster to the set shipped,
that'll give you a breakdown of what's on
them.
So there's 66 pieces that are on that
envelope already shipped. Let me see.
OK. If you hit the blue, the blue,
you'll take the end of what you need to
see. That's all. If you have permissions,
you can unshift it.
It unloaded pieces,
new piece and all in all,
whatever you need, but that was shared.
But yeah, they're loaded pieces. Yeah, so.
So as long as we prebuilt to load.
Then you can take this tablet out there
and these are your items you're looking
for as you confirm them and you guys are
pulling them to your staging areas so you
can build your load.
Then as you build your load, load it,
load it, load it. Oh so I do that.
I don't know if you can do that rather.
You're in the dashboards.
We'll go to the calendar because you're
on the area and the calendar. Shipping.
Yeah,
and you'll see what we were looking at on
screen.
We might be formatting a little bit
positive.
Scroll down to the.
Today or the next day. There we go.
There should be loadings.
So like that one is not loaded,
you can get the three dots on it and then
we can get all the details, yeah.
So now you got the list the the real it
says it hasn't been loaded again.
So if if you're like OK and you're
loading that and you come back and you'll
get that loading button.
Now you got a check box and you're just
checking one section loaded.
So just check one.
We will let you be able to check
something.
And then see that you load selected.
So you just as you get uploaded you can
just check that off and load it selected.
Now the system knows you loaded it.
It's not just a plan anymore,
you're loading it correct.
So let's see for instance.
So say you already got to go.
So the day I go to load it is on.
And I know all my quantities are there,
then I go through and select everything
and then Chris, I load selected.
That's up. You guys need to do that.
I I usually suggest that as a standing
loader,
like if you load 5 pieces of that and
then you come back later in the day,
you load another five.
I probably won't see.
That as it's happening,
because I just know that most of the time
when I go someplace and it's like, OK,
I got everything loaded,
what people end up doing,
they end up saying, yeah, sure,
everything's loaded and they do that and
everything and they're they're not
checking it piece by piece or whatever,
you know?
And and then you just screwed up. Yeah.
So I think it was normally coming out.
I'm checking there because it's coming
out one of these in my piece and then as
you go to the abstract,
it's either get painted or rebuildings
for its whole being.
As we heard this case may be, yeah,
but some basically do when it gets low.
To get shipped out. Yeah, it it it.
Are you building the load on the ground
then it's then it's starting up on the
truck.
So some people that you guys have to sign
this,
this that's the way we do the shop
housing that right there will be insured
as.
The loaded as it was built on the ground,
their little truck gave you toothpicks
were on the truck and and it's gone.
Then we get shipped.
So you guys got to even decide how you
want to do that.
So everybody knows what does the loaded
mean?
Does it mean it's physically on the truck
or does that mean it's built?
On the ground, yeah. So for us, our,
our definition shot I was in loaded was
that loaded built on the ground.
I have a loaded all the gamer is ready to
get. So yeah,
that's probably the best way to do it
because then as you go, they're.
And you're putting the rows of the rows.
You can go through that list and then you
have two of them between this row,
throw some more numbers down,
start on the next row,
those two are there,
those two are there working down your
list as you're building your load and
then you have that marked off,
you know your quantities are good and
then when you ship it.
****, put it in the truck.
Yeah. So it's the first time you do it.
I would recommend you walk through. OK.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
No, I'm always here to,
I'm always here to help with everything.
That's what what can be nice since you're
able to flip back and forth between
shipping stuff and receiving stuff.
Some people will do this still come down
here and so like all the inventory that
the perceiving.
And if you hold down and say open in
either new window, let's see, yeah,
probably tab group.
It's just.
So you can do it this way and flip them
back and forth. Yeah, you just.
I wanted it as enough.
What's the screen on my? That's my my.
Yeah, exactly. Well,
that's so many of the things in your
gesture argument, David. I couldn't.
I couldn't put an exclamation point at
the end of my freaking password because
you click the button and swipe down Dale
to add the toxic.
I got two different screens here.
Oh, I interesting.
That way you don't have to get out of the
shipping to go into receiving,
then get out of receiving.
When you go back in the shipping,
have one for one, one for the other.
We just went back and forth between the
two pads.
So I had hit a long hold on it and then I
hit.
That time track, the second one tabs.
Yeah. So you're not having trouble.
I I watch somebody just using it and it's
like you're not having trouble.
You're you're not scared to move around.
Other people are like steered touching
and then we want to touch, you know,
you know, messed up.
Anything can be fixed. So yeah.
I was waiting on the.
That's a that's a. Is that correct? Yeah.
No, it's the actual. I want to sit down.
I used to. I used to make.
I'll be able to you can to deal with the
relationship in the area you're going
with. It's something I used to have.
There's like a little working with with
my other half.
They'll do all of that and then get a
little warming to show up.
Do you want to stay logged to your team
and still do you? Yeah, do it or yeah,
you don't really need too much.
You can you can write it in the classroom.
The design you stay in modules.
Now you go in and you start marking a
bunch of **** out in production and then
we're gonna load all this stuff.
I cannot do it. You get it. You get it.
You get it.
Permission on the computer and everyone's
permission on.
So the only thing I don't think I can
create profiles for VPM at all.
It's user by user basis,
but I can copy VPM locally.
Commissions across users. So,
so how do I get this?
So is that there were anything from it?
There was a trimble in there,
one of the tabs was trimbled,
so I just went in there and logged in
with my pass to go.
So but if you want to add it into your
bookmarks and stuff.
On the Android guide,
so it should be here. I mean,
moving on Mark's territory with that one.
Too much.
Wow.
I'll be right for watching that.
OK, one of these.
Oh, I guess is there a share button? Yeah,
that.
And if you want to retrieve it and go see
if it's I I don't like that.
We we try to get the.
They basically buy it for 100 for 100
bucks. Yeah, for 100 bucks and uh.
They said, oh, we can't secure that.
You know,
we had everything like out security app
and all that stuff.
They bought 350 tablets last month.
They put it on the social media. Wow.
I was like,
why are you grabbing about that stupid
thing?
Maybe, by the way,
this was for you at some point.
You're gonna accidentally get that yellow
pad and see it change the view.
This is like an old view of the Android
screen. It sucks. It's that.
Just get that.
I think that if we get screwed up. Yeah,
cool.
No, they won't move. So. But yeah,
somebody will get that. And the old view,
the old way the inventory was there.
So we can have this display in Spanish,
right? Yeah, sure can. Yeah.
Yeah, that should be good.
We want you to work on the long use
screen.
Anything on Gavin to walk through you?
Yeah, on everything.
There's something like back and forth
communication.
I probably can build on you in this,
I'll be in it.
But we'll try to,
I don't think it's going to happen. Yeah,
when I saw it, I'm not going to. Yeah,
because the kids,
we're not really sure you all over time.
It's what I need.
We'll kind of connect you basically then
we should be accessible.
Now the next time you should run through,
you can go over the process flow.
This is what came in.
I'm gonna put up with mentioning you get
them on.
Tell him to **** himself when we're going
through this map,
so we'll go through it and get it down to
OT and keep that process going.
So I'm going to make us more efficient.
So we're going to need you to do that.
Yeah, I don't want to work in the bank.
What's recent? What do you do?
You're all set. So.
We can go over and see if he has any
questions, but I think you're involved.
So thank you. I appreciate you. Thank you.
First thing in the process.
Alright, so I didn't.
So my guys go to production tracking.
So we're going to put in here,
but there's time to do it.
So you're spring one up in there,
moving with one front and then match.
And then from there they would get start
and stop.
So so that how will that start and stop
will be this entire from B1 all the way
to C3, correct? Yep.
So I want to separate those out saying
they'll they only have B1 BG.
So if they only have B1B2B3,
then just select B1B2330. Yeah,
that's something that you can do.
Your start stop is already reply
whichever feature you have selected.
Which actually we go batch time and then
should be here.
Is this is for individual to be added in
our minutes individually?
You want to if you want to just so if you
needed um.
Just start there, right?
And then if you wanted, I get this,
you can say one there, right? Whoops,
I have two. It's all.
And then we'll get down.
We'll do B2 as well.
And just there there shouldn't be all
there's some work.
It'd be easier for that, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and then if you go back up to the top,
whenever you're done in your spot,
when when you get an update,
that time will apply to this free piece.
It's kind of cool. We used to it on,
but I I've just that you move your
patterns up and then I'll have you.
So and so I'll update that. Sure.
So I think your time you're working on
those pieces.
You know, and a lot of times,
like as we're sending out shop releases,
there's usually one word package or maybe
two word packages that's up and that'll
be priority.
So in a lot of times the the that we do
for the yeah,
we'll have a job number and all the
durations work out.
So packages probably be your best.
So it's only that one's nice doesn't have
a huge.
Once we're starting the shelf job,
we're going to have over 100 and they're
planning running on the additional shelf
packages for TSM three through that most
of those will be coded only imported.
But for the stuff that's coming out of
production,
I'm going to have a work package.
You look back at you guys in my order is
that in this one is only fine.
Yeah,
I wanted to take a look at that because I
see that when you're looking down,
I got to mess up the browse and make sure
the riding is going to use the one of the
or.
Maybe not when we started working on it,
but I think that that would be there
since those aren't tied to setting up the
station or deleting a thing.
It's just a piece tracking side and add
it to take it away at any time and it's
not going to affect anything.
Don't have a cut saw in there and cutless
is cut and then cut saw.
That's going to make things better than I
have to working on the East traffic
stations. Oh, sorry, yeah, that's the.
They don't want to be needed,
unless they want to see just how there's
things you do in that's private.
Everything we do that we've been doing so
much.
I'll go look at that because right now
I'm pretty sure all EPM users have.
I've been finding profiles for Powerfab.
Yeah, EPM.
It's pretty cut and dry as we started
getting this roll out.
I almost got the.
Start, stop.
We go through the process of this is.
Once you guys are done,
give me a call or run out there and we'll
mark the maps completed.
We do that two to three,
five times depending on the guy will be
second nature.
So and then we'll all be. So,
rock and roll.
I appreciate you taking the time out of
Dana. So if you have any questions,
we can come this call and then once we
get into the overall situation,
maybe Paul will go through it.
Thanks again.
Yes.
Those guys are required in general at all.
Yeah, and they should.
I'll be surprised that they'll call me
the first time. I'll be second nature.
That that seemed kind of eager to want it
and do it. So it's just good. Well,
and and I've shown it to them a few times
in the capabilities, you know, it'll be,
yeah,
and they just haven't had the tools
available. Yeah, I'll follow them.
I know that would be a challenge,
but considering some with the need out
there,
but we're going to do on the board list,
we're going to do salt scooters or ice
packs.
We have three waters everywhere and then
like I was saying in the shop,
we're going to buy that.
Beverage and just modifying the paperwork.
Yeah, yeah, so they take one.
I'll make sure Kristin, Mark,
that's the new conscious integration.
So I'm waiting for this time to add the
additional modules that we don't have
currently.
I asked if he did not have the comment on
the cutting against cutting, you know,
another CLC array,
a few different things in there, so.
Once he adds those modules to my quote,
then we can get that push through.
It's a credit card order,
which one it says the original quote
without the additional log rules is about
50 grand.
So we're gonna add, we'll have that much.
How big is your? What's yours? Well,
100K units of 35K, right?
You can call the number on the back and
use the falls address. ****. OK.
And uh, you can teach up your,
your balance.
OK. I know it was like 35,000, yeah.
So you can, we can figure that out too.
We can just, we have to install,
have all my phone read and off. OK, yeah.
But it's going to be like,
I think more for 20. No,
my guess is probably 17 would be 18 as
well 14,
but that's also was more than stating our
maintenance plan with them because our
maintenance plan has been down since.
First to be here,
so I'm so we're going to be put the
maintenance plan on there so that we have
steady support. We don't.
What's he got?
So we're not loading up the scope for
like ITR level code as well or so we're
plugging and building some projects.
So she says just for now she'll so OK,
Yep,
we'll do a roll out on that and it will
be the same thing.
You just call us there. Yep. Yeah,
reporting. Yeah, I mean, computer.
Two things I mean,
at least about 4 minutes or something.
So I would hear you, but it's very much.
And then since like the audience is oh,
it's the only emails when we need to like
Jarrod's inbox and in the chat it is.
And then you and me. It just gets lost.
You and me. You and me.
And I don't like to do about this.
So what I do is I send an e-mail and I'll
call next day.
It's.
But that's the only thing that's a little
bit more usable.
So as far as what's the process going to
be,
are you going to re get the loads for
them or what's the so?
Most of them we do,
because a lot of our projects are kind of
a bit smaller. Yeah, there's OK one,
maybe 10 loads. Yep. No,
you're not really looking for that
assemblies are really good.
I think it's probably that time shopping
there. I do obviously get the drawings.
And go and adjust it.
You want to be independent on it.
So most of them say you know I have to
talk to them and then, yeah,
they're getting like smart sheets or all
their stuff because they have plenty of
field programs.
I don't know who's still getting used to
that. Yeah, I work at it. So it's kind of,
it's kind of.
And that's what I've just done. Yeah.
Yeah. So I think,
so there's that's something like 3
minutes.
So you just walk across the calendars all
the time.
I guess I'll go up there early next week.
So we can we can just reschedule it and
it's OK.
All right.
Yeah. So, so with the process integration,
I'm hoping to get that,
that updates today and I'm going to not
submission as as I did for training today.
So we can kind of listen to what that
process entails.
So I'm guessing a brand new member of IT
because it's gotta be something that's
attached to the server because I know our
pronis is currently posted on our
domestic computer. Yeah,
and so that'll the placement in the
process.
The nice part is that I'm pretty sure
even the plug in if you want the
integrations,
you activate Cronus integration and just
link it too.
They should set that up for you hopefully
cause it.
The product integration is a little bit
complex.
It's got a there's a lot of segments you
got to set up in there.
Some of the integrations in there you
just say turn on and they just there's a
little bit complex,
but like go into go back into the desktop
version and go into a production control
job and.
Like go like you're going to go nest some
plate here. Oh,
and then you'll click nest with Pro Nest
and then it'll generate a file and just
keep that into my program. Yeah, exactly.
Yeah. So when you do that,
you choose Pro Nest integration on that
optimizations.
And it spits out the file,
it gets into progress,
and then it it does everything from there
pretty much.
Your plate inventory will then be
controlled by Prodisk, which is nice too.
You you'd have to do it before there's
like the nesting stage,
so you want to get combined is where you
want to go.
Good.
Optimizations and out out there and plate
nesting settings.
So there where it says take the power
fabs you would have. Yeah, yeah,
it used to be still projects and now it's
the same way. OK,
now it's when we have our 5 second
machine.
Projects program.
It gives land tech provides. Yes,
I love the machine.
And steel projects has equally the same
terrible.
Yeah,
and we always had the trouble with bicep
bone was different.
It's your projects point bicep.
I don't care. OK,
you got to figure that out.
If somebody takes somebody, make this.
Yeah, frustrated on me.
That that would be nice to be done and
and then we'll see them a scale of
excellence.
I know we don't know each other.
And I'll meet you mine.
We need to reply to the shots and have
that view the snooze, the promise,
play modules also,
that we can start pulling in that.
OK. And now with the added modules,
we'll be able to nest a little bit more
efficiently.
So without that common ground cut and
without the horses cut,
this company has ever missed.
You got this much space in the apartment.
It's like a square. Yeah, yeah, yeah,
I can't these run on a common line,
but I want to go one time and myself
prepare from both ends. Yeah, yeah, so.
But not bad. So yeah, get that.
I'm trying to get that to the day.
So we just we know that updated code,
we'll get that order and hopefully we can
get that that interface pushed through
for tomorrow. Yeah. And then we can do it.
Yeah, so.
I'm good. It's always. Yeah, I'm going to.
That's saying Alan is to verify too
because I'm going to take one is 35K in
London.
Yeah,
Joe had like 100K and now he's doing like
75K. Oh wow, something like that.
And I don't even get it.
But we have to max their **** out every
month, physically say,
and where they're buying ticket trucks
and credit companies can walk into the
Ford dealership.
I should put it on last night.
Did he get the updated price for the
bottles? I don't think so.
That was a good bridge though. Yeah,
it's like I'm hanging.
I'm putting a lot on ready.
You.
But you'll see that a lot of reports,
the last spreadsheets and how it is about
that reflect.
And does Nina appear to be working with
it for your faith back,
but between my money. Yeah,
this is a community project.
You just have fun, dude. Yeah,
I respond to being directly.
That's why I just wanted to,
since you have that question. Yeah,
it will be.
It's right now in the Christmas gifts
when we talk, it feels the next student.
All right.
So through this plate integration
discussion,
not really too much that can be done.
I'll have to go to one discussion if we
get not really able to.
He's like, Jeff. Oh, Chuck.
If they just see. So yeah,
I guess we'll be like, yeah,
we thought I was. Oh, yeah.
So I would like to see the electrical
verifies. Yeah, yeah,
right around there's not too much.
We can just talk to here and take a look
at our files and see what we can hear
about the codings. Oh,
that's like white coding.
How are your use of the work packages?
Are they close to that or do you have any
questions?
There's a couple in there that are
closing out.
Bug condition. Uh, you can see him.
You can see him in there. Um, it's.
OK.
Right.
They won't be weak. I think it's coming.
I'm not closing up or go back up to your
filter.
Um.
There should be, yeah.
Well, you just built it for a while.
Let's complete it.
Go back into the desktop and see some of
that. Do the maintenance,
production control and work packages.
I have. I have still goes in. Some jobs.
Absolutely other jobs.
Basically,
obviously all the work I can use.
So depository, yeah,
completed required here,
start dropping on the button.
I don't know what that the CPU is,
but it will be back. I know it's going to.
It's still bugging me that they move that
everything I have.
OK, so yeah.
See the Dashboard Productivity station.
Hit the little arrow.
I don't know if I talked about this.
So, all right,
so you got to say I hit the drop down.
So you can. So this is whether it should,
whether it's complete. Yeah.
So right now you got to say if the last
station is completed and you can key on
whatever, whichever.
So that's why it's it's going on the last
station.
OK, now that will.
With the with including paint that'll
include. OK,
so the last thing is done and they will
forgive it. OK,
I was just curious how that's going about.
So you would probably want to make sure
all the new ones that that we need are
the same one that you know. Yeah,
and some of those probably are affected
with the changes we've made in the route
because nonetheless,
I guess it shouldn't be that way.
If they were completed and then we
adjusted the routes,
so now that the last there's an added
last route, would that reopen it then?
So at the beginning, yes.
So that's probably why we added it to a
typical production. You know,
every single one of the packages went
down and not completed anymore.
So you're mainly closing the,
you're right.
Cause yeah,
that would be the that would be the kick
for that announcement.
So in some of these obviously they're
great to leave cause for a while they're
20/20/21 when we were pretty green on the.
On the mounting and everything,
we were making her up for a job. I'm like.
This is we're trying to figure out along
the way if you made all this junk and we
don't want clean it up.
It's like at least with this one.
I don't think if I wanted to delete the
straw that was on a project,
it's going to take a while off of that
item.
And that's what each project we had there.
Yes, for sure. So yeah, a little,
a little less of a struggle than some of
the energy areas.
So I'm worried about that, but for sure.
This one,
this will be do use on a couple of ones
which I could probably just change into a
complex route.
The only difference with this is it has a
a fit up one,
a fit up to a well one and a well type
here.
So we had seconds first and second stage
moment on that complex problems for that.
Yep.
This one I can probably just switch to.
He's gonna be help business counselor.
Yeah, actually following the same thing.
That's one of the business part.
Jacob still. Oh, Jacob. Jacob.
It's right behind me. Jacob was like.
Yeah, for some reason it's not.
OK.
Oh, did you try that? Um.
A little program to finalize all the
stuff. Yeah,
it did not open up my computer.
It wasn't going to be there,
but I I e-mailed a guy like I said the
the not the researcher sent me an e-mail
last night that said here's.
I haven't looked at it.
I don't know what solution we did either.
Yeah, it didn't work. He he said it.
I think it was.
84 million years or so that even to be
done. It took 10 hours for it to do.
They said on a regular computer,
it took about 6 seconds per per.
OK.
I think it's true.
We cannot make this necessarily.
I thought that that was different.
Hopefully that's only in one.
That's the easy fix.
This one's on the other one,
so I'm going to be going again.
Thank you.
All I have is e-mail.
I.
OK.
Yeah.
Goodbye.
Straight to.
Here are the objects.
Yes.
You were asking me about.
You were asking about the wheels coming
in, right?
Is that you and I talked about that
yesterday? Yeah,
for like the the base hour probably in
the project sticking or oh, the kiss file.
Yeah, how it's coming in. Yep, Yep, Yep.
And being able to toggle that off.
Yeah, I just thought so.
I had fixed that in in a specific way.
There's no way to turn it off,
but you can set it so that when it comes
in, it gives you no time. OK,
you want that? You want to look at that?
Yeah, let's check it out.
I listen the day in my existence on
customers. Yeah,
I did this but I'm one thing with a
client. If you go up to maintenance,
estimating labor, maintenance and Weld.
And then go to like um.
Fill it well, manual,
well go to the drop down to top well
maintenance drop down and then well type
maintenance.
And now it will feel well manual.
Number six there,
you see the well pipe mapping down there
in the bottom right hand corner when
you're importing.
That is the nomenclature for the specific
types of the welds within what the what
you're reporting and and so it says cool
if I see Andrew Weld as an example, cool,
we're going to make that feel well manual
so that it changes it feel well manual.
So what I've done is I'll create another
type here with with your rates or
anything. Take all these well type nacks,
put it in the no well things so that when
they come in it has no rates to apply to
it now.
I've done that with importing an IFC.
I'm assuming that his file works the same,
but I'm not. I'm not 100% positive.
We just have to try it and see. OK,
but you follow what I'm saying? Yes.
Do you want to try it? Yeah, let's do it.
So then just do a new one and create
whatever you want to call it where you
want to call.
Whale or whatever.
By the way,
you see that convert wind length exceeds.
By the way,
that is newly paint as well 2025 I.
Basically you can set it to say if I have
a will this.
20 feet, then converted to sun arc.
So that's kind of, yeah.
So it's they kind of built it for like if
I'm doing built up plate girders or
something like that or box columns and
I've got a longitude swell.
So I don't want to do it.
I want to do some work, you know,
or something like that.
So that's what that's for.
So add that and then we will then go back
to like fill it well manual.
Cut all of those out of weld type mapping
and then save this here.
Then we'll go back over and we'll paste
that in in the no weld and it's going to
be several other places throughout here
as well.
So you'll have to go back to like,
but I think they're all in the manuals.
Go to **** Weld manual. Yes,
you can grab all that.
Yeah.
Is.
Penetration. Well, I've been planning.
So what,
you're just getting files from the
customer that has all this already filled
out? Yeah,
essentially they'll supply us the kiss
file and and it'll all show up in the
estimate extra,
which you have to run line by line,
part by part, assembly by assembly.
And and majority of the time,
I mean it doesn't have any connotation to
it to what it could potentially go to.
You could go through and and do a full
well take offline in the lower case.
The total inch of the welding here makes
sense.
But lots of times they'll have like a
16th of Weld and they'll have a weird
size of Weld and it won't come in.
So it'll be a 0 size fillet and then a
bunch of inches or it'll be like a one
inch fillet and then it'll be.
Like 300 of them and one inch long and it
just doesn't even justify to what you're
trying to build.
So it doesn't always be recognized
properly and then also just adds a lot of
time and I'm even going to do our labor
codes.
And run this through the way I'm going
through and it has time.
I've never seen a detailer yet get all
the wheels right in the model.
I mean most of the jobs that I see come
through like on a.
Like a sheer pad,
I'll see one-on-one side,
not the other side.
And it's like I've got half the wheel
that's worse than than not having
anything at all because I can apply that
to the labor case. So yeah,
I I like ignoring the wheels if I can.
Just makes no sales.
So how long does it take to go through
and apply wells correctly, everyone?
I need a project.
You got it depends on the project.
It it's it's relatively easy to do, well,
especially if you're going to manual take
off because you're going to apply the
labor can be repeated as you go through,
but it's not difficult at all to do if
you.
Because you can globally add it,
you like pick all the sheer tabs.
If I can identify all the sheer tabs and
then say apply one code to that,
it's just a Y code which applies what is
along the length of the plate.
So it's not difficult to do as long as
you can identify the pieces.
If I can't identify the pieces,
now I got a problem.
I don't know what what what to apply so
you start getting involved.
It's definitely this.
This one's not a gas,
so actually we need to drive fine.
Where you've got all sections,
you've got CJP's, PJP's.
We got this one's a pretty sure's 14.
50 and he was getting involved in two
meetings. We get close,
but we don't have any fill seconds that
are going to capture this.
This gap in here are the amount of passes
required.
So a lot of times all the labor code to
get the fitment hours in there and then
some of the well hours and I'll add the
extras to account for the additional well.
Additional time.
This is the one where I had to add
heating and plates because we have 3 inch
plates even rolling in the flanges.
So we have BDDS and this one is probably
3040 units of drawing and this is at 5
more wood. But you can build that.
I mean in fact there's a labor code for
the weld.
Is that the what M code I think it is for
the plate because that that's for the
four beam wheel.
Now there's nothing that says whether
it's a single bem or double bem,
but I'm you could be on that.
But there is a labor code to put the
welding boat there,
the pre lead or something like that can
be built into it as well.
I've kind of built it in with um.
With all all the plate labor codes to
where I'll have preheat in there for any,
maybe other for a certain size,
certain size,
of course she's kind of preheat just for
setting it out to be hard,
but but all that can be built in without
you having to do it manually, so yeah.
And then you have to find that piece by
piece. If you're, yeah,
if you're which most people are doing to
take off on this as they're going anyway,
they're entering each PC inside you're
getting the feature and put the code on
it. If I'm importing it from somewhere,
which is.
SMC most shops don't end up doing,
but if I'm informing it yet,
then I got to select these pieces.
So it's it's fairly manual because the
system doesn't know what labor to apply
to the detail.
Once again,
you can import it and whales will come in,
but what what it doesn't know about. OK,
cool, what about feed up layout QC,
you know all its other stuff.
Back then saw it to get in there.
So that neighbor can details it.
So I didn't realize you had to go back
through the piece by piece estimating.
Yeah, yeah,
because there should unless unless you
want to do just like a part per ton.
Thing on it,
which scared the **** out of it, you know.
So there's some people that do that and
they'll spit out a lot of instruments,
but man, it scares me when it happens.
So I'm curious what happens here.
I haven't figured that out yet. Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah, this one.
I have a feeling at this level it's piece
by piece.
I have a feeling like the gilbert of why
you're one guy that's just way more than
if the D if I'm importing some and the
detailer has stuff labeled nicely.
You can very quickly wobble it and pick
all the columns, put one K on it,
pick all the filler bins, put one K on it,
pick all the stiffeners, put a K on it.
It's it can be very quick that way if the
detailer does a good job.
If the detailer doesn't label anything.
Huh. Maybe it can be a pain. Now with AI.
So with like with AI thing I was talking
about,
it will actually engineer the connections.
And put that in and then we'll put a code
on all that for you. So yes,
that has figured it out,
but if I've got a bottle and I important
to.
I had some details,
but really great at that. So yeah,
shoot from the guy. Yeah,
when you say detailer to me.
The detailer is either an external
detailer as part of the bid process,
or if it if you're bidding the job,
you may not even got involved in detailer
yet, but you just have.
Maybe you have to check the files,
maybe you don't, yeah.
I do have clients that have,
they have 130 tons on a retainer,
a monthly retainer for X number of tons
and they'll they'll have them create a
model for every,
every estimate that they do.
And like I got one client in Florida and
that's part of their.
I'll call it where every one of their
estimates comes with a model already and
I'm talking about a detailed model with
the miscellaneous and everything,
which is really to a great extent,
but that's kind of their,
that's what they're kind of known for and
it sells to both.
Yeah,
they'll create the model for for the
estimate.
They'll import the with the labor on it
and estimate and the model goes to the
client with it and says we're done.
Based off of that, we can do what?
Hit the ground running. Yeah, exactly.
And what else is in here?
It kind of depends on what the estimating
department is doing is construction lines
going through your building your own
assemblies.
You're looking at shelters and your
that's why the parametric assemblies can
really hear me.
The ones we have in there and the
estimators to having at home because then
you can you can go in there and enter
your parameters like a staircase that's
this long and this tall and this many
treads and then you just could go and it
populates all the material you need for
it.
Because he's got to do this in type of
structures.
They're doing this in this here.
They're not doing any type of structures.
Nobody uses type of structures here.
So for the stuff that I do, I did.
So I get the I get the stuff that we're
looking at here. I get the kiss well.
I get a model. I get.
I don't always get a model,
but I generally always get a kiss well
and.
I get it detailed out, shop prints.
This is what we're building.
These are our low limits.
They might be in red A4 and sometimes
we're speaking to some better latency and
OK,
this is our price contention on no
changes between our A and red 0 and then
I'm going to get by 0.
A lot of times they have already bought
it in and we run the notch.
So I I do think you would you'll get
better buy in from the rest of the
estimators if you build out some more
stuff in here such as different labor
case and stuff because if.
If if they're going to have to do a lot
of manual adjustments on each line for
some of that stuff,
it's it's going to be frustrating.
It's tedious it it it can be.
And so that's the key to the labor case.
It just makes it super simple.
So that that would be a key to getting
buy in I think is building that out a
little bit more.
You know, Tesla has like a lot of the box,
right?
And you go and teach people how to do it,
but then eventually everybody changes it
and becomes their own thing.
Right now I feel like you're taught kind
of halfway in between.
Right.
And you've got all this stuff you wish
would build out. Well,
if I'm doing a big job, I'll build it.
I'm not going to be fine kind of sitting
there and intering each of those.
I know how to build labor codes if it's
something that should have benefited me.
Like any of these nodes,
I don't know if you've seen the sheet
there, but I actually, yeah,
I saw it with all the breakdowns and
development.
Most of the time it's increasing the
number of fillets or increasing the well
size and increasing all that.
I'm dealing here and I think this is
because this is.
In all our estimate or somebody deleted a
bunch of our labor codes.
Maybe they want to function correctly,
but in here in our labor codes we'll add
a type and then the welded size and then
a type because everything in your
defaults is quarter inch.
So then we'll go in and operate a new
labor code, same code, same code,
add a description and and then from there
I'll pick that and I'll run it across the
whole project and then.
I usually try out the feed complex with
it.
Usually it's just fillet size increasing
so that all of my involvement's captured.
They don't want to add something,
you know something not being used.
When you say product across the whole
project, you still have to identify.
How many are there for? Yeah,
so if I'm 10 or 15 and I don't have 516,
then I'll go in and I'll figure W516Y516
to Z516 so that when I go through the
next.
95 drawings.
I'm just going in for getting a 516 level
that's throwing that one around there
instead of you know I was 10 drawings and
so I was early stage not not affecting
anything that it's incredibly ambitious
for you to just going to that point and
then if I do it that way then I'm
selecting this type adding.
Quarter range calculating out the well,
going down to additional part,
adding 16th of an inch of early,
which is technically getting me to the
same point,
but the better way to do it is to adjust
the labor product because then things are
going to roll up.
In the in the buckets that we have
associated, yeah, yeah,
Karam on the meeting type of estimator,
they'll create if there's if there's a
bunch of one specific type of wellness or
a specific labor call out.
He has enough to see what happened in
there. Bob,
I'm not 100% certain he has the amount of
scale around when they're confidently
pretty straightforward.
You can duplicate it over and we can kind
of adjust it, but.
Um, if you don't know what you're doing,
you can easily add one and apply it to an
entire project and.
Shoes.
So I've kind of restricted the Ron is
adding the codes.
Ron is the one who's telling his team
members. And by the way,
I had a Y 716 in that project where I had
so many well that that was 716.
This is going to get you that labor for
this type.
And and this is what you use it for and
and I would do the same thing if I added
something that was like hey I was I was
using the B for seat plates and every
single seat plate on my project was 3/8
well done. I had the B 3/8 in there.
I'll talk around.
Here in case you need it,
let everybody else know.
But will he see it?
And then 'cause he's he's the same pull
down, right? He'll see the pull down.
He'll have the same drop downs.
It'll pop in across the board. So um.
Most of the adjustments we're we're we're
kind of just working on electrical right
now, right? Yeah, we got electrical.
Do you want to see two things I'm
thinking since we're kind of running,
we ran through the.
Do you want to see that the I take off
thing for one thing? Yeah.
And then another thing,
there are 30 some labor codes that came
out of box that are need to be adjusted
like that half the wielding or something
on it.
I think some of those we made adjustments
to last time. I mean,
I think we deal has gone through some of
them, but yeah,
there's I guarantee there's a lot we did.
Yeah, that would be,
that would be awesome.
You want to get some labor codes first?
You want to see the AI label or do you
want? Let's do labor codes first,
because it's probably more important than
if we have time.
See the Girls Club.
Um, so let's start at angle. Go to decode.
Yeah, not there. Yeah,
let's click on the D labor code right
there for angles.
All right. Um.
See the welding right there?
It says 2 fillet welds at the quarter
inch times perimeter standard clip P
notice is 2.
It should be 4 because there's four clips.
So but that.
And the reason that standard clip P says
only two, that's putting clips on there,
right?
But in the standard clips it says there's
two of these clips. So two sides,
2 * 2 gets your four,
but that it's not the same length of the
wheels.
And so they've got that screwed up.
E is going to be the same way.
It's just weather clips on one end,
but you got one clip welded, so.
OK,
I don't know how often this is going to
get used anyway. This is, yeah,
on two ends,
but this is screwed up as well.
But if you're never going to use it,
we don't need to worry about it.
So well, just, I mean,
that'll be more on instance.
People have a job that has 40 in it and
then I don't want that to be our freaking
little gotcha. Yeah,
you see there it says burn manual.
So let's see.
The um.
So the burn,
it says to do that burning at the
thickness times the width. Well,
it makes no sense for an angle.
That would make sense for a piece of
plate. Yeah,
so we gotta modify that formula in order.
Or we'll create another formula to say
around the perimeter of the angle.
We could say long leg, short leg.
There's various ways to say this, but.
And.
That one, Yeah. So let's new on that.
Then we'll change our, uh,
width down there. Yeah,
just edit length formula,
get rid of width.
And I would probably just do perimeter.
Yep, there we go.
Oh, it's you back. No, we didn't.
I'm sorry.
It's it's probably used on plate labor
and also I probably need it.
And then L would be the same thing except
for just one end.
You left the K.
Oh.
It shouldn't have a well there.
That's only on the end,
so get rid of the well.
This is just full M prep.
Yeah, this, yeah.
Open world.
And the oak um code there.
Is this ever going to happen?
You put slip clips on two ends of the
neighbor.
It's not like they're going to do that,
right?
But this is wrong and it's got welding
for one clip. Might as well change.
Reason for some stupid thing.
All right, go to beams and D same deal.
Weld clips both ends.
We need to get more welding on there and
with E as well.
Go down to K So we got full pin prep on
both ends of the beam.
Different fabricators want something
different here, so this is full pin prep.
And it's only doing stuff on the on the
flanges, nothing in the way.
So I've had some fabricators that are
like, yeah,
let's just go ahead and plan a full pin
prep in the web as well,
which is not common.
I just pointed out as it's only handling
stuff on the benches,
which is plain on to make see it's not
going to do it right.
So I just point that one out because I've
had some that that want something
happening and then M.
Go to EM full pin prep and weld. OK,
so this is getting welding on the flanges.
So this is right with everything in the
flange.
Others will have a fillet weld in the web
as well.
So nothing's happening in in the weld.
In the way of the year, so yeah.
So we probably just a fillet weld is all
we want there, right?
So then you got to figure out, OK,
what size fillet weld and we might have
to create a formula because we're going
to need a fillet weld along the depth.
Width at length. So yeah,
unless we see something that says we'll
probably have to create one.
Yeah.
And probably something bigger, right?
And we want to do like a 3/8 rail or want
to make the garage.
Yeah, I'm probably saying, yeah,
if you want to do that.
And then we'll just change the length
down there. Oh yeah,
in the size and what it is, 375.
There you go.
And there's they got.
Oh.
It's the fact that we didn't hit.
I had a variable hit in it like the
formula.
What?
Yeah, yeah, I have variable.
I do that all the time. It's easy, but.
I guess I'm gonna keep one because I'll
have it memorized.
And that is not all of the labor codes,
but that that is what you would use
probably 8500% down within the program
somewhere, right? Yeah,
you you could get it that year, yeah.
Yeah,
and you can see here all the ones that
we've added. So yeah,
the Htap there's quarters, creates 516,
so on and so forth,
but I even they're gone.
I use on so many different projects.
They split it on both ends,
basically on one end.
So.
I mean,
it doesn't give you a detailed look at
him. No,
I just give you a verbal description.
That's all written description.
But I mean, I guess the reason you know.
How wouldn't I know that it isn't does or
does not have a fill a well on the to
here because it's just both of them.
I get that you don't know that.
It was. That's both ends. So you're right,
you would need four.
You need two on this end, two on this end.
Because I would assume this would be a
plan.
And then the AM is what he's putting up.
I know it's, you'd assume what that? Yeah.
Problem was there was a programmer doing
this to start with.
Anybody didn't know anything about
stealing work.
So when there's a updating.
First pack 5, whatever.
Is this overwritten?
When does this get overwritten?
When we do it here, this would.
None of this setup is able to get
overwritten with an update. It's just the.
That's we have our first data base. Yeah,
from scratch.
It's just a skeleton of the workings in
the background, right?
Not the the program itself, not the data.
So we're dealing with the data. So,
so then.
Oh, slope clips. Weld both ends.
You need it for four clips there.
Yeah, the little piece that we'll have,
well, two clips is right there.
That's right. Um.
Yeah, that's that's correct.
T What is T Weldon moment? Both ends.
All right, moment. There's nothing on the.
T double s the welding.
Also the 10 1/2 inch should probably be
more change to what the foot.
And what's the welding? OK, so.
Oh,
this is with the with this is with the
additional clips on the flanges.
So you're you're filling well there
around perimeter standard clip A should
be 4 cause you got 4 clips.
And then that right there two times
bottom.
How about if I'll burn your world?
OK,
so chase the width of flames times 2 + 8.
So I mean, is T just a clip world or is T?
OK. So the key is, yes.
So you see you got the clinch on the top
of the bottom. Yeah.
So I don't like the description. Well,
the moment, both ends. Yeah,
we we was talking about a normal, yeah.
Well, yeah,
you're you're just talking about web
clips on. Yeah, it was AD. Yeah, yeah,
D and then got added clips on the flanges
as well. So that um.
What I what I think of on this particular
line right here,
it's got two fillet wells,
two quarters fillet wells,
and it's just saying I don't know what
size angle you're going to have on the
top of that.
I don't know how long it's going to be.
But 10 1/2 inches is probably it may not
be enough.
If you got a pretty wide flange then that
10 1/2 is just to me maybe a little bit
too little.
We can change the formula like if I'm
building to follow.
In my default one,
I'm saying take the width of the flange
times two. I don't know how much,
what size angle will last.
I don't know if it's a three inch or 4
inch length. I don't know.
I just thought of it to a four inch here.
So I said the width of the flange times
two plus.
Can you get yours to get both sides of
the of the ankle and did that times four.
So I I I split the hairs here a little
bit, but I think it'll be more exact,
you know? Yeah.
So we need to change that here. Yep,
we need another formula.
Let me think if people bought,
you didn't use somebody like you who
wouldn't know all this,
all this **** is wrong, 100% right.
And that's what I tell people all the
time. I'm like,
I've tripped and fallen and screwed up
and I I OK, so I figured all that out.
Let me help you right there it is.
It's at the very bottom.
I guess the one that says two times,
two top and bottom of it there again.
Now actually the quantity is going to be
correct because it's got two and we'll
say it's all two meetings,
so which is unusual for all the other
ones.
So I'm very.
Yeah, put put back in there.
We we got to exchange with times 2
because we got to have this side,
this side of the floor and then we got to
and then we're going to add any issues
something like 4 inch angle or something
like that.
So T is a clip only connection, yes.
Yeah,
top up and the clips are going to the web.
I'm always used to the phone connection
with the public. Yeah, you're right.
Most of the time. OK,
we would use this very often.
I can't think of being behind. I'm not.
I'm not like, yeah, somebody just saying,
you know what?
Yeah, no, it should be welded.
So they really should be yes.
That's good.
But what's funny is that just that's the
whole plan.
It doesn't call the mobile connection,
yeah.
So actually that makes the gobbing just
that they don't just go to connections.
The only considerable one is said by the
it's not a lot of you to do some
engineer's capital. Yeah,
earthquakes and all that kind of ****.
So they're going to establish certain
ones as moment connections.
You still have a lot of other concern,
but the team more than the sit at the
moment connections, but they're wellness.
They're wellness same, you know,
it's just have they have certain specific
ones that they refer to as a search for
the engineers. Those are the ones.
Relating to It's weird.
Yeah, I'm not sure what's going on there.
So I I don't know that I'm worried about
it. Yeah, yeah, it's a custom one. So, OK,
standard base plates, is that not in here?
You will change their base plates.
So when you when you do a column,
you're going to put an H on it if it's.
And so it puts the welding on the column
because it is,
it knows the exact perimeter of the
column,
so it knows exactly how many inches to
put on it.
So then with so we don't need to put
welding on the base plate,
it's just going to be an A which is just
cutting it.
That's why we have type page half inch
quarter.
This is what you get right up there and
the feedback you had was paid.
We all of these did have additional.
Options to pick from for top and well,
all those changes we made to the well
yesterday.
Those were all going to be affected now,
right?
Because we changed the timing of the well,
right? Yeah.
So everything we did yesterday affects
all of us.
So you on beans is you'll change that
formula right there,
that second one there, yeah.
Yeah, and you only need more actually.
Yeah, so this is wrong too.
They had a good and wrong quantity on on
those as well.
The V code which is welded in plates both
ends,
which is just sheer pads on both ends.
I hate that description.
This sheer pads on both ends.
So there should be welding along the
length of the standard clip,
not the width. You see the.
So basically if we had a four inch by 6
inch shooter tab,
it's putting the welding on the four inch
side.
So we need to change that to the length
of the standard, yeah.
100 bucks. I'll put 100,000 on it.
90% of the fabricators haven't looked at
these to know. Yeah,
they don't know that they're putting the
wrong stuff on there. Holy cow, I mean.
It's integral screw. It is.
I've sent this to tech. As I said,
here's these changes you need to make on
your fault setup.
But there are there's got to be people.
I don't know about God.
You're doing the same thing over and over
and over. It's your it's outline.
You've got to figure out why if you.
Yep,
they're going through putting the cage on,
trusting that it's right and never
looking to see if it is the exact amount
of weld or if it's that they're just does
technically do tubes to base plates.
Two, it's a column. It's a difference.
Two column.
Two column goes through the baseline.
Is it automatically set up to all from
one side? No,
it's when you're going to attach the tube
to the top of the baseline. Yes, well,
it's probably.
It's still more time.
I still didn't see what you're talking
about. It goes all the way through.
That almost never happens that I've.
Have you seen it?
I think one of these light bulbs that are
here. Oh yeah, have that. Oh, interesting.
Yeah.
So you could be able to cage for that.
You did buy the light bulbs.
I think I don't have. Interesting. Well,
because you got a bunch of massive.
Hanging off that point or so, yeah,
to consider these estimators they are
using half of this **** anyways.
What they're doing is they're taking on
the race, they're taking on tall lights.
So they're necessarily using about them
to me. They're not really using this.
Assembly. That should be 4 as well,
because you're.
Because you're doing um.
On both sides of the flip, on both ends,
W is going to be the same way,
just on one end. That's fine. That's fine.
You did the last time.
Hear that and this.
We got something else to fix here too. Um.
Back on the what we can do here,
the so this is sure has both ends.
Notice there's no.
OK, so that one has holes.
The default has a box,
but doesn't believe it or not.
It was also standard. Yeah. OK,
so then you don't. There's no.
There is no field vaults here,
so if you uncheck show only included.
And then there should be a lot over here
for field balls.
Right there. So you need to for both ends.
Then they do same on W for one end.
No.
That's fixed.
Um.
Late we fixed the burner, did we?
Um.
Play indeed.
So this is if you're doing and I've used
this for.
It's rare,
but I've used to grab the clips on both
ends.
Like if it's a or really clips on one end,
somewhere it's like welded to the column,
but then it's got clips to get to get to
another beam or something like that.
So this right here, it's got the welding.
Once again, it's screwed up.
It's got welding two clips instead of
four clips.
Same thing with E, which is 11 side.
So you need two wells. There you go, Cave.
Um.
This is full him prep.
So the one we were looking at ran the
double on the plate,
but in the way of this does.
It does a prep on one end.
You see the burn there is just on one end,
so you need to bump that up to two.
And then go to the M code full pin Weld 2
ends and for full pin prep and Weld two
is only has one end included for the prep
here as well.
The.
That should be a.
That burn there should be two,
so it's got it's going to work on.
Two ends of the so you got your plate.
It's going to do it on this side and this
side, so you really need to.
Yeah.
Um T.
Which is through plates. So this is um.
So this is applied to the plate,
so that connection right there will apply
to the plate.
So the you got to have four birds at the
width, so.
Burn there. Yeah, there we go.
Could because it's got to burn up this
side and back down the other side here,
up this side, down the other side, right.
And then on you it's going to be the same
thing except for just you need two burns.
Yeah.
All right, so V.
Is.
I don't know how often anybody uses this,
but if you look at the guide,
reading of it. OK, so oh well,
this is for plates. Yeah,
I was thinking of manual. Yeah,
for plates. Yeah,
you use this all the time for gussets,
right?
So it includes welding on short legs.
Which does not apply. That's an angle,
right? So get rid of that.
So let's make sure we've got a little bit
on the leg that just with.
Yeah, so it should be good.
Rods.
Uh, go to K.
Once again,
how else were you doing a full PM prep on
two ends of a rod, you know? Um.
But this,
this wouldn't give you any labor for
burning because it says wall thickness.
There's no wall thickness for a rod.
So yeah, I mean,
I I don't know if you'd want to fix it.
You have to create a formally.
You never want to use this, right?
I almost even delete it, you know? Yeah,
L's the same way. It's just one end, so.
And M and N are the same way for PIM prep
and well, it's the same way,
but if you're never going to use those,
it's like how often is that going to
happen, right? All right,
tubes go to tubes.
He makes a.
Yeah, go to Tubes and D Weld clips.
Both ends has welding for one clip on
each end. So yeah, very good.
And then E is going to be the same.
We just need 2.
Go to T.
All right, double S the welding.
So this is.
Double S the welding.
Also tenant should probably have more. Oh,
this is the same thing as that other one.
It does double the welding here,
so it's weldable at both ends.
You need to change that four to two on
that one.
No, not on the weld itself, yeah.
And yeah, and then, yeah, the switch,
well, yeah,
the question is whether the 10 1/2 is
enough or not again,
but we can't use that and we've got the
land on on the two we have to.
Say like you know the the width of the
tube or something like that,
set a flange width in order to make that
happen.
I think there's like 2 get out of the T
because it'll be down there 2 something.
Tube depth and tube width, yeah.
No.
This is the last one.
OK.
Well,
I think that back at you down there to
your last one.
It's just the same deal with the.
Bye.
Banks have labor fields for me.
If you not that we're going to do this,
but if you learn to create all this stuff
for field direction, Yep,
you got to see increase your field
welding times overshot times that when
you create a new one,
it's got all new welding field
specifically for field.
Probably will be friends.
I would want to be able to differentiate.
The challenge of it is that when you're
in the estimate and you look up to the
top and the flowers.
It would show,
it would include both in shower,
but the buckets we created,
the labour bridge will be reorganized.
We could create some that's a the field.
And actually a lot of the reports you
would see it all mix together.
I already thought about it.
They're not going to change.
They're not going to.
I was sent down this morning.
That's my biggest battle everywhere.
It's just we're going to be able to
change their thought process and we're
going to,
they're going to keep everything.
Yeah, I think about it.
So do you need to go have the direction
we're going and think about how we do.
And it's like, yeah, I'm not listening,
but where they would move something like
silly they would not do it.
I'm like you're saving money.
We go much faster because.
It's like, OK, yeah,
I was teaching about the same part,
you know, it's like that makes sense.
That's not being expound.
I shouldn't care. I actually, I'm glad,
but ultimately, it helps your customers.
And I'm just too much interested to sit
there and say, well, I can't.
$140,
000 in the payroll that people do
something to this.
I can't sit there and say yeah,
what about your business?
I'm trying to get a holiday. Like I said,
it was about two minutes.
Yeah, yeah. I know you guys.
So I know I'm not.
I don't understand people for 45 years.
I did it so long ago.
I used to be in everything we've done on
the scratch pad. 50 of these. Yeah, I did.
It's kind of like detail on board and
then you have some of that.
They were not. He did not.
I've never actually run anything enough.
I suck at it. I used to run it.
Model, you brought it home.
It's going to be better to do that.
At least Jeremy may be not. I'm sure.
RIT guys, retire.
And he has a little side muscle of 3D
printed stuff for parties like Star Wars
masks and he makes costume stuff.
So he made all these different little
late characters.
Pete's pizza. It's very they said.
It's awesome.
Thank you.
For all these waiting, probably.
Yeah, I think that's right.
I think you're about to find out. Yeah,
I think you want to find out.
And he is the kind of the.
That.
They're doing this fast.
I don't know if you got me talking
sometime before you leave.
I get the sense that one of the questions
I want to be asked was can we use what
you have in the four times with each
other?
Trades.
I think the answer is they could probably
do anything, but as a man, yeah.
But it's just tents.
I was at a shop last week. There is tents.
I'd be curious what that would look like.
Is that a lot of stuff?
Or is it out-of-the-box?
The out-of-the-box part would be you got
blanks and everything on the right.
The the the set up stuff would be like
the flanges and all the other stuff you
might have to put on this to be like a
little new.
The God.
I won't say non steel,
but you know what I'm saying.
The non conventional shapes.
So let's say you have a shell that's a 10
foot 9 tank.
You've had a stretch out in 31 feet or
whatever.
It's it'll pick all that labeled up
automatically.
Yeah,
you you would just build out labor codes
specifically for that stuff.
So there would be set up for like in
estimating the the you'd have to build
labor credit for.
It's like same deal with like ridge type
guys, like I've been spinner,
which is what the end way we go to waste.
Used to build the labor codes to do what
you want to do.
So with bridge type guys I'll have to do
the build up bridge grooers and what not
so.
Yeah, Nope, it's not.
It just takes a little bit of set up.
Yeah, I used to do all this stuff. Yeah,
I like, I know they, I know those people.
Mm-hmm.
Anybody track bikes?
I don't know anybody doing it.
I wouldn't describe if there's if there's
not somebody out there doing it.
I got a bond in Wisconsin that talked
about doing it, but they.
They never really get there.
I don't know why, but we like the track.
Yes.
OK.
I don't like being Yeah, it does.
They sent me their drawings.
That client that I was thinking about
doing, they sent me the drones for it.
I'm just used to structure on this one.
You know,
I'm looking at their pipe drones and like,
what about living?
It's just a bunch of lines.
It was different.
Probably bothered me.
Everybody knows all of this stuff.
They never give you the data. Exactly.
But.
It's nuts that.
It's the dumbest industry.
You got a architect that creates 3D to
put it into 2D to give to somebody else
to make it into 3D to give it in 2D.
It's like it's the dumbest cycle.
I don't understand how we don't put that
****.
When you get these thousand drawings,
tool packages.
No, no, that's it. Give me the data.
No, we can't do that.
Now those new take out programs they have.
Those are pretty cool.
They're just spitting out the same.
This many columns this side and this many
meetings this side. Well, again,
five guys the same thing.
It's all guns for you, except they.
Tell them when you get it,
if you have good relationship with the
owner, with the owner,
the owner forces them to give it to you.
Possible.
He's like, hey, this is our data.
This is our fabricator.
Let's not waste everybody's time.
This evening.
Yeah. Well, good. Thank you.
Yeah.
You should be. They got models.
They get to check off the food layers.
No.
Alright.
If there is any restriction, I don't know.
I mean in front of the bus and the street,
that's right.
For some reason, I work.
I work in problems.
You know what to do about that.
They almost told me I'm going to lose my
gallbladder. I was like, no, man,
I I like the repeats. I'm ********.
It's going to take everything from me, so.
No, stop being a *****.
I just made a ***** still.
I don't know the time to turn 21 is about.
Oh, I think it was this weekend. Yeah. Oh,
yeah.
I was here. Actually, I'm here.
I found something for today.
Thank you.
Like it's to.
Sounds means.
Meaning, you know, that's it's like.
We need one back to coverage.
Matthew Garrett's.
BBQ links, right? We'll bring in the BBQ.
We'll bring one out there.
It's a.
So yeah, I'm sorry.
Yeah.
Were the odds successful?
They wouldn't be doing their job if they
didn't find it.
They want your dues to keep coming in, so.
It might go one way or another, right?
I think I've seen about that.
There's the UL. Yeah, UL is horrible.
Really.
They make you so we were different.
Every design they want to essentially
have a.
I'm personally involved.
They can make free visits and all they're
doing is ripping off another code, yeah.
I'm like,
how in the world is this fossil
exhausting? I think they asked itself.
It's funny.
They'll give you a list of five or ten.
Yeah, there's all them. Next year,
they'll find new things. You know,
like you didn't catch them last year,
but they all used to smile.
Find something to get your money,
get their money.
Yeah, the one that.
You know,
for us with a pain in the *** was ISO.
Yeah,
because Charles ISO guy was the aerospace
guy and we were doing that.
And so he's perceived. I mean,
ISO is only who would you say,
say what you do.
Yeah, but he was.
He had written some procedures like so
handcuffed and for our aerospace business,
we could do one thing for finding his
people.
Yeah, you're like,
what the **** writes these procedures for
this?
****,
we gotta put a section that says for this
slide, for that slide.
But I still hates that they want the
single standard in the whole facility.
I'm going to go on the separate our
business and OK, this is aerospace only.
That's two year business.
I've seen companies do that for us,
even when it comes to union and non union.
OK, we got one that's over here,
it's non union and we got one that's over
here.
No, that's what it says.
Solved the problem. Yeah, so.
I'm sure it creates function.
I spent the whole day.
And I'm saying she wants a ship like the
union, not union,
wants to put the shops in different parts
of the city. Hey, what?
I don't know.
I wish the role of withdrawal is possibly
on connecting with my new if not received
the new objective and Johnny and Tom will
load your account and we'll automatically.
Yeah,
it wasn't in the video until 15 or
something.
Still we.
That is nothing to do with my phone.
Yeah.
I thought it's 100 years,
so I was in the table.
Yeah, I'm ready to go.
I'm the.
Good.
It and.
And here it is.
OK.
Yeah.
It's basically about 30 different.
I'm here fix it.
I don't understand why I'm not fixing
like you know, I don't know.
I saw them until about three months ago.
I said 8 months.
I need something in the second.
I guess you have a good relationship.
Do you think they'd listen to you?
I'm just going to keep wondering for my
car.
Thank you.
You can't even touch it at home.
It's been touched.
It's still a few years ago,
I had a gal film and trained the smile
and sober in moving.
She can do something that you're doing,
but the moving man,
this ***** and I've learned a lot of ****
about moving. So I'm like,
how are you now? You know, moving.
I'm talking to and it's like the same,
but it's very, it's very short.
They're making money and they're like,
yeah.
I've got,
I've got and and they're the ones that
were really kill me.
There's Adam and I've got one of these
lists.
Yeah,
but I assume wants to use want to make
part of it. They don't want me to work.
They're doing.
I need to learn it.
Which I want you to know.
OK,
I need this action model because we need
this in in the empowerment. No,
give me that. I'm like, I don't trust me.
So then I did my own research on some of
that stuff and I did with that. I'm like,
can you tell me better?
That's fine.
Yeah, I may be so mad that I just didn't.
But if I had done your work,
I could've done this and this way I also
should do.
Here's how you're doing it so that we get
what we're doing.
I think that's the only way you would.
Yeah, I think you're probably right.
Details of answer to everything was magic.
Yeah, like the army.
Yeah.
OK, I've achieved.
His settings were different than his
settings, and they were they were.
To protect the structures to rewrite all
this land units and get all our past
situaries. You can hear a little bit.
It's supposed to be there two weeks for
how much six months. We just,
we wouldn't let them be.
That's what concerned me is that there's
detail being done by multiple entities.
We ended up a.
Steve, you know, can you set the sentence,
get the sentence the way one of the bar
shapes and the grade in the rubber
opinion and like our standard components
and then put that.
So you didn't want you there was internal
or external have you been on the new job
and put that down because you can
understand and so that that helped a lot.
But there were still times when external
details you didn't do that.
Then we get thought about the life of.
If we couldn't get the internal detailers,
internal detailers, things,
all of our status, stuff like that.
There's a library park. Why is it there?
Oh, well, I did it this.
This is the library park. What's he doing?
Like we solved this problem 10 years ago,
yeah.
We had to do that that morning,
maybe withdrawing everything you saw on
the regular,
you have to have multiple ordnels to run
a data floor.
Yeah, I think, yeah,
I think everybody needs to realize more
than life is you're not inventing
anything.
If I could, you could think about,
it's probably already been done.
It's kind of funny. Years and a half ago,
they're building a fusion that you got
here in Boston.
I'm sure that is some accepted MIT.
So they came to us.
They said we want you guys to build all
the cooling panels.
Nice. Or exterior.
They're probably closer. You know,
they can see it's not over here.
You guys are weird.
So I look at it and they didn't really
know if they wanted somebody to draw
nothing.
They just, I mean, sample. Hey,
this is what we're going to do when you
drove. They just kept on on and on and on.
It's like, you know, you better just.
Go down the road. They're building it.
Somebody's going there.
Joseph is super cool thing.
I wanted to do it all the time.
There's like a big school thing in the
building, but there were just panels,
right?
Panels that they wanted to make on the
back of this and make it run cooling.
So my brain is like stainless panels,
stainless tubing, welded you together.
It's not really exactly hard,
but they made it like.
Can you hear one test on that?
So as far as getting selected, yeah,
I think we are on the Q3 there.
So I was gonna have four wells in between
the two and the three.
How much fun it is to build that.
That's the like a.
Oh, I said this together.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, that's.
That checked.
We should.
I don't want somebody of what is that.
Yeah, I mean, yeah,
especially when you're working on.
I know I got a call from the vendor
yesterday's Smith right.
They want to redo their whole facility
and want the entire property given their
yard.
And they asked if if we can quote being
the chief speak for.
So I'm very. OK, I mean,
we used to do this. Let's do that one.
All the trades are electrical.
We are fully frigging.
We can give me the information.
We will be done.
So we're sending the overall bid
information.
Well,
for us to make sure because it's local
that you develop. Yeah, right.
So you know the building for the buying
middle building or somebody designing a
building.
It's something very nice. They don't fail.
They don't say what to go on.
So like there should be a.
That too.
So we got all the best that's have to be
on.
Are you getting in there for a little bit?
You know the breakfast.
That's no difference.
That's I shouldn't have.
I've only played once for a long time.
First they expanded the bean markets.
Now they are.
So they have,
they have one project and there are
multiple projects they have.
One Kasma was a 50 foot bed,
so at that they have a secondary yard
that has 260 foot tables and they also
are obviously clients.
Well, so oh, the line is long. Uh, Delta,
Bartsman and.
So now Delta bought the lines,
so now Delta owns all of it,
which is why they're trying to completely
redo the facility here off of 30 bit,
whatever it is, so.
Yeah,
what I would like about the doctor
facility is you could literally take it
for take coil and give me what I want and
cut it.
Nobody can do that so I can get cuts of
length.
It's nice. Yeah,
that's they they've been doing pretty
well for everything,
every far more requests they do them.
Even the one in the quarter police said
do a special no one for all of those.
They brought everything in.
That would be when I first started in
Tucson and we use them on this period,
but it would be only for the small, say,
you know, half a truck or whatever.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, yeah, that'll build.
So and then they have a they have aborted
on the premises and they'll they'll
double replace right off the machine so.
2.
Pretty soon these service centers are
going to be the people doing the beam
line stuff. Yeah, you know,
they they could be, yeah.
So I have it in the mine board. Well,
the person was going to put a pipe
process processing center in right here.
Across the highway,
just a little bit more.
And I got the land and everything.
I got a super center right next to it.
I'll go ahead and.
So you have to get the five processing
done in elevators, which sucks.
It's those Houston shops that use those
service centers to bring in everything.
Partially finished.
You're sending me,
I think all those service centers,
you know,
one company that bought us service
centers, they wanted to go, yeah,
that's really what they.
I will be Ben Clips, plasma captives.
I can just see it.
I'm climbing up and up and up.
These days they're going to just have 5B
months there and just be here.
Possible.
It'll be interesting to see if we were
standing. Yeah, it's horrible.
This is where you guys think it got
killed this year on terrorists.
I'm sure they know very much.
I don't see how much.
Make a pass through.
The price of yield in Mexico is quite
cheaper than here.
We were buying for our shop in Mexico,
out of Mexico,
you know it's 15 to 20% cheaper and
you're bringing it in.
We would bring in trucks from Monterey,
so.
In the sound of people just seeing all
those.
In the States, we have a shop in Mexico,
Mexico, Mexico,
and then the manufacturers will be coming
across.
Let's just say we got good at it.
It certainly.
No, you can have more, right?
You can kind of polish it if you got
typically four people to deal with,
two on this side, two on that side,
but they all have to be on the money.
But so, you know, once we worked it out,
it worked. It was all inside business,
so it was all inside.
It's like,
that's how the US ever competes with this.
Let me tell you.
Share with the rest of the.
20 years now, so factories, India, China.
Possible to continue? Yeah,
we're just got much lower.
I mean, laborers must think it's free,
but it's.
Chatter didn't start packing down for
2017.
You can actually do that after that.
It would probably work, right?
Was it that way around?
I thought they got, um, for the year. No,
let's try everything right now.
I was gonna try it out for a period of
time, but.
OK.
They went,
they went so far like we had to do before
we're using frost into the bushes like
all the bushes were like from bumper
spray and then they came in and they had
us put a booth in and then thermal optic
batteries and they put thermal.
Olympic stadiums in China and we can see
them for something.
Thanks.
Always a problem up there.
The guy's fine with the Ivy, the wounds.
That's what I saw in the Middle East.
They're doing the same thing in our sales.
Yeah,
and any of it would be a sample of
welding.
But I still think it's like a million.
That's why I make this looking soon.
Pretty much.
Geez, and it tastes half the value.
Oh,
Jake sent him the e-mail on business card.
He's sending it to somebody that they can
go. I don't know, obviously,
it's a thing and he's sending it to
somebody that looks that prank.
Jesus.
That's that's something inspired.
7.
Volume standard, Jacob Crow, right? Yeah,
see what's the rest of the problem. Yeah,
so.
I just hold the standard.
I gave him my silo. I gave him his time.
I get permission.
That's all that I've got together.
Set up the e-mail.
Yeah, it was.
Did you get feedback when you set up the
vacant shunt thing,
your e-mail signature map that looks like
business and all that? Yeah,
I got experience.
I looked at three of them. They were none.
None of them.
So I picked one of the three that I
looked at. Yeah, there you go.
I was looking at like,
who's the highest ranking person here in
the United States?
Well, I can't expect that. Yeah,
the e-mail from Louis Daniel where he
said something about it's the overall
company thing for all days or whatever,
and it's a good one. Yeah,
it's what I just nobody can bet, right?
They bring me up.
I just pull them online and see how that
works.
I've got the point like, OK,
I don't even get my business to start out
any much,
but like that we go through mostly we go
through the sale guys, go through the PDM.
Say yes, Sir.
It's correct.
You're not feeling like that's what
you're taking care of. We've actually.
This.
So.
Well, would you?
That to everybody listening up and it's
not for.
Thank you.
When you are here.
Some type of the question,
like the stop that.
Dude, it's even worse than Samantha.
Oh yeah, I'll just leave.
I need some food. It's like $30 meals,
$60.
00 after freaking the door rash and it's
27 bucks.
It's another
Bye.
So we but if something was like we try
something. I don't know what happened.
Hello Fresh and it's me.
There's a three one that we have.
I think that we could figure it out.
It's been happened freshly.
OK.
We'll do that. It's really,
I'll say I get the same one.
I don't know what time the time is.
Out.
No, I'm honest. I'm honestly,
I don't think all about it.
We need and I've only and I've expected
from Mr. I have a sandwich shop called Mr.
Diggles and not have a list.
There's only two sounds that are there,
whatever the club is,
another chicken salad.
No, it's.
Well, that's.
It matters.
No, that's probably about to.
It's the time black boy.
I try to work up in the far.
You're in this particularly an hour.
I use that.
Start.
It was a lot closer than I started,
actually. I thought, I think we did it.
So the information is like a.
No, you didn't give me, uh, basically.
Once I was good,
but there should be a separate one. OK,
double check that because that's the case.
Mark, the one. Mark.
He might have just started the one on
there,
but I'm pretty sure he put it somewhere
else. Yeah.
Yeah.
I don't think I estimated it.
Yeah,
estimate that there's only five number.
That's.
That's the only happy nothing.
You were supposed to push it down here
that as a change order. Yeah, so I yeah,
I guess I'll just go back and type in the
GX and see what the other two are.
He's still a big one.
He's not understanding. Yeah,
because they have both there.
So they do the field portion and then
they have a compatload.
He started the compatload.
That makes sense.
Don't you guys are responding things in
there?
Yeah,
I had 29450 from Steel and then 150150.
Yeah, he gave it a.
Yeah, so he gave you like what?
He gave me the total 31, plus 31,
some change or whatever my e-mail said.
We're talking,
we're talking about shipping.
That's because we can save time by going
to just the one quote and worried about
keep getting lost.
Maybe we have three different quotes in
there, one for the harlot,
one for the drought, one for the.
The clock.
Yeah, yeah.
Right.
That's the limit.
Must be worried.
We'll be in the powers problem.
What do we have one person in question
and it is.
I just think it's a very sort of bridge.
I just saw it clicked on in in the
morning. I just got it.
Till disclaimer.
It'll be sure to spread it yet,
but it's not.
Uh.
By playing music.
Yeah, I'm sure.
And then she's learning the lab only if
we needed so they don't create much
different sheets. I'm really doing.
No, it's probably the more field schools.
Is that one of the problem, John? John?
Yeah, do you want to go to the drawers?
Yeah, we should have a.
Should we start in the original at least
in close?
If you're on the down where you want me
to, I should have something.
What are they doing?
I'm not sure yet. Well,
I mean what I've got here.
They're going to put me on.
They made it something they're going to
put me on the same TJ's on so TJ doesn't
have to do it. So but you know,
haven't you looked at that adventure?
There's not an auto kind of venture for
like, so we had a better.
Stop.
Veteran Solid Works are very similar,
but seemed like a lot more than people
who are very solid works,
but we didn't want to keep all the
licenses, but what sucks is.
Inventors of AutoCAD boxes.
So a lot of the old guys like me were
AutoCAD people and so now it became a
problem on how many AutoCAD licenses
could be achieved while we were getting
these licenses like we all know started.
But I mean if you want to do simple lines
like that.
But I mean, Inventor is a whole or song.
It's a whole thing tomorrow.
I got.
I haven't entered for a little while and
I'm like, we need this add on,
we need this add on, we need this add on.
I was like,
it's going to cost a fortune by the time
it's not like we're redesigning our if
you're going to use it for the field or
you can.
Yeah,
they wanted to do it here for the shop.
And I was like, I think that'd be great.
That just sounds what did you draw here
in the winter because the buildings and
the oh, they actually draw it. Yeah,
they who's going to do the home?
They want me to do it.
Jimmy had started doing it and there's
just, that's for like, you know,
real tight manufacturing where you're
really trying to get it processes close
together and you're trying to.
Yeah, sorry. But I was like,
I don't have time for that either.
It's a lot. It's not just.
I heard somebody you, you know, you know,
Upwork. No, it's like a website, you know,
you can just throw a job at somebody and
it just does this **** all the time.
Exactly.
And then what we did is for one of the
buildings,
we did a demo on a building scanner and
so we're all walking around doing the
training on it and scan and then they
said, Oh yeah,
we'll send you your file for free,
you know, we're part of the just the demo,
so that we never were.
And bottles.
Yeah, so I think,
but I have some interest. Yeah,
that's the jab.
But I I have, I have. I'll look at 2011,
the company I work for a bottom of the
disk,
so I haven't had to have it forever now,
but it's it's limited but.
And then I start deals with that software
code.
Because there's kids that are so good at
it. Exactly.
So we're going to wait for the electrical?
Should we do your demo?
I haven't heard something about it.
Must be in that cold though.
That's what I'm thinking about that.
It's like the.
In a call to see 12:30.
I don't see it.
And then there's this 15 chicks, yes.
2.
I did just a bit on on the one that I did.
I didn't do an estimate of it.
I didn't do the labor. I didn't.
You can't reject that, kid.
Not unless it's 8C. Yeah,
that'll work that way.
No, we did not. Uh,
I mean ready for the top model.
Yeah,
I'm just walking in the conference rooms
and you just.
I believe it's seeing in the field site,
the other construction site.
Yeah.
It's our technology.
I'm good. Yeah, like you know.
I was not that impressed.
I was a little one in here.
They get embarrassed.
I think they were bad.
It's like they thought it was kind of
funny. Well, you know,
you got to remember.
Or I've come from other places that have
all this really nice equipment and I go a
lot of space to do that.
I'm going to use it.
I'm purposely use a really good set of
drawings so you can kind of see what it
can do.
That's throwing up the most difficult
things. See what it can do, right?
So.
They've had this thing.
They've had about 70 fabricators on it
for about the past six months,
just as a in beta mode,
just to get things working.
So I'm gonna upload a set of drawings
here.
Um,
just put in today's date as a project
number.
Fill out whatever you want to there.
So it's gonna upload the drawings.
Let me actually,
let me go open that so you can kind of
see what I'm uploading. Um.
Uh.
So this is what I'm uploading.
Just just PDF, just sub PDFS. Yep.
And what's good?
What's this program going to do?
It's going to do magic. It's going to.
So once it gets up there,
I'll fill up the analyze PDFS.
It'll take off the columns.
It'll take off the B.
Things it'll engineer connections,
it'll spin out the next floor to to bring
in the power plant and it'll build the
model all in one shot.
How long have you got to say?
Are you impressive? It's.
Crazy. It's unbelievable. All right,
so I'm in there. Let me go here first.
This configuration. No, it's it's you.
You don't have to upload everything like.
This page is going to do nothing with,
right? Sure. But even with the sections,
it's not going to really look at the
sections right now.
They're actually working on it where
where we'll start using the sections to
get more detail and to get other
information.
But pretty much these are all the pages I
can.
So now I can write here on this config
page.
You would wanna go in here and look and
do all your settings for how you wanted
to do connections,
the Bman reaction method, seismic stuff.
Do I want to default to double angles or
shoe tabs? Right.
So you set all this up in order to do the
connections.
Does it actually understand different
side of the parts of the I'm not.
I don't know that I know the full answer
for that to be quite honest with you.
I I haven't you know I haven't used this
in production it's just so I I I don't
know all those have to ask them on that
but So what I'm going to do on so I'm a
foundation plan.
So what I'm going to do it picked up the
scale and.
the well pick up top of steel because
there is no top of steel, right?
So I could do zero,
I could do minus one for that,
I can do whatever I wanted to there for
for this and then I'm going to tell it by
hitting this button to go and analyze it.
So now you'll see that like on this one,
you'll see it.
It'll pick it up here in a second.
See how it is now highlighted in blue and
has that overlay on it.
At that point I'm just making sure it got
everything and making sure it didn't get
something that I don't want like this
over here.
It picked up stuff here which I don't
want,
so I'm just going to highlight that and
say don't don't do that and tell it to
rebuild it with that with that out of it
so.
You're pretty much just letting it do its
thing,
then making sure it got everything and
cleaning it up.
Now if I I'm going to then go to the next
set, it picked up top of steel.
It picked up my scale,
so I'm just going to tell it to go.
And boom, it got all that.
You can see the red though.
It didn't pick up like if I zoom in here,
it didn't get this one here,
this 10 at 12 and it didn't get this 10
at 12 right here.
So if I were to select both of those.
I can then tell that it's a dead whoops W
10 by 12.
And that it has six studs.
It is picking up the studs, by the way.
So I'm saving that, telling it to rebuild.
So really, I'm just cleaning it up, right?
Like I picked up all this crap right here
thinking it's a beam of some sort.
So I would just be going through cleaning
all that up. I'll go to the next page.
Same deal picked up top of steel and my
scale. I'll just tell it to scan.
I see you're going floor by elevation by
elevation, correct?
So yeah,
I haven't really cleaned up anything,
right? But just a few, a few things.
But as I'm doing that,
if I go here to my 3D view,
you're gonna see this building a model.
This is where I think modeling is going
to be a thing of the past before too long.
And so now I've got my model with
connections in it.
Hmm. Interesting. Isn't that crazy? Yeah,
it is.
Absolutely, I believe.
So I I got my bottle.
I can come over here,
but you see that bill of material.
This is actually the the import template.
For technical power fab.
So you can see that it's it's picked up
my quality, my shape, my size, the length,
the grade. It's got my labor code in here.
They're they're working on this being
customizable to your own labor codes if
you want.
It got camber coat holes, studs. I mean,
it's just picking up everything, right?
They would find it a whole lot.
We've met one of yours,
not growing up here,
but that's that's one thing that they
wanted all these fabricators on there for.
They're like, hey, go on there, it's free.
Now I can come here also with my columns.
You see that it thought that it thought
that on the upper level it was a 14 to 74,
but it's a 14 to 68.
Actually,
so I will change this to a 14 at 60.
So what it did, it put a splice in there.
That's what that is. Put a splice,
I won't get rid of it.
So now I've got that fixed.
So you want to check your column schedule
here.
But like if I literally did want a column
splice here,
I can do that and then choose whether I
want it to be.
Be welded or bolted or what type of
connect splice I want there, right?
So I can build. This was a client of mine,
so it's a fabricator that wrote this,
which is another big check box, right?
That's a good thing.
A firework behavior like this.
So it's pretty awesome, isn't it? Yeah.
I can also right here,
they're going to get it set.
Let me apply that.
They're going to get it set where the
bracing just it figures the bracing out
and does it. If I get a braces though,
I can't build my bracing in here if I
wanted to by saying hey,
start at column C1.
C1 go to column C32. I want V bracing.
I want it to be welded to cool and I want
it to be HSS 8 by 8 by I don't know
quarter.
Wow.
Freaked out on me.
Oh man, you're bad.
Something freaked out on me.
Let me get back in there. But I can.
I can build my bracing if I wanted to.
Then once I get all that done and I have
the model, I could import the model.
I can also by by getting the the IFC
right there.
They're building it so that it.
You can go straight into tech
construction or SDS too as well and and
just build the model in there.
But I can also do this export as PDF and.
It marks up everything that it took off.
Now I can go do the rest of the junk,
you know, the gingerbread stuff,
all the perimeter stuff,
my miscellaneous and everything.
So I mean, yeah, you think about it.
I mean, how,
how much savings is is that if it's
picking up the drawing, right?
I've got, um,
one client in Texas who was if you go to
um.
Uh, what's her name? The other guy.
The other guy is here. Lyft.
If you go to these guys website,
you're gonna see a sketch deck.
You're gonna see one of my clients is the
biggest user of it.
They searched over the his.
And he he says that he's getting about
40% more estimates out what is moving on
the same people.
So they're straight structure. Yeah,
industrial drugs don't need, yeah,
but like straight structural stuff.
That's what this guy.
What percentage of what you guys do is
strange.
10 percent, 50%.
Everything on depends. Well,
so that's last question this way.
I'll ask them just to do the restoration
function.
Yeah, well, I mean,
we can throw a set of your plans. I what?
Let me read it right to you.
I don't care if you use it.
I get nothing with you.
I just like to show the tools that I'll
see if it'll be back to just for the day.
How do you know how much it's going to be
when they come up?
It's they'll be settled in January 1st.
So like right now that that we talked two
months ago,
you'd be able to do this for free as long
as you get feedback. But yeah,
come January 1st,
it's they're not taking any more beta
people.
So but I have no idea what it would cost.
They know what sketch that.
So I would imagine it's going to be at
least on sketch deck. So yeah,
which was pretty expensive, but yeah,
it was pretty expensive, $80,000,
I've heard all over the place for sketch
deck.
They were doing it the revenue-based
while kind of like Perthest was going for
a while,
then they stopped that and they started
doing it per license,
then they started doing it per company,
then they started doing it per estimate.
I I don't know how you're going to be
quite honest.
So, but it was pretty expensive.
I was here with $25,
000 in licensure should remember.
Uh, I don't know that. It seems cheap.
Probably licensing subscription. Yeah,
it wasn't licensed. I remember that.
But I guess my thought is if I assume $25,
000, you get that 40% more estimate.
I'll be I'll be all over. Sure.
This is 25K. It's done. Yeah, I'm tossing.
The way this this happened was they hired
a guy from like Hungary that came in and
he started detail.
But like he's got a program background
and a new background and as he's
estimating he's like.
Guys, I think I can do this better.
Will you let me start working on
something? So he started working on this.
Then he got some of his buddies from back
home that are programmers to start
helping them on it.
So they've been working on this for about
two years, so.
So, yeah,
it's been actively used in their shop
citizen. So, yeah, cool concept, right?
Yeah, cool is almost an understatement.
And I've got Sketchbook.
I haven't tried them in forever.
I could throw one up there too,
but there's it doesn't do as much.
So doing that.
So cool.
I would be to try the girls to see how
much they've advanced it cause I've done
some and it's like OK,
well they've had estimators on it here
like that. I don't know that they got it.
They had to fix too much of that like I
had a set of drawings I put up there.
They're for a client and they really need
to and it it should.
Arkansas sent it to them and I got back
through and said OK,
you're trying to mail picked up
everything.
So I was kind of pleased with their
response right by their crowdsource agent
and they can test about a bunch of
different components.
Yeah, exactly.
When I saw it nine months ago, I'm like,
guys, you got to sell this now.
They're like, it's not ready. I'm like,
you're way farther than anybody else.
Just tell everybody what they can do and
what's needed and just go sell it.
And they're like,
we're not going until it's until it's
ready.
My OK but.
They're doing it.
Actually,
so I'll grab those and I will try.
Where do they present their software?
Do what they go to a place that where
they going to accept it.
I don't think they've gone anywhere yet
to to add any shade yet.
I'm sure they will once they start
selling it, but yeah,
I don't think they already have.
OK.
So you're not having.
Yeah, the music.
Yeah, they're YouTube videos. Cool.
That's what you were gonna show, right?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
This set of drawings I'm looking at right
here has um.
Where the building you got half the
building on this one sheet have to build
on this other sheets now has to pile
those two together somehow.
They're in trouble with that at first,
but they they got that taken care of
evidently.
Yes,
we're hoping to put down our meeting on
this.
This is what we really just need to let
people take a peek at this.
I like Jimmy was just getting us in an
instant, yeah.
There is a way also to actually draw
stuff on here if you want me to.
I don't know how to do that.
There's someone.
Nobody's called EME.
Uh.
You mean the company that owns Steel GD?
Master Steel is the is the steel company,
but they kind of formed their own company
to sell this.
So there is a company called DNV that
does conceptual model of the analysis
with student structures. Hello.
Oh.
Well,
I think when I searched for Steel Genie,
Yep, this came up.
There is another trying to think of a
name.
There's another one that I had a a login
to.
There's search game with infra bells
trying to think of the name of the but
it's just.
It's a little bit frustrating because you
you upload the drones to their site,
they do the take off,
they do the take off of their software
and send it back to you.
You have no control over it so.
It's it's a little bit.
It will be a little bit frustrating to me
just because I don't.
I got to get it through now,
pick out everything,
manually type it in somewhere.
Kind of weird that in a YouTube video
they built.
It's like nothing about contact
information.
Maybe they just posted the video.
OK, guys, don't come. What are we doing?
What are we that's left?
I received the import that we're going to
try.
I just wanted to do for all these
trapezes. Yeah,
I think guys tell me just go here.
Oh.
This is on some,
but it just like a regular or something.
Well, mostly that's processed up there.
You got an import on the electrical stuff,
is that what you're saying?
It was Mike Williams. I was just,
I was just e-mailing Battle Born.
Oh yeah, yeah,
that we we helped them with estimating.
They're wanting to help with,
they're wanting to help with production
control.
Well,
they're clean mayor from the council.
They do structural, they do cranes,
and they do all that.
I don't know anything with them.
Thanks to work started the start for
division about better still.
There's a.
A lot of other companies out there I
haven't done anything with. I'd love to,
which I'm busy though, but.
Are you booked out once ahead of time?
Yeah, I'm booked out.
Into April right now. Yeah. Yep.
But that's um,
I'm planning one week a month not
traveling.
So that's a little bit artificially
inflated from where I used to be.
So you live on the road. Yes, I do.
How many people do you have like Jason
that do the same community? Uh,
one other guy?
Well,
there's probably so many structural shops
and it's just never ending.
It's supposed to be out there.
It's in the US. Yeah.
And I've been to 130. I found like 87.
I was looking like what the West looked
like. I found 87 of them.
West, not including California,
not including the coast. Most of my,
it's like most of my clients.
I don't know why,
but maybe there's more fabricators,
but most of my clients are eastern side
of the United States.
More southern Western,
which I don't know whether it's just.
Um, like there's.
All of the green dots are on the clients,
but you can see that a higher
concentration of them over there.
That's a little less.
So for whatever reason that is,
I don't know.
No.
I'll refund my skills and let you know
when I'm looking for a job. Well,
let me that got a change down here.
I'm having to be 3 miles rather than just
my other.
I'm looking on like 3 times the sales,
3 times the.
There's really stuff,
which is exactly what I found one day,
so I have to figure out this is what I
like to do and I like to schedule.
Wait a few minutes in the sun here.
I like to feel like I'm helping, you know,
that's the biggest issue for me with work
over the last, you know, 10 years,
I'll say. That's the biggest issue.
I'm being helped, you know?
Yeah, I stuck my nose to this 5205 thing.
I was hearing all these different
opinions and finally I talked to the
field.
That's why I left this morning to go talk
to them.
It's like everybody just being backed off.
Sounds like got it.
Well,
because there was such a partial story
being told by and this guy basically has
to go do the job.
I thought Jimmy was really good guy kind
of driving all this,
but I can see that's not the case.
So like check,
they must talk to first manager.
I think he got pulled into it.
It's not really his, you know,
but there's nobody that's really good at
doing this.
It's a it's an easy job for somebody with
experience, OK?
Now, when it comes to field direction,
I'm out of my I'm out of my lane.
The only thing I'm trying to help with is
the welding of the alloy and and but I
couldn't get anybody to tell me the
welding process.
When you get the super alloys,
there's welding together.
Actually it's asking the corrosion
science. We can skip that stuff.
Until I wondered what the girls were
going to do.
Try to make sure they understand.
Needed to put matters.
Not like I've been used to welding beans
together in touch with us.
They're gonna really hate it when I tell
them to use like really small stick rod
and travel fast.
I don't know.
That's not the most efficient way.
It's like might be the only way to pass
the corrosion test.
There's no promotion test. Yeah,
a customer.
Welders have to have a welding season to
accommodate. Anybody go smoking,
go out there and make a good look.
Go out with it. It's bicycle machine.
We do every housing.
It was pretty cool. I've heard that one.
Yeah, I'll look it up.
Vice President.
Yeah.
Call me.
So this one was like 160 feet in the air
inside slack, yeah.
Laser well, yeah.
Can we add off the screen a little later
on? Machine. Yeah,
they're becoming to be more and more
popular.
They have machines too, yeah.
It'll be interesting,
so a lot after the Megan TIG and there's
all kinds of.
The question becomes how long will the
President say?
Because laser welding is using the
welding. Yeah, pretty much. Yeah,
I guess ASM code is not allowed to use
your toxin as well.
So.
Used. I'll take it.
Yeah.
Reference.
OK.
I'll find it.
On video, just didn't let me go.
Still,
they're making 100% because they have the
people that have this process basically.
Do not have there's a full function like
social we have to give you thousand time
of the public trade order.
The.
This person, but I'll even start.
This is what I was about here.
Everything's done.
It should tell what's the interface.
So this is what you got to find.
Yeah, it's not done. I thought issue. No,
like it's not done since.
To go to January 1st.
Well,
the the site just needs to take me to my
the login site to do a job.
Steelgb.com Yeah,
it should just be steelgb.com.
Yeah, that works.
If you want the fabricator's website,
it's masterdashsteel.net.
So what are they doing? Structural. Oh,
they're the ones that developed this.
Yeah, yeah.
But what did they do? It's visible. Yeah,
you know, due to the, I mean,
the finished and so on that.
We just said it.
Get us.
What should we just get back to you on
these four meters?
Reply.
Good.
In the meantime.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I know we're going to do it.
We discovered this.
OK.
Should be close up in the hours.
It's talking to Jim, Jim,
you're talking to Jerry,
probably not sure I texted him.
Should we just message reporting this?
We sure we need this.
See what he asked me back.
What are you saying?
I don't need to be here,
but they send me the info.
But yeah,
you said just this is the Danny's lead.
This is the Kevin you didn't even test
and see what's expected. OK,
but I don't share this one.
Yeah, that's a lot of did.
That's the budget.
Gotta get it next 1271 we messaged in the
messaging.
Did you get that objection number I heard?
Well, that's in a month, yeah.
Well, I want to get there. Steve wants to.
They followed me since I heard.
I got projects and then when he's not
that setting do not that was like each
individual trade.
Each individual trade needs to separate
report that went from 5 to 11.
So yeah, Gary,
that's about because he is saying that I
was being, you know, we have three.
I asked Gary and Chris to see if someone
could be an important for us.
Sorry.
I got the back up.
It's the outing solutions. Yeah,
on the charts. Oh, that's that.
Successful in programming electrical
training. It's exciting.
I did have to suddenly modify this file
to add a different column for growing in
there, but I just imported everybody.
Oh sweet. So.
The keyboard and admin plan is the minute
for this.
Um.
Like, I guess.
They bring this.
I have what I have to whatever you have
to your project.
Oh.
Sure there's there's definitely different
aspects that you can add in the summary.
I don't know if it's something we can add
as a default though.
So account, account,
would you do that or would you see?
But if you're doing 109 hours of graphic
labor, 25% add 25%, so $25 for admin,
we see what the cost is and then figure
out and add on to the.
Yeah,
I think it would cost to cover that part.
You just keep them one by half, I guess,
yeah.
Yeah,
because most of that we factor outside of
outside of the system. Yeah,
they actually push us there.
Obviously.
Sons.
Oh.
Do you need to stop?
Oh.
It's.
Yeah, and then the bonds change.
Oh, excuse me.
We'll do that or he doesn't want to do it.
No.
1.
Yeah, that's all you have to do. Yeah,
there was a there's one,
one column that was missing here.
So I I ended up taking his main mark
column to the.
Uh, everything on important daily bill.
So hopefully we'll definitely have.
In the in the process, targets would be.
Just making sure some of these can.
Let's say yes,
quite a few bars that we can in here.
I mean,
and you do think that I would say you
could buy all the two further. Yeah,
probably have a little bit less
optimization, but at least.
Yeah, I'm sorry, so.
But yeah, if that was,
that was my process on it.
So something like considering we are and
so on,
I can probably just combine and see it
all the way through all.
So why don't we just run here?
I'll just skip something.
So I think he was working something right
now and I guess maybe beginning of the
year.
I thought they were like virtually
waiting for it to feel like can we get
this done now?
I wouldn't surprise me usually it's it's
kind of part of the second time I played.
You know, make make it seem that way so.
Depending upon how much work you need to
do in the background to get that Excel
file,
we'll look at it as whether or not we're
going to add an actual add benefit to
this. Well,
I'd love to be looking into those parts
and we don't know what the total quantity
here was.
Trying to get all these loaded up without
the cards would be the pain in the ***.
Or they we think they're doing this by
hand in the other shop,
just one inside or something.
Yeah,
the other shots made more for the we
can't send through us,
so it wouldn't make sense.
We do the processing and suddenly build
their carts, run all that stuff out.
So you just drop parts of the.
See you in one.
So it's a seven dollar display.
And actually we don't want the separate
even.
So a couple of guys who stay here and
these are super simple to assemble.
So this room used to be this room,
the panel shot and used to be and.
What are the words and that whole wall
used to be the roll of the words.
We installed a new roll of the origin
panel shop fell through this.
It's kind of kind of a silly little facts
you can't do and then and then send it
into this swapped it back to the door and.
Oh.
And that used to be just a closet with
added storage because so.
Starting with Modeler and I own office in
Modeler and then I went to a pretime and
was there for 3 or 40 years and I was
back here.
You're gonna build an office above the
shop overlooking the.
That was, uh, that was a good idea.
Never left to be on a new stage.
I'm going to.
See.
Oh, you're going to see.
You gave me another way to run that last
thing. Oh yeah.
Run,
but I think I think I'd be able to do
something. I figure it out.
I tried to open it and it didn't work,
but then I opened my computer.
The morning I came out of him and there
was a weird file on the bottom.
I almost said it was trying to run after
a long time.
Hello.
I'll do some more investigating.
I don't get out here at 6-7 o'clock and I
get a point here or no.
Just spend the night. Yeah,
and a few dogs that I'll let it consider.
Well, passive freaking house yesterday.
The problems.
Yeah, yeah, I had. I had my.
Yeah, I was like, you know.
OK.
Do you want bug shell when you put the
shot in your ***, chief or.
I'm currently going through running
everything through,
so I did the important creating the cuts
right now,
combined everything through in the
purchase order speed bid.
I'm making the cuts right now.
And then we can smell that to me and say.
It's normally good.
Here's all the records documentation
required. If this is what you want,
once I do get after the confirmation,
know that the electrical database portion
is working, then I'll take this exact,
you know, copy it, put it in there.
So that they and you can see it stopped.
But oh,
I see the home site that we went through
here somewhere.
So I didn't think it wasn't going. Yeah,
that's.
I'm still very.
That's what we've gone through it.
Yeah, that's.
Open this.
Select.
No.
List.
Yeah.
I think we want them to see if they like
this where they have type of training.
This statement established for cutting
people.
Oh.
I think too, if I'm not mistaken,
in permissions they help.
There is. Or maybe it's coming.
You can set somebody's default workshop
so that they don't see their stuff, yeah.
It might be.
It's not going to be working what it was.
Yeah. OK. You know,
we're going on the speed.
Which one of the bed it is? It's OK.
Is the day before young here?
No story.
And usually, I think,
but usually I'll be someone in the office
like it's.
Yes, but there's not one thing.
OK.
What type of music I expected me to be
listed? What were you expecting? How?
How was it was expected at Lake Park?
Lake Park?
I was at Lake Park even though I only
like old Lake Park. There you go.
We never really knew old country,
new country, EDM.
There's only two kinds of music. Western.
That's it.
I said I can listen to anything except
jazz. I just don't get jazz.
So yeah, it's just like,
how can I play it as off as possible with
still maybe consider I still like classic,
yeah.
I went to see James Taylor. Oh,
do you at Red Rocks, Denver. I was like,
I heard he'd be so old,
but he felt a good show.
I saw him last year. He did like 3 songs.
I didn't get a hurricane back in North
Carolina.
Well,
I did a big concert in Charlotte with a
bunch of big big one.
He was one of them there.
He'd like 30 more. He's, you know,
rarely he is impressive.
I think he's 74 or something. Yeah,
but if they have, it's just.
Really good, yeah.
He's awesome.
I saw that Eagles last year.
That was really good. I'm really,
really very bad.
I haven't seen anybody in the spirit.
You're inside them, right?
We got all these custom ornamental panels,
metal panels.
The company that I just left, they didn't.
OK.
Yeah, I'd like to go in there.
I haven't did it myself. It's a uh.
It's a production, you know, it's, I mean,
my daughter's a responsive.
They won't let you stand there in the
concert because they're afraid you're
going to fall over.
So you have to sit in the concert.
It's great. You know, Vince, he'll say it.
He hates playing. He's like,
I've never been ignored by so many people,
because I said looking up and watching me.
And that should be OK.
You're getting all these dumped into here
from the electrical side,
so that we can use it to estimate that
project with that thing. No,
it's for processing.
I think it's just for processing.
I don't take any. OK.
If all that was set up because we're
purchasing that and for nesting, yeah.
I'm sure it's the best thing part that he
really wants to.
That's why I'm surprised that he wasn't
going to just ruin it here when the
jacket we were losing power cloud.
But.
Once I'm done with the text count.
857 assemblies and 2571 parts and that's
rods in industry, yes.
It snap.
2000 lbs of brackets. Yeah. I mean,
it looks just super simple. Yeah,
that's why I was wondering if, yeah,
can you run this? I thought it helped.
I see it.
Said. What would you guys do on your saw?
You can just change your blade out for
this.
That depends. Obviously,
if we're running a specialty metal and
stainless, yeah, we'll we'll switch out,
but I guess we're about on cutting too.
So more than likely that,
but I could imagine that the blades you
use for being do a good job cutting units.
Yeah,
probably going for a little bit finer of
a tooth, right?
It's it's jagged as we have.
OK.
Yeah, I got the bundle coming apart.
It's just if that saw is working,
interrupting it, you know,
you better just run it for a day and
change the blade and do it.
By the way, there is a limit in that list.
Oh yeah, yeah,
I found that out a few weeks ago,
so I closed it out.
Some of your closed projects would be new,
but there is a.
Yeah,
that'll be that'll be the one that's in
the filter list when he's looking at jobs,
I see.
So I guess to the question that jobs
don't automatically close when they ship,
the jobs do not better.
Everybody seems to want them done.
I didn't even close them until I got a
change. I didn't. That's what I'm used to.
Yeah, yeah,
or the leadership develops for it.
They don't automatically close at all.
Yeah,
our system we use automatically close on
shipment.
The invoicing people would have to open
it back up to.
To the file.
I imagine you can set the clothes on
wherever you want to close.
I'm curious.
Picklet probably has just one right there
in the blue.
Yeah, this one. It's here.
Then open up one of those and um or hit
the eyeball next to one line.
I'm curious about the public cutting.
And hit process.
The last one of the one that might be the
only thing is you know how how we
identify which ones you can bundle,
which ones you couldn't.
So you you you the only way to find out
is really go into the eyeball on one of
those and process like.
We did that it tells me to tell you what
over.
Yeah.
Yes, that's a that's a one.
So the logic's not in here to make sure
that it does that. No,
because you know when they build it's
like building a structural environment
and you know it's it's not often you're
building on that and so but it will allow
you.
So if if it sees so many bars up that are
identical,
they don't give you a quantity up here.
There's like 14.
So you can say I've got four,
four of those together right there to
process all four bars.
It's interesting that they've got 5 and
three eights, five and a half,
five and five eights.
But there must be was a little bit of
slope in that building or something.
Well,
I guess what I'm saying is you could
really get those very easily mixed up,
'cause they're just so slightly different,
yeah.
Now if you had stick out allowance in
your nuts,
you could probably eliminate all those
different lengths.
And just let the extra stick out and hang
below your dents. Yeah, that there we go.
That we're getting some more.
So if we could, you know,
somehow identify.
Did you see how close that works and what?
Oh, that's the drop. Yeah.
So if I go back and go here, see,
these are 10 foot six, three,
one part of the bar on these 20 first.
We'll get back to this challenge that I
made.
Easy to.
Yeah, I took that to the four foot. Yeah,
I got it. Those are just drops. So yeah.
So if you so you went for 20s,
but is it you could create a stop list of
less than two and twelves? Yeah, yeah,
I combine it against 20s and twelves and
once again the 20s.
Or but it's always looking for the low
usage factors, so it's gonna try and.
What's the 9595 and 7-8 you're dropping
it? Yeah, that's you. That's the problem.
Yeah, we're having a slot ahead for it.
I remember to pick back for this 10 foot
six. Yeah,
I think 12 makes sense here because
you're dropping way too much.
Yeah, that's weird. Oh,
that's that's not wrong.
And found anybody, like if you need any,
you know we have 144 for.
Good goal. Finish. Yeah, exactly.
So seems to be seems to be functioning as
intended. Yeah, let's see.
Only thing I want to figure out is like,
you know, how I would know, you know,
if I would go out there today, how,
how would I know what I can bum the cut?
I don't know. Who do you buy?
This one was wrong.
That's what they wanted to ask Jimmy is
if it was was a threaded end.
Is it a threaded end?
I don't know if the douglas shot as a
threader.
I don't thread the bottom parts of these.
Or if it needs to be bought as all
threads,
or we'll buy it up from Duncan and off
thread, I think it's right there.
That's why would you think it's Duncan
stone.
No.
I'd be surprised if David's at the end.
It'll be so much later.
It should just be all for a you thing and
you have full adjustable capabilities on
that.
But I've seen crazier things, so.
You gotta say it.
You would think that there's a supplier
that just supplies us all out of the past.
He was driving with all grids and
freaking support about that.
I'm pretty sure I can find somebody who
is also,
but maybe that's the he's not going to
get into.
They got to hope that somebody looked to
see if they can buy now and then they
said, well,
for this quantity we can do it way,
you know, for half the price.
Yeah,
or the lead time is 3 months and we need
it in three weeks.
Yeah,
I I don't see any issue with doing this
thing. I don't know why they were curious.
Well, I mean,
this is we've ran the money initial
projects through here and a lot of this
is freaking night and day for anything we
run.
Yeah,
that's may I get as big as the XL import.
I've given that example XL imports the
same report we came up.
So would you take the time in their
database to get rid of that half inch rod
and put the right stuff in so it gets.
Yeah, I mean, if it was all thread,
I guess just going here and switch to all
threads,
it's gonna keep the same and keep the
same logic.
So time we're going from a linear to a
plate, so and going here.
Percent all three of the run and no half
inch.
It's not that that's in my lane category.
I'm going to keep it the same length so
it should be offered the same amount
across the board.
So in that one I can get a 144 so but I'm
going to get 24 so.
Did you need the head of piece tracking
or reports? We need the default,
but you have the default default for that.
So piece tracking is on for everything
from all the routing and assembly routes
and the apartments, OK.
So and then so now now we have cut saw
and burn routes that are just for parts
and then we have taken Weld for the main
assembly.
Gotcha.
Yeah, I'll change that so that I can do.
This.
Should have an issue.
And.
OK.
OK, all good.
Say confirm alternative.
Even though it'll be long.
He's one of the landlord. Yeah,
that's what I remember you say. Well,
that's what I have.
Yeah,
we were in the house room or a pardon.
I was in the town of Chandler and I'll
never hear the end of the fact that I
forgot to like **** *** my twill with you,
so.
It's freaking making my wife clean ****
*** the toilet seat for you. I was like,
I'm freaking telling you. Sorry,
I forgot I was freaking moving.
Ever since then, he is to be my boss.
Jimmy is to be my boss and my mentor for
the longest time.
Jared was my boss and Jimmy was my boss
and Mark became my boss.
Start.
But my interview was I don't want to work.
You work hard. You have a job.
We'll figure that out on Monday.
We'll see you at 6:00 AM. All right.
That's when I got all the books for Fab
Troll and I just started reading.
And yeah, once I figured that one out,
then this one was a lot easier.
A lot more, more videos for it.
That's very that's the damn share.
Well, it's a lot more flexible,
but you got 40 ways of doing the same
thing. They could take for 20 more.
Here's what you did there, left to right,
the last name, yes, but it was good.
Yeah, especially estimating.
It's hard to get estimated. Yep, but.
I also had to do all my manual well
take-ups,
all I have freaking binders of drawings
and I'd be going through calculating the
wells. Everything else is easy.
I get all that stuff done with the well
take-ups over and over and I go to each
drawing.
Well, this might be interesting.
So this is the last I'm over shop next
month that I had originally set it up
with this 2-3 years ago and.
They're an estimator wanted to majorly
put in every building here.
It's in the labor case.
Let it do the things that he was adamant.
He went through there and they had a set
of estimators and all of them were
banging like, why are we doing this?
Why are we having that?
So it's taking 400 long to do this,
you know.
I will be curious to see if we're still
doing that. That's.
That's some as we say.
Pre-2020, yeah. Well, for me, at least,
yeah,
20/18/2019 was all fast roll for me and
then in 2020 was when we had end of life
fast roll and we bought Tesla and we were
basically.
You know where they get to the point
where they're like, Papa,
we ain't facing ****. Yeah,
duplicate this **** over and you're using
this. I don't care. I was like, OK,
I guess I'll learn it. And usually people,
when people say, yeah,
we're working on that and we're facing it
in,
because they're not really going to do
anything.
I love going to shops and say, all right,
guys, Monday, here's where we're starting.
So I'm good.
I'm just the one to down and then I'll
figure it out. Yeah, well,
that's how it wasn't this. When I started,
I had full permissions. I had everything.
So it was like, oh, I wrote that.
OK, yeah,
now I'm gonna figure out how to fix it
and it's good. OK,
that's how you figure things out.
You break it and then you got to fix it
and now I'm sure that works for it.
So yeah,
which now I now I know a lot of different
ways to do a lot of different things in
here. Yeah, honestly,
we're going to treat this the only thing
I've.
And then we're really fussed with and and
have the ability to be. Most people,
though I I had to use it, but yeah,
most people are there too.
I don't think anybody served my own shop.
Small projects and running them myself.
Our break off was if it was detailed,
it was a production job.
It wasn't detailed if it was,
but we did all some residential meetings
for some local contractors.
We probably ran a couple $1,000,
000 worth of stuff through the order
engine. It was great for, you know,
pull the inventory and it would, yeah,
we could create the invoices out of here
and so it was good for that kind of stuff,
but.
It's 100% paper driven that you can't do
anything on getting with it or anything.
So oh, I was going to ask you,
I was trouble with the mentions this year.
It was good because it was it gets better
every year. I tried to get them to do.
More sessions. I did two sessions.
But I figured, yeah,
the more sessions they do,
the more people come. But yeah,
that's good. That's good. Yeah.
And probably I was supposed to build.
Yeah.
And then long roll they're going
percentage per Vista. Oh really?
And they had a whole,
a whole topic that they were speaking on
and how they have Vista integrated with
the PTO system and and doing all that.
Yeah, but.
But.
Anyway, it should be gone.
It should be me. Yeah,
I guess the cool thing about it is,
you know they they are there to help.
They want to hear from you and what you
want. And so like they did one session,
we'll bring up,
we'll bring up the video on it,
but they did one session where it's like,
OK, here's what's coming,
tell us what you think. Yeah,
although their thing was,
here's what's coming.
We're a little promising, but you know,
here's what's coming, you know,
because I can't really say what's coming
outside of the current folder anyway,
they're doing.
Yeah, OK,
restrict user cut lists and work packages
by location. So that's yeah,
multiple shots.
They they always see their shots though.
Um.
Oh, estimating this one. This was mine.
I made good for this and I had multiple
meetings with him about it.
They're a study I'm estimating so that
you can get a breakdown by.
Multiple different things.
I'm not sure about how we're doing it yet,
but what I asked them is in the estimate
summary,
you can hit the summary drop down at the
top and choose cost. It'll get.
It'll break the estimate down by cost,
which you're not really using.
But I I I asked him there,
I want to have an option there for
category, subcategory page,
give me a custom field,
but I need some way to break down the
estimate cause like if if.
Client is like,
I need a I need a dollar for this
building at that building.
I was going to say,
get three or four buildings,
you know what I said.
All four of those buildings. Yeah.
And it's going to be able to do that.
You don't really have a way of doing that.
Yeah.
That's the codes when you have to say,
put it in building A, B, C, D, whatever.
So it's permanent over there.
That's the way that's what happened.
So I shouldn't be able to.
Multiple workers thought it on the same
basis for happening.
You will be able to say nothing ships on
my side is complete,
which I've never done a thing,
but that'll be an option,
which I haven't looked for a little.
To be able to attach documents on the
loading screen when you're sharing.
Some of the matrix, yes. You're going,
you're going to be able to finalize when
you receive on together if you want to.
I don't have any reporting in there.
Everybody does.
I got stuck with every single one we've
ever done at this company. Yeah. Oh,
you know how to do that? OK.
I was like, no, I didn't, but now I do.
It's the assembly lane is going to become
more prominent as well.
I've kind of think we're talking about a
20 foot length of slice,
so the assembly length is going to be
more prominent there.
Where we use a lot of reports in order as
well. So, but that, you know,
they have recession where it's like,
how should we do this?
What should we be able to do this?
And that type stuff.
So picking user's brains. Yeah.
Figure out what the real world's thinking.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's.
I could care less of this in Vegas.
That's a perk. But yeah, I wanted to.
I've always wanted to go.
I asked every year. Yeah.
It's a that's an expensive conference,
man.
It's like 1700 bucks a person or
something like that, which, you know,
all in all, it's worth it. But you know,
it's it used to be like 600 bucks,
something like that.
Yeah, absolutely. But I need to do this.
That's one of the reason I speak,
because we're 700 knowledge when I speak.
That's perfectly the same.
Yeah, there we go.
They're going to send me and Bob and I
was like, I don't care,
send me no one to be on the Bravo project
and then they went to that.
A convention in Chicago for all the
equipment Fabtech. Yeah,
and we had like 5 guys in the Fabtech and
then spent all this money going up there
with getting the equipment we were never
going to buy. And they were like, oh,
this kind of just seemed like a waste.
Yeah, that was a waste.
We knew that was a waste when we got into
it.
Careful dimensions wouldn't have been a
waste.
I was taking notes I would have and tried
to have a good take away from it.
That was that was purely knowledge that
is truly.
Yeah, right. Unless,
unless you've got a serious buy off for
some equipment before you go into it,
you ain't going to go there and and say,
well,
I found that half a million dollar
machine I really want.
We think we can do this.
Maybe, yeah,
we used to send to people every year.
Like, yeah, I don't think so. Well,
you already do.
A lot of the vendors come see you anyway.
Benefit is if you are shopping for a
bunch of, you know, starting to shop,
you see everybody. Yeah.
So that was a GT that was here the other
day. Is that correct? Yeah, that that is.
Who's looking to bond?
Who's Who's still needing to do all that?
Mark. Mark through. Yeah,
here's what here's who visited.
Something to consider. Yeah,
I need to talk to Mark because I was all
in on the line on that.
I traveled to their place in Canada to
check them out, talk with the programmers.
I love that issue. Yeah,
what's it good for?
So it is a robotic building,
but it's it's well known.
It's not it's not sure unless you have
you have to pack it in it and then you
put it in its space which rotates and.
Then you download from the instructions
for us and give directly to their
software. It runs things saying OK.
Yeah,
I can tell what's the best way to build
this. Yeah,
I reach everything that I'm living in
here, attention, training,
the well site can't do.
Maybe say here's what I want to do.
So like.
We need the first piece that we ran on a
bunch of 12/12/5568 students and to the
14 minutes to run that up. So it's.
We had, we had a 60 foot,
60 foot sale that we that she for that
one it was 40.
We we we did a 40 footer at first.
So the arm had reached 20 feet or the
carriage moved. So yeah,
the carriage moved.
So the you put the I'm familiar with it.
Yeah, you put it.
It looks like we're tracking, right.
You put it in there and the computer
would would be down here where it would
be down the other area, the well,
and then there'd be a lot based on the
other side.
Yeah, well,
not necessarily on the station.
It just ran a little track to the other
side of the poop. So, well,
I looked at clues.
Clues makes something like that and you
know, while it's welding,
you want the other side.
Somebody's setting it up and the ones I
saw were rotating,
so it would rotate the piece in this
thing. Well, exactly what you said.
On the other side,
they're loading the next piece in.
So they they we we bought the one cell to
start with.
We bought a single cell thing and so it
it was a 40 foot.
43 million that was in and so one piece
was in there.
Then when that was done pulling out
through another piece in and then it was
our welding idea.
Their brand and butter that they tried to
sell you is a 2 cell thing.
So you got one piece here,
one piece in here.
So off welding on this piece,
you're over here packing up on this.
Yes. And then once none of it goes out,
we pull this left the middle,
we'll start packing it up.
It to me wasn't worth the money because
like we would tack up,
we'd have a Bay and the brothers on this
side,
we would tack up on this side and then
while it's welding and then bring the PC,
pull this piece out,
bring another PC into it.
I didn't feel like it was worth an extra.
$100,
000 and get another area for us to pack
up. Yeah,
I just didn't see the benefit except for
work, maybe about, you know.
5 minutes of time to pull the piece out
in another lead.
How many pieces were you running? So are.
Like on those 12 square columns,
which a lot of that was from red and
furniture,
we were getting about 28 columns a day or
shifts, excuse me, 28 columns a shift.
So how are you going to do?
How do we have to do?
Like, uh, 10,000,
I mean that that was really a bit better
than most of the jobs we're doing
services cost a little bit. So OK,
so so it makes sense because we're doing
it forever. Yeah, trying to find,
I got a video of it early, but.
There was always just how many pieces do
you have to judge by the cost of it? Yeah,
first the set up of it. I mean,
if you're doing something all the time,
it would do the work of about 3 1/2 to 4
revolution.
So yeah, it was.
It was worth the money and I think we've
made like, I know it's gone up since then,
but I think we've made like $600,
000 for it.
Um.
That's so worth.
A good machine.
Yeah, there's fair,
fair and weld options out there,
but they're going to be double or triple
the money too.
And we were striving all the all the
pieces of the layout and fill up was
nothing, you know,
pretty much just put the line on the on
the main piece and we took a job for a
solar farm once and it was thousands of
the same thing and yeah.
We had one of those Lincoln machines.
Yeah,
we had a table that rotated on this side.
So we well on this side,
well on this side. Yeah,
there was table on this side,
well on this side, well on this side.
I think we probably put 6 or 8.
I'll call them columns.
They were a small piece of.
And you're literally, for most of them,
as the welding was so quick, yeah,
that you really just hadn't got all your
parts taxed.
You know, everything had to get there.
We weren't barely attacking it.
The the biggest problem we were having is
it was finicky,
but the piece had been exactly in the
right place.
And I hear that the vision system would
have gotten better.
And so the vision, if it wasn't there,
it would stop. Yeah,
the AGT will do that too.
It feels it scans at first.
It is actually it scans at first with
pieces of there and then it'll stop.
The simple little flapper right there
just popped in and it just it's scanned
in that wall and and then the tube.
So even if the tube is slightly there,
it is.
OK, I don't know.
So that thing with we had one within the
first month or two that we were just
going full board with it and and that
well with this side and then it was going
down to the other side.
Somebody broke it and I'll stop.
And that big carriage was going down and
I'll stop the cool.
And so I called them and I'm like, guys,
we got a big problem here.
We got a lot of work in this.
I told them what happened and I said we
called them back, so.
30 minutes later, he called them.
That's it. I have a flat look.
I have a part in my hand.
I'm carrying them with me.
Can we get your? Absolutely.
And so they fixed it overnight and got us
back. So what's this thing that I do?
Is this column going to rotate or is this
mark going to re fix?
First got we we needed it so bad and they
were like, OK, rotators are not ready.
So we're like we put it up on bucks for
now.
So this was before we had the before we
had the rotators.
So you're going to have to rotate this
thing four times. Yes.
So it it's always well and flat. Sure.
And so yeah, it would.
Rotate four times. So yeah,
so we can integrate the rotator. Yeah,
with our this was quite the pain.
So but yeah,
then we got the rotators about a month
after that and then once it goes in there,
yeah, it just rotates it on its own. So.
How much was that 600,000? There was 600,
000 when we bought it,
but I'm hearing it's 8900,
000 or something like that.
I believe I'm for sure,
to be quite honest with you,
the full cross bear.
I mean, I like clues.
Clues was pretty fancy, yeah.
The thing I was most concerned about was
whether we were.
How easy was it gonna be to get the?
From the software into their software,
from detailing into their software, I was.
I didn't want to put somebody else on
payroll just to do that, you know?
And it was.
Honestly, seamless.
It's literally an export import.
Yeah,
it includes the ones all that German
welding equipments and I was like,
do you guys stop,
get over this ship in the US in case
something goes bad?
Somebody here,
I'm waiting for consumables from Germany.
But they were awesome. They were awesome.
And this was pre COVID when I was looking
at it, yeah.
OK, so I don't know that he was in here,
but I can go over with him,
but I kind of want to be going to the.
Production planner or future production,
current production work packages,
so on and so forth.
I think that's what they're able to build
that into. Yeah, OK.
So then we do some set up already on it
to get it kind of set up for departments
and stuff. Yeah, yeah,
I know what we did and what we didn't
then.
So we have our code.
And then handling cuts on burning fit,
well, assembly,
comfort stone and unplanned handling and
quality control. You see that there.
It's still down so we can see the future.
So that's where you can now do. OK,
we just got this job. It's 5500 hours.
So this time frame and then we'll plug it
in there for you and your schedules for
you'll have it on there for future
planning.
So essentially, is this just like a form?
Form fill ordinance? So yeah,
you'd have to have the job in later.
How does it?
How does it know the resources?
It pulls it from estimating,
which is why it's so critical that in
estimating they use the labor codes like
we were looking at because it it knows
all those different departments and
everybody knows to split out.
So it pulls it from estimating so.
But it also clearly must somehow know how
many people you have in each in each work
center, right? Yeah,
so there's a resource setup,
so like cuts also in the hours.
Actually,
that's gonna be in production control and
then fabrication maintenance.
Yeah, they gave a appointment.
Uh, they go to workshop first.
That's where you set up your shots.
And your different work areas.
Can we set up work areas?
OK, OK, that's cool. close this and then,
yeah,
go to go to the part of the maintenance.
One of the things we were trying to do is
try to run schedules by days.
So that certain bays just didn't move
because they had long term projects in it,
certain bays moved.
You could essentially do that here.
So yeah, right here,
like handling is set for 60 hours a week
and then cut saw at 60,
so on and so forth.
So you you can build that out here.
You can build multiple shifts if you want
and whatnot.
In different work areas.
So like you can have if that is in
multiple bays, you can do work here.
It needs to have different bays.
Like I was a shot a couple weeks ago.
I was really having work in their shop
about which bays at the end of the last
time you guys have got to do.
Acid even so they we set up a different
phase. So yeah,
it's real time against the wanding.
It is.
It doesn't really look at the hours that
you have been work.
It's looking at pieces that are done so
to whether it's closed down.
So it's not even looking at this.
This schedule is not even looking at the
hours,
it's looking at the hours planning for
some your capacity.
But whatever you work is whatever you
work,
it's it's just planning the work that's
never done so.
So the plan is man hours or the plan is
pieces plan is it.
It could be done by man hours or orphans
and you could and you could set both of
them up and talk between the two so you
can see either one.
Yeah, our intention and it's.
Essentially.
Because our word package is.
To build this to populate the hours in
here and then go into the selection
planner and drop these work packages in
by week and we can see how resources
begin to get to use the hours that are.
Mobile.
Well, and that's why I would be.
Really nice to get it linked up to
estimating,
get it linked linked up to estimating.
So there's an average to show up in here
without somebody,
I guess Mark or somebody having to sit
there and say, well,
what kind of split do I think this is,
you know, estimating.
And what was the toggle that says this is
a likely job to land or because obviously
you know all of them. Yeah,
but the way they built this initially it
was only work that you had released.
Now they've got it dealt with.
With where it's like I've been waiting at
this job and I don't have as many hours
in this time frame and then as releases.
So I'll put that on the schedule so you
know to plan for it and but as you get
releases it, it reduces that plan work,
right?
So it it will take those hours and reduce
it there.
But so let's say you've got your released
work and let's say you've got your landed
work, which is the released yet,
but it's coming and now you want to say
if I take this job, what happens?
Yeah, you can do that. Yeah.
So you can put in a future job as a what
if somebody did and put it in there and
say, hey,
what does this do for me ever that kind
of thing? Yeah, it's gonna cool.
We have to do that in Microsoft Project.
It's a pain in the ***.
Because you're going in through schedule
leveling and then you level some and
they'll level others and and somehow I
have to kill myself. Yeah,
this doesn't do type of leveling.
So it's not going to be like, OK,
I can schedule four times to work,
four times my capacity if I want to.
It's not going to level it for you.
It's going to force you to make those
decisions for it, you know, so,
which is good in a lot of ways,
but always too, right?
So my role is always to take a lot of the
future and easy work. If it's hard work,
you better think about it really hard,
yeah.
In in in this industry, it's hard to say,
OK,
just let all this happen because
everything works, right?
Let it all work and it should be OK, so.
No,
these probably need to be adjusted
because when we set this up in July,
we have a different amount of employees
to get in July.
Are you having to use this at all or?
Pretty much said nothing and then
whatever. Yeah, that's what we did.
So I mean, we can run with it right now,
now that it's at and then once Mark gets
in here,
we can kind of go through of like
handling.
I guess 60 hours a week. I mean,
I guess you're not handling movie. Well,
the channel's there too.
It's in order for that,
instead you got to have a station for it.
That's right. And it's like.
It's not like you're processing the
handling station for a job,
so it's hard to have that on the schedule,
so.
But for me, I only ever looked at it.
That's it. Well, yeah, I was like,
handling,
we'll we'll get more people to do this
stuff right now. Yeah, yeah.
Well, you know,
we can always cut it because cutting and
the subcontract cutting was not even
about Oregon either, yeah.
So go back to your work packages and read
the planner up again then.
Or you can get it right down to 12.
Yes.
So the idea is you got week by week here
and then you're able to pull these
packages over and drop it in a week.
Then when you do that,
it's got a breakdown of the of the hours
by department.
So you go to the department view,
which is up there next to the Riggs
workshop before, yeah, or that way,
either way.
Hit the little square up there.
So now we got a breakout by the part of
here.
What are we looking at there on?
So is that a day by day? That's a week,
a week over there, yeah.
And then so in that week there's the
packages for cuts all the packages for
burn.
And then you're like,
is this actually working? So like,
when you first drop it into a week,
it's probably going to drop, cut, saw,
burn, everything all in the same week,
right? Well, that's not going to happen.
You got to cut it before you fit it.
You got to fit it before you weld it,
right?
So then you might be moving these
packages around to say, OK, cool,
we're cutting it this week.
And burning it this week,
but fit well are going to be next week.
So you pull those down into the following
week or something like that. So it is not.
So in project you can have same star,
you know, after it's finished star.
Yeah, that's that's the reference.
This is a game chart platform like that,
which there is a game chart platform in
here, but not not on this schedule.
This is.
This is very,
very much you have to think through.
What's known we have so and it's not
gonna label that out for me so.
I mean,
what I'm hearing is it's a very manual
way of putting blocks and packages in
different places and then if you fill the
bucket up, you better move, adjust it,
adjust it. Yep, it is, I think.
Project will be faster then. Well,
you're totally disconnected from the from
the data.
So this actually does work well when you
when you start working with it,
especially I think with the packages
you're putting out there, I think.
I don't think you're moving it around and
you do a drug. Yeah,
especially the stuff we've been having
now. I mean,
it's 150 total dollar package,
$200 package like this TMC.
Fab three,
that one's 21 and almost 2200 hours, yeah.
So that one will be a little bit more.
And that one I'm probably gonna release
to the shop Monday of next week and we
have to have it done by 12.
The the advantage here is, yeah,
I might have to drag that down to another
week,
but I don't have to build the project
over there.
I don't have to build the schedule out of
Microsoft Project.
I don't have to build the the job out.
I don't have to build the hours out over
there.
I don't have to do any of that stuff
manually in Microsoft Project.
That's why nothing there.
That's that's a little, so.
So you're saying what,
12th of January you have to be done?
And then so you're basically giving
yourself 15 days more or less to produce
369,000?
Well, really, 2200 hours, Yeah.
Yeah.
Do you work here in tents?
And um, unless the work has justified.
So are you have a 1493? Yeah,
that's one of the. Sure, you've got 20,
any photo holidays? Yeah.
Maybe more.
Do you think that's hard for you to do
2200 hours by then? No, I think.
I think it'll be good. Honestly,
I I think,
I think it'll be cause that will be other
projects that will be.
So what's your trouble about, you know?
Literally nothing. I see. Yeah,
the only work that we have is whatever
would be Mark.
It was more than what we have to do.
I see. Really, this is only 100 jobs.
I mean, jobs coming from them.
Almost never. Almost never.
The only job we're winning is the job
that I'm estimating insecurity. Oh,
the 4% job we're getting,
they're not coming from.
Karaman, they're coming to you.
I haven't even seen Karaman.
I just heard that number for a crowd.
96% of the work that's, you know,
I'm shot from me and Mark estimating
reaching out to our contacts.
That's a great planning to tell me and I
can't remember the estimated field jobs
too. Yeah, they're estimated field jobs.
They're estimating.
They're they're doing it all the
estimating for anything.
Me and Mark are getting,
we get over to over.
You know, over for work for Sahuaro,
you guys just have it on the over for
work, big shots and yeah,
you're working with that son,
you know they're going back and down,
yeah.
That's fine, but it's over.
That's the way for the country.
That's what I'm asking.
That's what I was going to be asking your
question, but then your answer. Yeah,
they do.
But they give their plan for all the over
over the whole United States or just here,
however.
So the the stuff that it's for all around
the country.
Are they getting jobs for going to the
other parts of the country?
Sounds like it. Yeah. Oh, OK, yeah.
So the overall win rate though is 4%.
You deal with that if you do.
If you got a less,
you're getting enough jobs, but.
If we're trying to make it really big,
do you feel better?
That's the that's things are electrical.
I mean there's a big one, $50,
000 and and then you know at the same
timeline we want one $50 million
electrical.
So,
but I I don't really know what's going on
back on that. But yeah,
it's been me and Mark this entire year if
there's been a job in the shop,
me and Mark.
Sort it out, put a number against it.
So and it's all the stuff I've estimated.
So a lot of our a lot of our numbers that
are right on are Mark's landual take-off,
just my tech will take off and then us.
Or to retrieve that for us and because we
can't rely on estimating department.
So what's going on with the jobs like the
water treatment plants and stuff?
Who got those jobs?
These are estimating those up.
The PDE are doing it themselves or which
you want to be.
What kind of work are we doing now?
Honestly, this stuff. It must.
Mostly we happened. I said that maybe.
Camrails and canopies and graphic. Yeah,
camrails, canopies, swing rails, batters,
fence, man ways,
and the PDS are are they using tech load?
This is where a lot of them are using
previous data,
so so they'll take a lot of believe we
fabricated this like 36243648 inch rams.
We've got a.
We've done so many of those that they
know what we're going to throw 30 hours
in there and we're going to do 1500 bucks
in cost of materials and we need four of
them for this project.
It's all very surprising to me.
You know, it's hard to make.
It's hard to make a lot of money going to
hospital jobs.
I think you can wear yourself with that,
especially if it all shows up at you,
you know, like $10,000 jobs over one.
Five million more jobs.
It takes a whole bunch of time to manage
those 10100,000 jobs. Yeah, yeah,
a whole bunch. OK,
like I can manage a three to five million
jobs, the same amount, you know.
I want you to take.
It was under 100. Yeah, it better be 50%.
I think this is a packed habit because
otherwise it's not worth disrupting your
regular open business.
I'm scratching my head trying to figure
out some stuff.
Some of this stuff ain't have nothing.
But Lowen Rd.
to spot these guys in January, right?
Big master grand plan or something.
We're not worried. Well,
they just said that last night, right?
Did you guys see the grand plan?
I did see that. Yeah,
we're doing everything in red,
white and blue and this and then I got
all that.
That's good, buddy.
Where did I got one of the.
OK.
But may I do my work?
Yeah,
when we're supposed to be the the shining
star template for all the other shops.
So we're supposed to refine our tech,
get everything filed in and do it there.
I like that idea. That makes sense.
OK.
But me and Mark don't actively working
for work looking for work, you know,
3-4 days and best and and then we'd still
get a random package dropped in our lab
and then ask what we're doing like we're
doing kind of jobs that we can get.
Well.
That's the that's the thing. I mean,
you can do so much.
There's so many different things. I mean,
even even with even with the stuff we get
from the next level, I mean,
we're doing heavy structural work for
W&W through the next level and yeah.
And I mean,
one of our biggest constraints is I get
all those big materials and then I have
to get those subbed out process and then
they come back in and then they can fit
in well, but.
Otherwise,
anything over 30 inches were buoying
cuttings,
and anything over 30 inches were being
more level line on our.
Does this just take through that?
Thank you.
So a lot of a lot of refining to be done,
but I I I think you think that the tech
way is going to help.
I'm not as worried about that now.
I have jobs, I have equipment. Yeah,
you know,
it's like if they're going to go to all
the struggle to get with big jobs,
they've got to have a method of doing it
and it's just going to be they're going
to buy farming.
I just want to get a shuttle management.
She had a mill map that you can go.
Call your call, your beam line work here,
this work over here.
We're going to do a little bit of welding
here. Send the pack. I guess. OK,
now that I've been,
I get a sense that there's X amount of
fuel.
Right. And I say, OK,
in X amount of field work we're seeing.
Packages of fab. There's this one thought.
Let's grab more of those packages itself.
OK.
There's the other one that says in order
to self perform,
you got to have the equipment to do that.
You're actually going to self perform,
right? I think they're not.
I think they're going to buy a certain
portion of that. I'm curious. Yeah,
I'm curious.
1.
I would just.
Look at it. You know I would do it.
You know,
nobody really analyzes until Jeff came
here. Jeff's also analyzing.
That's why I know these things,
because he's told me.
But I think Chris and Jarrod kind of were
like, oh, we're only winning 4%,
but they didn't really realize that.
And so now the next thing is to me is
categorize what are we winning and what
are we losing?
Or are we losing a lot of stuff that we
could add a half million dollar piece of
equipment to win more of that? Yeah,
I understand.
But I think stepping into the world of
Bechtel is like 3 steps away.
First we got to take one step.
They're they're thinking they're going to
get the Bechtel job because of the time
constraint and they're going to be at a
higher profit margin.
Because the other,
the other companies bidding it arguably
at the time,
we can cram it together and equipment to
different places.
I think that's what they that's a
straction. Yeah, I think so. Yeah.
Problem is all the other places are
actually busy.
Yeah,
it was a guarantee that they got to stay
at the game too,
but cause I reached the steel beds.
Steel bed's busier in common.
They got backlog like crazy.
They always got backlog like crazy.
Large majority of our be mine work is
Saguaro.
Usually they are really pricey and all
this and all this out. Are they? Yeah.
I got to send my TSMC stuff over to them
before I think that's it this year. Yeah,
I gotta have it done.
I try to do it this year,
so so let's say they make a good job back
to.
Who are they going to throw all that
stuff out to?
Remember that the release date is not
till November of next year. I know,
but they got a certain portion of work
has to be done by March,
March of the following year.
So the following year 2027, 2027. Oh,
this is way in the future.
Yeah,
I don't know if everybody else realizes
that, but if you look at the schedule,
so they can do it then, then why?
Why are the standard team mining
companies not big enough? Maybe they are.
Yes, if it's near and halfway,
they can certainly do it.
I wouldn't think so.
And I think there may be a little bit
confusing that this has worked for this
March,
it has worked for next March and the
packages are not going to be ready until
next November.
That's why you only have 81 days and
about 7000 sons.
There's the time constraint is then it's
not because it's having parts that
they're going to,
but it's still next to a member.
So it's still very tight fabrication,
you know, so that's why they're thinking.
We're in the pump again.
We we can't in the Bectel scope of work.
Bectel deserves the right to award
packages at different values.
They don't have a split expect.
With.
So what's your questions here?
I think you're set up this road,
but what's what's the?
I guess our biggest questions were like
on future work is essentially the goal is.
Um.
Christie wants us in codings to be able
to go, OK,
we've got a project that we got awarded.
This is all the work we have active in
the shop and it's scheduled out.
We got a new project awarded.
And we want to try and plug that one in
the other system or even theoretical
something that's not ordered,
but we do not potential this many hours.
How do we plug that kind of stuff in so?
It would be a a bit hard considering you
still have to have the job number in
there and something that's not,
it's just going to money in the system or
at least making up the job number. Yeah,
I mean, you might even have a.
Fake job that's in there,
always that says you can plug in.
So it's within tech,
but this is the production plan.
You've also got a dance chart.
Are they linked? No. Oh,
are they good to do that?
They wouldn't do it. So now there's any.
We might want to get over and consider
something else.
There is a production schedule linked to
the project schedule that could be run as
well.
So the big point,
just more even is what I want and some
people just want to make 30,
000 for the year.
And I think we looked at that production
schedule, right? Yeah.
So this thing only runs your week at a
time. You can't do a month or whatever.
No, no, no. You guys already want.
You got five units more open. Yeah,
only one one week to show because there's
so many.
You scroll down and you'll you'll see the
other weeks, so.
Yeah, they're in development. Got it.
Yeah. So yeah, besides this one,
then you see there's two other. Yeah,
there's a Gantt chart one and that one.
The project schedule is a Gantt chart.
It's never been a Microsoft project.
I see that it's right here. Yeah,
we're looking at.
It's what we're looking at yesterday.
Yeah. OK, I see. Yeah. So now this can.
Automatically build a production schedule.
So like go to the drop down at the top
and go to production schedule.
Sure.
Um,
then when we got set up for resources
either with.
And then beside this, there's another one.
So this is the production schedule,
this length of the project schedule.
Basically it puts it out here and then
you can scroll out to the right.
You see week by week you've got a
capacity like for.
I've never seen this, really.
This is pretty cool. Yeah. And so this is,
it's not the production schedule for your
overall shop.
The production schedule by area on T,
by cut area, burn area and all that.
It's just kind of what we had over there
as well.
Right.
It's been a little bit more dynamic with
it over there. But this,
by doing the project schedule,
this pretty much just creates itself.
It sprays the hours out.
And this is only for one job. No,
for all jobs. All jobs, OK,
we we have a filter for one job.
But yeah, OK,
so can you put a dummy job in here then
if you want to say about, yeah.
Let's see like a good option.
Right click over there on the right or
just anywhere it says flaps off and then
like open up or open up welder,
whichever one you want.
Now there's all the jobs that are
contributing to the welding resource.
And it would say how many hours per job
each week gets a good on that.
Let's say I'm not these guys are running
the schedule.
I'm sitting wherever I'm sitting.
And I don't want to forecast when I had
test jobs, does it mess with their units?
If you put hours and stuff in there and
apply to it, then it will put it in here.
Yeah, but you can do a.
You can do a um.
It like I used to put in a paid job that
I just had a job that said what what did
I call it?
It was like I think I call it estimating
or something like that and I might have
50 limelines instead of working jobs we
might think we might get.
And I'm pulling in and out. I want to.
But when these guys lose their mind and
they see the schedule.
Yeah, but I mean,
most of the time I'm going to put it in
there just to see where it is. Yeah,
you have a special name.
They just won't include that particular
one.
It's not like you're going to drop
anything and leave it for two months,
right?
You don't drop it and you see what
happens, then you don't pull it out,
right? Yeah. Well,
I'm going to give you this one.
Now you drop it in there.
If your boss calls you,
you leave and walk away.
You forgot that you did it.
This guy's going,
my whole schedule just went tense up.
Can you can you say, oh, I mean,
you want these jobs, that schedule? OK,
you can just say, OK, I don't want those.
Yeah, I mean,
I have my own schedule because master
schedule never wanted me to mess with the
master schedule.
So this is tied to the project schedule.
The project schedule is each individual
project, right? Yep.
And then the first one we were looking at,
what's that called?
So the the production planner,
production planner, yeah.
So it's basically this,
but you can get much more five nights
with it if you want the production
planner. I don't think I'd use that.
I'd use this.
They they had,
they've had this for years and when they
want me the production planner, I'm like.
Wow, you got this for finance? Yeah.
I thought this was fun for workshops.
Yeah, I would think so too.
Says what workshops do you want? Yeah,
that's what I do. Or Microsoft Product.
Yeah.
Yeah, I like this.
And this thing has the has the ability to
do a start to start or finish to start.
This this particular program is like,
yeah, I like this. That would be good.
And you could put total available hours
if you wanted and then somehow we
calculate here's how many hours for all
the jobs for two weeks from now and
here's how many hours available.
So and then you tell OK,
I'm short or I'm over or whatever.
And if what it will do with that is it
does.
Let's say you put this job for four weeks
and you have 1000 hours.
It'll do 250 in each week.
It's just going to make it even, right?
But you do have the building going there
manually saying now $500 over the first
week they'll split it out, correct?
And you and you could bot try this every
week. I just pushed out. Yep, Yep.
And you know, I like,
I don't know for you guys.
You guys are already doing what needs to
be done for this.
You're already in scale,
which I'm wondering if you use this to to
see if it would be.
But we're not using it, right? Yes and no.
We right now there's only a couple weeks
worth of jobs,
so there's no really reason.
Right. But yeah,
when you've been really busy,
it's like for two or three months.
But the problem is,
when we're really busy,
it's like 30 tiny packages that are gonna
be in and out for oh, three days. Got it.
So it takes me longer to set up and it's
5 minutes.
And do all this and it does.
I see for it to it's process in the shop
and that makes a plumber would be easier
because it's it just happens to work
package.
I was told there used to be 50 guys right
here. Now there's 20 when you get 50 guys.
You have two or three months for the work
back then. Yeah. So at times like that,
it would be very useful for you, right?
Yeah, day and night shift. Yeah,
because I remember hearing it.
Back in our prime, but I I guess to me,
yeah,
what you use depends on what you're
trying to accomplish. Yeah,
if it's just I need to be able to look
and see.
Two months from now,
whether I have a hole where I can drop a
job,
you know this this might probably be
great if it's like, OK, this week,
what packages am I working on and what do
I need to work on first or the production
planner?
So who did the skid job for Iowa here or
Gilbert GTS? Yeah,
I'm really glad to know this is to be
personal, but I'm learning. Yeah,
it looks like Microsoft project only in
some ways.
I think it's a little better because it's
breaking it out.
By, you know, well, yeah,
automatically from what you have in your
estimate. Yeah, yeah. Or So what? What?
Yeah, it is.
So when you get an estimate and you get
the job, what does it take? Do you get?
When you get a job, so OK,
I want you to know what I'm looking at.
Is that the harvest of the site?
So all those hours.
It was all in their venison of your
project.
There's somewhat this confidence that
there has to be made with the nine hours
of overall opportunities.
I think it was maybe not that to be with.
You know, it's in the system,
but there's no schedule for it yet, right?
So then you should go into that project.
So everybody's schedule and then it shows
up on this.
OK,
so then you got to put in like a schedule
to build for this programming.
So then I would finally you'd also you
will be from the college screen business.
But you got to shoot sequences in there.
Yes, and it just marks all of that,
which isn't.
So even once you have the same time and
you'll just say, look,
even before you sequence it,
the thing was they got 10 million hours.
We put it in the schedule,
even being a sequence.
Yeah,
if you didn't have a sentence and
leadership, yeah,
they usually just have to say to say all
this in one giant seat.
It's still put in here.
I really want a sentence.
Yeah,
I think it's the least utilized part of
the system. It is.
It is a Microsoft project.
A lot of people are the one.
It's like I got a spreadsheet to
understand it. Yeah, just Brents,
you want to take some 3 seconds?
OK, the color of these boxes are here,
here and here,
and everybody hates their spreadsheet,
but they don't use it because they would
have to spend more than 5 minutes.
It's one easy to use the spreadsheet,
but this one kind of does it
authentically as long as you enter the
system directly.
It's already there, yeah.
So hopefully it really does depend to me
on your goal for scheduling. Yeah,
it depends on my mute.
I need to look and see what's happening
this week and move my packages around and
figure out.
What I need to do this week and next week,
yeah,
I'm the the planner is the tool for that.
This is the I'm saying that maybe not 30,
000 foot would be, but I'm saying that 10,
000 foot would be, yeah.
I have a feeling these guys,
pretty small amounts of work can do it in
their head.
If you've got a bunch of 2000 hour jobs,
you couldn't do it.
But well,
it sounds like a bad or it's only a
couple weeks right now.
So probably pretty easy. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
After January 12,
I'll be able to work it again,
trying to find more work in between here
and there. So, but yeah,
I guess we're having this work, you know,
all the regular.
Taters will be giving us overflow.
Your regular guys been coming to you all
the time.
That's good. Yeah.
We have a good report with all the
foundators and that, in my opinion,
that should be filling work that we
should have our own big dogs and that all
all that work that you guys are getting
should just be filling things to me.
You all stand to work with whatever the
hours data space.
That will keep my head above water,
but I don't think it's delegated
salespeople or in charge.
I think it's exactly what I've been
saying. It's the key, you know.
Yeah, this would sound like, you know,
pretty much an opportunity falls in our
lap hard enough giving the monthly
talking tomorrow or getting.
I did mostly getting work for the.
The city getting work for the company
that stayed down.
We're not getting much of that work here.
They're just not getting much worry out.
Great Falls is empty.
There's nothing in Great Falls.
I don't think the caster has much.
I think the answer is the facilities are
severely under realized.
And they would like to change the map.
Yeah.
And then New Mexico, they can't,
they can't keep employees.
They've got three or four guys there at
that facility. See,
a bunch of estimators needs that we need
to figure out how to build and work.
That's the money so we can get more jobs
and be working better.
Yeah, in a nutshell, absolutely.
And that's the weird thing, man.
Just like we were so busy all the time.
Don't know what changed,
but we also had a start to do with this
facility like you do with your hand.
Much work to be done here. Yeah, I mean.
And I guess I don't, I don't know.
It's great that maybe a a dollar that I
can see. Yeah, I don't know.
I think that makes the.
OK,
I guess any company there goes 15 million
departmental only.
It's 30 some odd percent profit margin.
I mean we have marked the phone cranes
that's somewhere around 4,
almost 5 million just in one year,
just in one year and that's, yeah,
you're probably getting.
Dana, Robert. Sorry, I haven't found it.
I just kind of asked the same question.
You and I got a lot of the same questions,
yeah.
But as far as tech was concerned,
I think we can just show us it.
It would be very helpful.
We don't have all this. This is even 1,
2025, 324,000 pounds shipped to job sites.
And then Q1 of 2023.
568,000 lbs.
Should we know how much we're done,
we're selling,
we're still on average Q 1/20/24,
I guess we're not entirely certain.
So we're quite a bit of land this year.
Well, this is a quarter of one.
Yeah. So Q 4/20/24, yeah,
that's what we're going to see.
And where are we at now? Q4 hasn't done,
said none Q3.
634 That's all about fixing me in North.
What are you sellable? Uh, 850.
That's what I'm going to do. Yeah, it's,
I mean the in mind different facets of
work that we're bidding.
I don't know if there's a true,
I'm sure there's an average,
but I'm not tribute to an average.
How about any of the jobs that you bid?
Do you know what any of them are?
Oh.
Or do you not look at price per pound
price per pound? No, usually.
I can certainly figure it out.
But like a TSMC job which you're about to
do, what's the sell for?
Do you know the call to sell it?
What do you get scheduled for a month to
check? Anything you all welcome.
Are supposed to be some kind of old
public presentation.
I don't even know what that is.
We don't give. We don't do the cadence.
The what?
We don't want to talk about floor cadence.
Yeah, we do that.
How many for the airport?
Why is it like 340? So get to the new one.
Yeah, no more than two.
I don't know, I'm just, uh,
over the weekend.
But it was at,
but we got there for the flight
department at 5:13 and we got it there.
Yeah, this is a one job right here 4.
6 million.
Back in the What is this?
What was your question?
What software are you looking at?
This is Poco, I see, and I was.
Yes.
I believe when we have to,
we have to go in, we have to go in.
That is not a job.
This part of the European system can't
just put that out.
I assume that doesn't deal with dollars
involved, but you have the contract price.
It'll figure out dollar for found dollar
for. There's metrics for that in there.
You can pull up if you want to do it.
If you have to put it from,
you have to put the commercial side into.
I was just wondering to see what if it's
all.
I don't see dollars anywhere.
I see an app. All right.
Yeah,
I mean you you can see the this is
showing you use an estimate summary.
Use an estimate summary.
It'll give you all that, all that data.
Just interested on side downstairs to
know.
For me, dollars per pound for 836, eight,
516-1704316.
I always want to know the metrics Andy.
Are you pulling out a table to put in
here to wrap your split up?
Long way to do it,
so we need to do this with summary,
I guess.
We have done it in the summary before.
I think the other reason we haven't done
it until we see any of this for summaries
is if we haven't updated any of our tech
level reports to have a loan Roman.
This all reflects one Roman.
And also I have the ability to play with
the margins and there's something that's
a little bit easier in this.
What I what I just keep seeing is there
are 18 programs that we got to get in to
do this.
Same thing that we can do in the blood
for if they like me.
I just came to figure out why that is.
Yeah,
it seems like something that is the
biggest.
Yeah, I think there's legacy, mom,
and I think that's all.
And I think legacy was X and well,
it's just like there's pieces of
information everywhere, so.
I'll do the test and get this part of the
text,
but I'll do the purple and get in this
part of this. Yes,
I know it's in one place and in the
moment. Vista.
I predict everything has to go to Vista.
I don't know about this.
Yeah.
Think that's where the proposal's coming
out. I don't know. I look,
I read back the proposals and I couldn't
decide what generated.
I think everything generated.
That's what I think.
I think they're going to come out of him,
but.
I have seen all of those. Yeah,
I think they're putting bring everything,
all the dollars and everything company
they have to bid. Yeah,
because there's a there's a 67 page thing
that went to that. Yeah, we got a copy.
Yeah, with the CSSC one, no no pricing.
Just one I didn't price like.
I didn't go through labor codes,
calculate everything out.
Not when we submitted a ton of time.
You know we had to drastically reduce our
our labor rates,
our labor rate was lower so that with
Margo it was a certain dollar rate to be
able to.
But we worked. So I mean,
you can do all that already, so forget.
So if I didn't want to use the labor here,
I just want to do a price per pound.
I changed the unit cost up there because
you got your your weight in here.
I changed my unit cost and I go down to
labor and I zero that.
Yeah.
We'll do that.
It comes.
OK, I'm just.
So the quantum there is in balance.
What are you trying to do?
So if we were trying to switch this to a
price price per pound, yes,
just unit cost versus .64,
just talk to whatever.
But $2.
00 will make sense if you want to or
something like that.
What's that going to be?
And then that would give us this is our
way. Yeah, 250. The others are kind. Yeah,
we can go down to the hours down here.
Where's your sale price?
Where's your sale price on here?
All the way at the bottom.
Is that the real sell price?
Go over to the right.
There's yourself price for how many
pounds?
Well, that this is, this isn't a problem.
We we, we respond. OK,
I'm with you because when you clicked the
250, you changed everything. Yeah,
that 250 is probably.
Yeah, we want to know.
We want the program to calculate based on
the sale. No, no,
that's to me right there should be the
price of my material,
just the material line that it should
have made the value of my purchase orders,
right.
And that's that's what that normally is,
but in this scenario he can say.
We didn't do the labour.
We just saw that a price per pound for
the. I'm sorry,
they never ran into the labour.
So do you have any idea what this job
sold for?
Windows M.
But you have to go in the folder to look
at it.
You wouldn't just hop into Vista to look
at it. I think there's some of that.
But you won the job, right?
But because you submitted that bid,
you entered it in Vista as a contract.
It's for railways.
Well,
the proposal is just to keep the
proposals.
So 2021 hours, maybe $27,000, 15,
000 profit at a 12% level.
The other one was at 338,000 lbs.
That is not right.
This.
159 lbs.
Store.
Pretty see that.
Or 56,000 pounds. That still makes sense.
No.
By the way,
if you're trying to get 6000 lbs, $0.
50 per.
If you if you got to do it as labour only,
it's like.
Yeah, there's no material in that. Oh.
Yeah, OK. Yeah, that's labor only. Still,
that's ridiculous. That's chef's only,
$127,000 for 256,000 lbs.
You're doing the labor at $0.50 a pound.
I mean, I'm just doing labor.
$2.00 a down.
128 cents. We make money.
Make someone about 15, right?
So you were getting paid.
$60.
00 an hour if you did the job really in
2100 hours.
Hours.
You know, search area conferences.
Said 15,000.
What do you say? OK, yeah, yeah,
it's not very much.
Well, I mean, what's the shop right here?
Cost. We're gonna fix it. Uh, cost.
That's hard 'cause they keep,
they keep splitting up.
They're trying to split overhead out of
it. So um,
I think our actual sell is like 40 maybe
$49 or something like that,
without overhead.
Suing shop management leads and.
And employees. So this is only a really.
So not fun, but we need to work,
so we got it. Sure, I can understand.
Take my local office market.
It's OK and we really need. So this one,
this one was our.
So it's like a.
One second, we got there first.
So the contract price is 1563.
Yeah,
which is actually more because there's
cheap original. This is the original 1,
000,600 is a lot close. I think it's 1,
612,000. Where are the thousands?
No.
685,582 66558265655582655582.
Which we had to say it again.
So Chief, this is our, this is our video.
So that one we're doing well, I think.
And.
That one we were probably going to finish
at a 47%.
So,
so we aren't cheap fabricators if we're
making make that kind of money,
but we're fabricating really cheap.
So, OK,
you're you're we're talking about sooner.
Let's see what that is. Yeah, that's true.
So.
We we have. I mean,
we're pretty much trying to run through
everything we're going to do on on the
business.
I'll tell you what I would like to do.
Yeah. What's that? I mean, OK, so I'm,
I'm pretty much brought here to say what
are we doing in tech, all right? Yeah,
exactly.
I would,
I would like to absolutely run through
the entire workflow and say what's in
tech or what's not in tech,
but where are we doing and I'm estimating
all of our shipping.
How? How's it being done?
Where should be done?
Make sure everything is.
Sounds great to me.
Kind of like with with estimating that
I'm I'm not, yeah, if if the goal is.
This.
Well, yeah,
what I'm leaving in writing report,
I'll get my opinion that. I mean,
obviously part of what part of what I'll
say is I think there's way too many
programs that are being used for the same
thing. It's like, Oh yeah.
That, you know,
to me estimating is there that that's my
flow chart. So you made it. Yeah,
I was like, how record is this?
It's the it's typical flow of a.
Of a structured job and so it it and what
part of the system here can be used and
then it can be modified for your own
purposes.
So what you're saying if you'd like to
say this is what you think it could be.
You'd like to know what it is.
That's kind of the the door. Yeah,
I want to know what's what's what the I
think it's great idea because I'd love to
know it myself. Yeah,
I'd like to kind of just start walking
through it,
really walking through an estimate like
you know what's be what part of the
estimate is being done in here,
how the material.
We're sitting there. Yeah, I got, I got,
you know, most of this stuff,
but I think it'd be great to have. Yeah,
the hard part's not having our estimators
here because I can only speak truth to.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, so.
Because everything that I do when I run
through to check with all my,
so I do all say all to be.
This is also my going back to everything
you do.
But even when you're wrapping it up
though,
you're going over in the program or so.
Is that a company reason for that or is
that a that's just what we do thing or is
it you know is there and it may be the
best thing I'm just saying it seems like
actually work to me because now I've got
to create each other they are.
Pull all this information from tech or to
take over or to do something,
whereas I do that at the time in here.
Yeah, there's a reason it is,
but and pro core whenever we get the job.
We we have an opportunity,
we create an opportunity,
fill out a new opportunity form and then
they create an estimate folder and then
they create the job and pro order and
then they assign it to the associated
estimator, which is then tilted,
tiny sales force, yeah,
which is the sale opportunity.
And then depending upon the status
updates in for a board,
whether it's submitted or worded and
whatnot, based upon the bid board,
this kind of stuff, updates, Salesforce,
so on and so forth.
But you want to go through the whole job
start and finish that we're using within
tech.
Is that correct? Yeah.
Estimating all the regulations. Yeah.
It's just got to make sure here's the
stats,
which you can do that you as the banker
option. Yeah. Yeah. So where,
where do we estimate?
Uh, we estimate and check the heavy dead.
I think there's one other one.
But all structural is estimated in time.
I understand any guess I agree.
Now, based on what I've heard, yeah,
in my six days, so.
And yet,
do we want to walk through this now?
We can start through this now.
We want to wait till more. No, no,
do it now. All right. So, all right.
Estimating. We get a job, all right.
Uh, I'm happy to.
I can't able to answer my tip from from
for you browser, so like this will be.
But now, first of all,
some of us in Texas, some in heavy bid.
Somewhere else,
somewhere additional system that I'm not
privy to.
But for for what you do for the
structural side, it's heated.
Did Mark in here as well or she does does
another thing. Mark,
she can do manual takeouts.
I'm doing type of takeouts so we can on
the same jobs. Yeah, same, same jobs.
OK.
You want to go through the steps of the
estimate,
how he puts the estimate together. Well,
I mean, we don't have to do the steps,
but um.
Let's say a little bit elevated without
getting into the details.
Do you get the job?
Do you run us from tech?
Do you pop it into the project?
You're estimate or not? No, I'll link it.
So you. OK, I'll link.
Of like so like this one MGS um.
This is my. This is my estimate in here.
So I'll enter the production control
'cause I prefer entering almost something
there. I'll enter everything in there.
I'll export kiss file,
import it in here so it has all my
information and then.
All my bridge outs.
So and then it's the job that you've got
to do it. Yeah,
it's having a the one piece this week. OK.
And so I'll estimate by by drawing.
And break all this information down and
then give my total hours and and then I
end up going into pro board and 06.
Let's see.
It's the side of these estimators.
So I'll go in and estimating part of part
of why I think we were also doing it in
here is to the codings side of things are
all broke out in here.
They have codings broke out.
I'll make the attack limit now I'll just
add to that.
And do all of those,
do all the steps in there.
But I'll go in here and I'll plug in my
shop hours for what was estimated.
I'll go in and take all the quotes that I
got for my materials.
I'll have all my material quotes in here.
So let's go back here real quick.
So the material cost is not intact.
OK, we're not using it. Are we purchasing?
So I don't.
I I haven't messed around plugging any of
my quotes into Tegrify.
Usually just you know, yeah,
because this is essentially where where I
build my my proposal.
Break everything down, verifications,
putting information, inclusions,
exclusions for for everything.
And then this is all for, yeah,
this is all for,
so I'll submit everything.
Through here. Yeah. I mean,
we want something like that.
So you do this because you don't have all
this set up in a low growth template in
tech, yeah.
So if you have this all in Tekla,
you would stop using Procor. Yeah,
that's the reason why I need to use
Procor. Yeah,
because they would save a whole lot of
transfer of data over this. Basically,
can you go back on the job and show us
where you put the material cost and you
had Procor entered it into Tekla?
That is what you want, right Ricky? Yeah,
well, I mean,
it does sound like you can go to the bits
up for any reason in tech, right? Yep,
because this is where you wrap this up.
So yeah, if you're doing,
we're purchasing from here,
your number has to be in here somewhere
you can buy material for, right? No, no,
it's not whatsoever. It's not tied in. OK.
I mean,
you could do this here for material, yes,
but.
That is not where I would normally do it.
I will be putting it on each like if I
had a bank and a half two,
I'm going to put you know specific price
on it, but I have as opposed to.
Yeah, any other size.
So like when you write out your purchase
order,
you're going to the project management
section, right?
Or your purchasing section. I don't know,
production control, production control.
You're not using the estimate at all.
So open up production control.
Let's see what's your work,
but that but that's not what we would do
here for the estimate close out of here,
right?
So if I'm pricing material here,
first of all, the material,
the the material cost can just flow in
from the database if you want to.
If you maintain the pricing maintenance
from the as I enter in here,
it just flows in, yeah, so.
The second means,
which is what most people do,
got the estimating drop down and you go
to job specific pricing maintenance.
And go up to pricing drop down at the
very top and add signs from estimate,
pull everything over.
Ever.
OK,
you have copy prices from the database.
If it's if these prices in there pulls
over like this bullet read a dollar
thirty-six 100 weight and then I'm
adjusting it here either by global
editing or changing it like here's I'll
be changing the one line.
And then that locks the pricing in here,
so it's not going to change and it also
puts it over there.
So this then sets up to where it gives me
my pricing for estimating,
which I can then in reporting compared to
what my actions are.
And then after this then you go to
purchase it and you at least have this
price compared to. Yeah,
can you do both questions in here?
Plus I have a pricing database of.
And once a quarter,
I send it down to my vendors and they
fill it in.
I can update this and then push it all in.
Yes, I see that. Yeah, so like.
Do more pricing,
they do the they do their updates.
You can pull that in a couple of months.
So that's the normal way of doing
material pricing so you can get right and
then.
It will also be in the remnants,
then your drops could be done more.
It applies just the percentage or I can
do the bonding in here to get more exact
so you know the smaller the project.
I might have 30% scrap on the job because
it's smaller, right?
Whereas larger projects I might have 4%
scrap or something like that.
So you can combine and do whatever you
want. So pricing.
This, this is normally happens. So.
And then, yeah, it sets it up for yeah,
comparison. So.
So when you're wrapping it up again,
so really all you're doing this for is we
get apps is really what disappoints you
right now, right? Yeah. Yeah.
Pretty much just for hours.
So, you know,
do hours in here and then uh.
And then everything else is been external.
And then once once this is done,
the bottle's sent off,
everything's where it needs to be.
That's when I take everything that's
production controlled.
And it's in the middle of my back.
So do you think that, let's see guys,
the wrong and talk,
are they doing the same thing with you?
It's using her out.
You know,
cause they're not using it for material
costing you all. No,
they'll combine it here so that they have
be buying rooms.
This one is exactly like keyboard. Got it.
Yeah, that's a bit surprising.
So then in here, brush control routes.
Yeah,
everything and then push things through.
So let let let's drop back there because
we we we jumped way far ahead.
So we got we did the estimate and so that
goes over to Pro 4.
Everything gets submitted there.
Nothing else comes back in the to the in
the estimating when you win the job.
Advance bill.
You don't really do advance bills, right?
All right.
How much materials you know?
One big picture.
You can send it out and say, hey, look,
I'm gonna need.
I'll be an e-mail this pretty soon.
That's the early look before you actually
finish your design. So let's go to.
All right, you win the job,
set the job up.
What in project management is being
utilized?
As opposed to elsewhere, pretty minimal,
right?
I think you're because with usually with
Vista and Procore,
a lot of that gets done elsewhere and.
I'll say in a lot of cases rightfully so.
So RFI's, where's where RFI's been?
I do all of my RFI's through here.
What about it? What about?
I'm the only one to be using that one.
What about transmittals drawings?
Are they stored within here? Yeah,
all of anything that I'll use
transmittals and drawing log and track
all of my back and forth between here and
the other guys.
No, but the other guys don't do it.
They're it's estimating.
They're out of the loop.
They're able to get estimated hours and
they never use basically this program
again. Is that right?
They just estimate hours and they're done
with the tagline the.
So and and do you control all of the
drawing law?
I feel like we're grilling it. I'm sorry,
do do you control all of the drawing law
and transmittals for everything that runs
through here? OK,
so all all the out for approval,
everything is in here.
You can see what draws are out.
OK, um, we're going to need that and I.
So maybe the only one, yeah,
none of the other project engineers that
interface with any of their customers are
using this format.
They're using a smaller system that I'm
not. But are they,
is that work that runs through this
facility or sometimes it is work that
runs through this facility.
They'll but most of the time when I see
it,
it's it's in a project coordinated
request one for this is the work that he
pushed through.
They've already worked through all that
background stuff all the time.
So there's there's work that you guys do.
That somebody else has control and they
handle all that out for approval and
transmittal and drive along all that
somewhere else. OK,
even though it's the same company,
the the only stuff that's trapped in
Tekla.
For transmittals, RFI's, drawing log,
back and forth between detailers and
approval stages is my projects and things
that I do.
So the other guys are probably using a
spreadsheet or something to track all
that stuff or whatever change order logs.
They've got all sort of different.
Different interfaces and and different
things.
Do you have any exchange orders in here
too, or do you have change orders? Yeah,
I'll enter my change orders in here.
I haven't had any projects since we've
gone through all this that I've had that
huge amount of change orders.
I I do still track it separately in a in
an Excel sheet log because a lot of
customers like to see that Excel on that
it's easier to go back and forth with it.
But anything that I can possibly use this
program for, I use this program for.
I made the contract and it was on and we
didn't really look at it.
Usually when there's a business,
it's not used just because you can do
whether it's pay at,
but you can do the pay at over there.
It's got to get over there anyway.
We were going to talk about it.
Is there a need for that? Yeah,
I saw it on our list.
We had it on there just because that was
a part of our action items from last time
of trying to figure out the importance of
it and and The thing was it was like.
I know about it and it's all the
duplication of other things that are done
external. Yep.
So it's more of a me and Mark in a large
project than we want to use something
like that for something that's long drawn
out.
This looks like your projects for the for
the actual building portion.
How's that function?
Do you actually send the invoice or pay
it to to the client or does that get
somebody?
Did you tell them this this month?
Yeah,
it's simply there's based upon whatever
whatever our original agreement upon,
which is usually like, right,
that portion of it we'll do.
So that's the original and then the rest
is built upon completion and then usually
I'll reach me or more marketing jobs.
I don't have jobs in the last four months
where you say, hey, I'm 40% this month,
the next month I'm 60%,
the next month I'm 100%.
Line was kind of that way,
but then even then that was started in in
November and it needed to be completed by
the the first week of December. OK,
so yeah, so you're not doing nothing,
it's it's usually.
Most,
not most of our projects are done over a
month,
so we'll we'll go through that then maybe
tomorrow and check with you again just to
make sure it's useful for you.
Mark will be in for the full day tomorrow,
so he would be going through everything
with him.
So it's project schedule we are doing.
Yep, that's pretty much everything, right?
See,
we have everything projects scheduled,
every project that touches our floor.
Turboconnect. Turboconnect.
Whenever we have an MMC file,
everything's uploaded in the turbo future.
So just your job. So just that.
I'm going to get example 250-67155,
this is one you're getting this uploaded.
This one we have everything essentially
production wise length.
So I've sent status updates to the
customer based upon.
So educate me a little bit.
What is triple connect going?
It's a model viewer and so Tribal connect
to me it's the best way.
I did use that when I was at ASD.
I was connected.
So I get straight to the model from
within tech. Yeah, yeah, I did that.
They need more color.
I was the model based on material status.
We have a lot of that info as to why.
Oh my goodness, it's so.
Awesome. Yeah. You say, OK, this is built.
It's one color. This is,
this is already installed.
It's another color. Yeah, I saw that.
How did they ask you? It is.
I've talked so much stuff that way and
it's such a good way to get proactive on
jobs.
Reacted to oh ****,
we forgot this problem, right?
It's like you can say a hand up with this.
So the stuff that you're doing is
attaching to Trimble Connect,
but the stuff that Karam and Pock are
doing is not.
Well, because it's not real.
They're not running the production.
But if somebody's running their jobs that
they do again,
some project manager over there is
running, right?
Well, I guess it depends. So electrical,
electrical isn't as OK to to be added to
this system.
But but Karan and they didn't right? Yeah,
we did structural designs, right?
So who is managing those jobs?
If they're getting,
if they're getting production and they're
involved with us, it's us. If if it's not,
you know, OK,
so sometimes you would manage a job that
they got, yeah,
and then in that case you would actually
put it in the terminal.
And and the times you don't get a model
here,
is that because what's what's the reason
behind that?
What's the cause of that I guess is what
I'm saying.
The only reason we wouldn't get a model,
it depends on the the project itself,
so like.
Like these little runways we get,
I don't even,
I don't even get CAD files for those.
We have to draw all of our plate files.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They don't give us kiss files.
We just get a drawing package. Yeah.
But most of those are maybe 10 assemblies
at most. Some, some beans, some columns.
Yep, so.
Uh, but if you have a model,
you're you're getting, yeah,
so always like reference.
We're always pushing to deal with this
because we want this level of visibility.
Yeah, and then also.
We want to run into our elements. Yeah,
yeah,
that's that's teared on the same level.
Dropping back on your drawings and
transmittals,
are you able to get a PFXP filed and
important drawings? Yeah,
two reason got there.
Through our own detailers, yes. OK, cool.
That is a part of our design standard.
They always supply on them for our
insurance packages that are detailed by
us. Anything that's customer supplied.
Sometimes when you control it,
you can get it, yeah, so.
So then you place your file.
Um.
In um.
It's really the only other things in
project management there were those
little tiny.
Journal entry and task list and check
list like things.
Most people weren't doing that anyway.
Even even then task list wise we don't
have anything. We'll check the set up.
We aren't even.
I had three or four orders.
This was helpful. Yeah, I haven't seen.
It's it's where people, yeah, yeah,
it's it's there if people find it useful.
I've gone to shops where they had
searches with that on and they basically
the same thing on spreadsheets list.
This entire checklist is based off of the
procedure that I have for project
coordinators, which is our project.
It's.
Project flow, organizer lease folder,
save request form,
open project management job,
fill out information provided,
important zeros and production controls,
select drawings and CNC files.
Not relevant if you Yeah, VFXT,
but fixing the material,
make sure everything is checked,
go through applying routing.
My materials using programs for the blade.
We see PCs for work annual my materials
purchaseable names based on my materials.
With inventory for stock,
we can use yard drop, send RFQ down,
send hardware up.
And the production check volunteers
accounted for confirmed and proceed with
work packages,
330 working and leasing add hours to work
packages. Once work packages complete,
generate, be a women trailers,
BLL load list.
There's coatings and this reports are
generated, do your placements things.
So this is where we've been saving our
files in the drawing logs.
Link IMC model and project management and
users.
Project management, procedure,
transmittals,
create application release for sequence
and log. That's all talking to reports,
open source e-mail and then include all
the following information in application
release and break all that down the
production schedule.
Production schedules will be entered into
the project schedule in project
management and then this breaks down the
project management procedure.
Hour breakout in the Gantture,
hour percentage updates.
Adjust scheduled for production,
schedule released the fabrication shop
and then we fill one of these out for
every time we shoot something out to the.
Those stuff from project management is in
that. That's pretty much everything there.
OK,
release for Fab and production control.
You get a PFXP if possible, right? Yep.
So you imported in.
Um.
You're you're doing the routing. Uh.
You're doing the combining and everything
to purchase, right?
Are you purchasing with a little?
What are you grabbing?
They haven't figured out on yet.
I had an accident without the kids,
so just see how many months. Yeah,
sleep is probably what it does do. Yeah,
it sounds like it.
Some days I try to find time.
So you're combining and purchasing,
combining every single project we send
out,
we send out to three to five vendors to
get competitive cost purchasing in here.
And then we also program.
So we created all the plate mess things
and PC mess things for the equipment on
the property.
I specifically handled any of the sub
application work.
So maybe these federal beam line or
processing or get the teams to get rolled.
That's something I specific.
Handle OK and then I'll attract all that
to transmittals. Um.
And then we create the work packages and
then it.
So I guess once everything's imported,
sequence the mod accordingly.
And it was routed and then.
Work packages and then Douglas and then
final reports,
just so that our BLM reflects work
packages and everything in the shot
traveler and we see all those reports.
Everything's all structured the same,
so if we go into any.
In these folders, see our releases,
sequence one, lot one, shop reports.
I ended up releasing multiple sequences
on this,
but everything gets bill of materials,
everything's Traveler,
bring down a cut list, pull list,
pull list for plate and that goes out to
the shop.
This goes out to the shop floor if if you
got 10, let's move out the shop.
Just because this has kind of just been a
part of our procedure,
now that we typically at this point still
haven't paid about a full request to
everyone on two equipment.
So that like one or two over done a
notary level plus the physical people
report.
They have it.
And also part of it's just so that we
have record of it as well.
Then at this point, you know the original,
and what's the shop traveler?
Shop traveler is.
Essentially just the assemblies and
quantities that are associated in that
inspection fit, fit or well,
can they feel that?
No, they no longer use.
They no longer use.
That's what it was for. Yeah,
they no longer.
They're piece tracking everything all all.
Um.
The areas where we couldn't go away from
any of this, because that, yeah, I mean,
you know the danger of paper cutting this
and revisions that that's, yeah,
that that can be solved hasn't burned us
in a long time,
but it's definitely burned us.
Yeah, yeah.
So I could tell some bad stories,
obviously. But then, yeah, all of our,
all of our playlist things started here.
I mean,
this is what needs to be maintained with
the latest revision of everything when
you think.
Hold this footage to the thread folder.
Anything new is updated in here and then
also updated in echo as well so.
OK.
Um.
And once,
once we have all of that information
pulled,
put together and added things to the
drawing log,
which we can take a look here in the
project management chapter for this,
then we'll take.
All those sharp reports, all the drawings,
everything converting into what we're
planning and releasing them before
they've been added to the drawing along.
So all of that is all saved in here and
in the associated areas.
And then transmittals are created for any
of our shop releases that are sent to the
board.
Cool.
And then once all that is all put in here,
we'll then e-mail that portion out.
Now this is my multiple bot shot release.
Essentially all the information I had
broke down in there when the materials
coming in, pertinent notes,
quarter seven bottom plates will be
processed in the following phases since
all of those are when we cut the size,
anticipated deliver radius of materials.
And then any specific notes and then
right down to our later codes.
This one is on the boxes,
so each box's length had its own sequence
and locked in the hours associated with
it.
Coatings layer codes,
coding specs and then production
schedules for each.
So submit the information that may turn
into project management.
Are all of those lots a?
Separate work package.
Hello.
You know we I'll I'll apologize ahead of
time. You know we're not on news on this.
All that's on good, you know, so.
That takes a lot of time to talk about.
I'm just, I'm lazy, you know,
is it needed or is it just spoon feeding?
You know, spoon feeding. Yeah,
this is also what we use for updates for
the team, so.
Um, oftentimes,
I think this one's a little bit different
because the PM and the PE are obviously
both marking there. Yeah,
but a lot of times it'll be the other PE
that we have found on this e-mail.
So if there are any delays with material,
it's supposed to go to this e-mail thread.
So that way it's easily tracked for
everyone. Um, if there are.
Are once that the project is completely
complete and it's moving into codings,
we're supposed to have an item who will
send another e-mail updating this. Hey,
this is not complete.
Coding is supposed to be the same thing.
It doesn't get realized the way it should,
but that's how it's certainly said to go,
yeah.
So and all that can be done with
automated reports.
I have no sympathy for people who are too
lazy to go look at the system and not and
then look up that stuff.
I have 0 sympathy oriented people.
The problem is that what that turns into
though is just them calling us.
And asking for an update and I'll end up
on the system. Well, but yeah, you're,
you know,
like on a totem pole you were probably
pretty high there.
It's like we're down here.
I can tell those guys that they,
but those project managers and project.
Do they all have that one?
Once we are involved in instructional
missing kids, do they have a new tech?
Good.
That's a good place that they were using
it for me. I've used it some,
so all the time now the.
I'll I'll say the the danger here is you
two guys go somewhere else.
Nobody else in this company knows what's
going on, you know,
you know something and and that's that.
And and that's not just a yeah, well,
sure.
I've been to there's a shop in Brooklyn.
I've been to three times because they
lost their YouTube guys twice and they
did it right.
It's because nobody else looked at
anything. So that it would be.
And I don't know, I'm pretty sure.
So yeah, yeah, we're definitely,
definitely on the same page.
Yeah, they seem really interested in tech,
even this morning. They're all in. Yes,
like they're all in all your PM,
all your project engineers and everybody
needs the PEX and and the PE is admin on.
Yeah,
there's all the all the information is
there. Yeah.
I've been they were using checkbook.
They did all of this stuff that he's
pointing out.
They were the ones that did the
transmittals.
They were the ones that did the RFI.
They were the ones that took the drawing
from the system.
They fill out all the stuff.
They were the ones that pulled up the
triple connect and said, OK,
I got this checked out, this checked out,
this checked out.
To doing that.
The system 10.
That's what it is.
All the brothers and all and project
managers, they're all on it.
They all do all that stuff within the
system.
That's what I think is to be here. Yeah,
yeah, it is. In other words,
I'm not talking about that's going to be
all, that's something you might need.
If anybody has to be on 100% on this,
I see it at work.
And then this honestly is an uncommon
analog. We we buy ours with you.
But yeah,
the the ones that are like you were
talking about,
the ones that are have everybody looking
in there, man pays off so much.
We also have the purchasing agents.
I mean four or five project managers,
five or six project engineers,
all those people were using it all in all.
And then the estimators,
it's like 3 or 4 estimators using it as
well.
They got about 15 people using it back
home.
300 tons a week. They do a lot.
They're doing 60 million a year plus.
When I left them a year and a half ago,
they were,
they were trying to get to 100 million a
year.
There's a tree I've been working on for
years.
It's about two feet in front of me and
falls flat.
I don't think we're working at all.
Based on when they told me how interested
they were going forward with it.
This morning when I talked to him,
since I knew about,
since I've had LinkedIn,
I've been following Ricky and I have
followed everything that you do out there.
I've been blessing you to come here for
years.
It wasn't until we became long ago and we
finally gave the investment.
And now they're trying to push more
things. Yeah,
it has been a I didn't see a great idea.
I'm not sure. Yeah.
Does somebody have the other volume that
they use? That's technical.
Their their goal is, I think.
The the So this call came from Lonro.
They want to be in tech or it came from
us and we pushed it for them.
They saw how well we they saw how well we
offered. Oh OK and and I still feel it.
You guys are barely doing it.
Yeah. What?
What's you're using before you do the
virtual app? Yeah,
certainly it can be expanded. Yeah,
absolutely. Perfect.
That's the that's the truth on some of
these other systems.
I mean,
it just seems like you're double at least
all working. Yeah, that's true.
I think so too.
Every quarter I hear about this.
So after every quarter, OK,
after the release and so.
Receiving is that's we we're working on
getting that done out there. So then.
It's yours should be should be received.
It should be received.
It's doing it yours. Well, it's also. Yes,
it is.
Uh,
so you can look up and sit back on this.
He's helping me when we're sitting there
and it's probably less to have a piece
side for more than. Let's say, I mean,
he's sent back the rest of the yeah, yeah,
all I have to that job. OK,
you can build it for.
Can you show him?
I think it would basically just be.
So if this question was if he needed to
look up a job for all of the HDRS,
we'll have a form. He's a guy.
I need the money. All right.
You don't have to show me this piece of
egg offline for a job.
It's literally got 3 clicks once you get
a new job. So yeah.
So they started where we were.
It was cumbersome because you had to know
all the purchase orders and then you
could pull the purchase orders in one by
one. It's horrible, yeah.
To review TFS details, yeah.
Man, that is sweet.
There's very few without one.
I I can't tell you that. I mean,
you can imagine most shots I get into.
I'll see 90% are not in there,
but I can even the ones without the box
goes with batch edits so.
One of these that has a multiple,
this one probably has the numbers for all
this.
So they just sign documents that all
after the falter.
You know,
save documents and then you can also get
a report that gives you piece mark like
each number by by everyone.
And you guys don't have to do any MTR
review here, right?
I've only had a few customers that have
replaced.
You could think that the AISC audit would
be all over together.
Yeah, I see.
And he showed agree to keep all this. Oh,
OK, yeah, there we go.
And it saved in the the job folder also.
Oh, so that's where he saved them.
And that's how he pulls them. Yeah, yeah,
when you.
I don't understand why they're in the job
folder. When you get check, pull it up.
You gotta save it somewhere.
So I think that's kind of here.
Here we go. We go on to this project,
we go to the front, should be received,
received.
You would think it'd be in the MPR folder
that you have there.
I don't really understand why we have
that because it's no, you should have.
Yeah, like I said,
you think that's where you just double.
But they're literally saved.
In here for at least if you have it, yes,
yeah, yeah.
So the the reason we have an MCR folder
is because.
That's ASME shop.
You had certain ones definitely had to be
reviewed.
We wouldn't put them into the MTR folder
until they see review the.
The thing about the if if you just go
back to the folder to pull everything.
That takes away your ability to be able
to swap heat numbers at the machine.
So like if the one we bought for the job
is over the bottom of the stack of Tina,
I'm not going to take that out.
I'm holding one up top,
going to the machine and I'm swapping the
heat number at the machine.
And then it's going to record the problem
one year, but it won't.
You got to grab it out of hold or it
won't be the right one, right?
So it doesn't swap. So. But yeah,
that's cool. That looks.
That looks awesome. It does.
So then cutting, pick list,
cutting on getting OK then then
everything else is happening on getting.
The time tracking on the base tracking,
probably they've been using the time
tracking through tech button.
They've been using the time tracking
through tech button.
Have you into it? Yeah. OK, yeah,
I think it's been at least two years or
so.
So you're so we're looking at today's
label for now. Yeah,
you go into the time tracking detail.
So much today. I really have. Well,
especially on this side, yeah.
It's OK.
So these are all of our time entries.
That's really good one.
I guess I have that so.
We have a lot of data on their leaves and
then the mandatory stretches they have to
do in the morning for safety.
That's that's like stretcher. Yeah,
it's literally.
I thought that was the guy's nickname the
first stretch.
That's a lot.
I've never seen that in the shop before.
I've only seen that in the field. No,
it's it is required. Everyone,
the guys are out there stretching.
Is this a 5 minute thing or something? No,
it's very solid. Yeah,
it's it's solid stretchers.
How much are shopping in Massachusetts?
That's the only minutes.
Yeah,
they're playing all over their their
safety talk.
So there's we're up straight in this.
Spread some flex in a in a you know
tailgate talk. OK, JSA.
OK, Job safety analysis in the shop. Yes,
each project has to have a JSA filled out
for it.
So they have a separate JSA's in the shop.
I see JSA's in the field.
That's good.
I didn't say it's a bad thing.
I just said I haven't seen it before.
Just saying, just saying,
just keep me in mind because we were kind
of talking about the start shop on the
stations.
It will be in addition to this. Yeah.
So it's that time though.
So everyone in TJ will be over this every
day and check their face scanning against
what they have.
Where does that 30 minutes go?
1200 indirect. OK, it's indirect.
Got it. Oh, I see. That's the job.
And it pulls lunch out of here
automatically out of there all day. No,
no, no. It's far influence part back in.
We'll verify.
That'd be hours from here,
travel for 7 AM priority or the next.
What would you change about the time
tracking near me today?
Well,
one that this integration would be nice
being able to establish the engineering
and the converse.
The other thing would be is it's.
And I guess I've used different
interfaces at shops,
most of them on a computer,
your job and how long you're on and then
clocking in and out of it physically.
And this one in EPM Go can be a pain in
the *** when you're typing things in.
Yeah,
that is not adding notes to it sucks.
I thought I was gonna say that.
So that would be that would be the main
thing.
Obviously I don't have strike by time in
this fashion, so no work up my back,
but I'm sure few guys have some choice
words to say about that. Yeah,
and then well, as you can see though,
it's just it gets very.
Cumbersome for a guy if he's jumping in
between jobs or like jumping 9-4 or
jumping in between, um,
stations going from, you know,
fit up to whatever,
you gotta go to the tablet punch in. Uh,
I think this works a lot.
A lot of the shops are moving in those
stations.
It's a computer over there.
I got to get off my break list.
I got to shut my breaks off because it's
not safe. And I got to go over.
I got to log in and then I got to enter
my stuff, enter my job, clock in,
clock out of my job or clock into the
next job.
And then I go back and I'm in the same
station and I got my materials and I get
back and forth.
This you got to tap it right here,
go into, go along with this job.
We go to this next pile of steel and
working on this job.
So that side of it is great.
They have a swamp job,
so because there you got stopped,
then you got to do another record and
start it right there to do it.
You know,
they ought to be just like a swap job,
change job or whatever.
But they have that, right?
There's a lot of them that when you stop,
when you go into the next one, it stops.
Yeah, yeah, this one does.
It's a that's why I say.
When clients ask me about this,
I'll say it's a little clunky. Yeah,
it it could be refined. In fact,
I'm seriously thinking about rewriting
the interface,
having my son rewrite the interface for
him. What was the best one you've seen?
I don't get into a lot of people's time
talks what they're using.
What I used to use is called time off
plus and it worked pretty well.
I just couldn't go very deep on my level
so I could I could do job and see what's
as low as I could go if I wanted to so.
So I'm going.
I have some good input on what's the best
thing out there.
I didn't know our ours changed to where
it used to be you'd walk up, you know,
whatever we did last and come right back
up. Yeah, and the new system you had to.
Do it every time.
It was just ridiculous because you might
be sometimes on jobs for weeks. Yeah,
but yeah, I don't know.
And then I didn't think about having to
do at the interface to the business.
If I was like they were going to do it,
you know?
But what? What ends up dumping the Vista?
How much detail?
All the detail or or what jumps the Vista
automatically or that you have to like
automatically the the integration here
does PHP over seats and that's it.
But they are doing what the next form out
of you manipulate.
We have to get in the right form after
this and they get this right.
So much time does that say at this point
it takes me 10 minutes, 12 minutes a week.
So in the beginning we've paid the guy
the whole time.
Now it's starting to it's a side task for
somebody else to be planning.
They're ready to do it.
So not not too cumbersome.
No, but yeah,
that's that's pretty much our process.
Um process sold for the most part.
And then, yeah,
it would be very useful to have more
members in this,
understand this and then switch it on a
cloning machine so I could have like two
or three of me and then I'll be safe.
Yeah, yeah.
But you know,
in all circuits and time studies,
I guess I learned this week that that's
my job. So depending on the studies and.
Data in the system and say this is the
last chance.
We hired a guy just to do what's called
CI and he was responsible for all of that,
yeah.
We haven't got it for a while.
We really did some time studies and stuff
and we changed some hours around,
but like it was when we changed some
hours around,
we wouldn't push it against the other
side and change it for that size. Yeah,
you know they have to cut a C8 by 11.
5 crazy in this thing.
And that's it.
So it's never pushed into a range of size.
So that's that's something that would be
huge. So yeah, that would be brilliant.
Yeah,
I've been looking in there just with
scheduling.
I think it should be breaking more into
the normal X. Yeah, I get it. I get it.
Nice part is the shop starts performing
or anything because I start time at 7:00
AM. So I.
I'll reach it all week. I haven't.
So we sometimes that's what she had to do.
Consolation goes.
I felt like we were picking on you there
for a while. Oh, none of you.
It's you guys are having great questions.
So like it's to me,
that's one of the biggest issues with
this system issues.
People don't see it as a communication
problem.
They'll see it as you put the data and
you know what happened so I can call you
and figure out what's happened.
And that shipped me well.
I think it's like that ain't the brand
supposed to be working.
We're doing the work in the background so
that you have to.
No, exactly.
I had one of the best friends in
marketing Sunday.
He did the production and if he were,
he would get bugged all the time by the
project manager. Did this Jerry.
Yeah, what about this big spot?
And I told you, I said,
if I hear you tell, they'll have,
if you give them information,
I'm going to kill you. I'm like,
when they call,
you show up one time to do it and you
upload next time.
I mean that we're already believe in that.
You know, I think, I mean, you know,
why do so many kids stop?
I've never heard of only things I have
generally different things. Exactly.
You should be able to do this. Exactly.
I'm not interested.
I'm interested to find something that's a
great interpretation, especially in the.
Yeah, there's a problem. Yeah, it's so I,
you know, it's like.
It's as long as plenty of it.
So I it's fact that that's it's. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because he says 88%, I'm assuming 88%. So,
yeah, I don't know.
I'll answer some questions.
Do I even get a watch?
That's really on here.
Yeah, it was.
So we definitely got some different
concepts to work on.
It's so much easier for the board to work
on. It's like, yeah.
Programming versus running these packages.
There's so many little back dates to take
time to set up to the level of.
It's not hard for the working,
so it's like that. I mean,
it's just that that was a little certain
level of time.
It's a really inefficient on this level,
but in the same, it really is. I mean,
especially if you change factor and the
environment on top of it,
it's not really good,
but we know that like this.
It's it's what I got today. Yeah,
I thought I was on the push.
We'll be on the same page.
I have to say the block processes,
you know, you know,
I brought break up some more data.
I might get break toward this guy.
I think we're close for the heritage.
I I went to one shop more time than they
were, but I've got a deliverable.
You want the next page.
I don't know. I was like,
that was every one of them. I'm not sure.
Yeah, it's.
I'm sitting obviously not always going
for us, which is great. So yeah,
but it's the and then it's you know,
it's right on us. So we we building out.
Well, I'm not, you know,
you understand what I do behind the
scenes. Yeah, there's.
We need this phone.
That's what I've been doing with the
training. It's certainly no cut and dry.
61 I'm sitting on a project that's why we
did that.
Yeah, pretty much.
So we need like a residential meeting or
something. I'm like to do it.
Maybe that's something.
I'm trying to figure out how to help you
with it. Amber wants.
They're all kinds of.
OK, he may be,
but it's 43 yards down from, but yeah,
it's a lot of time.
So I believe it's all in the e-mail.
It was able to, and we e-mailed it to the.
Some of the team that was meeting a month
ago, but good to see you.
What do you use your glasses for?
You like them? Yeah, the one thing.
I would say.
Yeah, yeah, I was really. I was really.
It got better. OK,
so can you see anything?
So this is the older session,
the new version.
I've been working at that.
Some of those that are more like they're
like reality glasses that are like just.
Yeah,
like my flight in that cone was going to
be for that, but I mean, it's probably,
it's probably.
It wasn't. I really haven't got a minute.
I'll switch. I'll study. I was like,
I don't know where to schedule that.
I do appreciate that.
I'd like to send me about it.
So I went through all that this morning
for you to have me start over there and
just slipping back my floor again.
So, yeah, you know,
we have about the problems locked in
common.
So I need to start with a new call for
you.
Then I need they go up there and it's
actually.
So I remember all that this morning.
It's your statements that this is a good
job. It might be more.
It's not good to do before something.
I think, yeah, as a manager.
Yeah, but I mean, I think I'll get this.
Yeah. And that's the difference on it.
All of this, all of this,
we need to put it on.
It's like you can privacy see what you do.
Yeah. And very nice. Yeah. Well, I'll.
You guys have a good easy pay them off.
It was for the shop.
I have an authorization for over to buy
all of these because and at the time that
station wasn't around,
but Trimble Connect was they were messing
with that.
So I was going to buy them while I was
waiting.
Well,
the second generation of all of this is
coming out because the first generation
was plus one. You know,
it wasn't like the second generation was
willing and I've left before the second
generation.
I think it just played with it.
Seems really good. It's it's awesome,
especially like it's simply yeah,
to see where every specific numbers could
be. Yeah, or it's not.
I will put that in station, but.
And that's just, I mean,
it's essentially the same thing.
It's just it has to break here. Yeah,
that's way more. Yeah, Ted. So Ted,
I'll I'll start at the end of that Tekla,
one of the guys.
I'm I think of some guys I listened to.
They want to talk to people that are
using to see what they like,
what they don't like.
If they can improve on something,
what they improve on,
which kind of tells them we might be
trying to do that to improve and so.
Yeah, so I'm, I'm, you know, yeah.
Which I'm kind of surprised if you look
at doing that.
If they got partners in that is like
already doing that.
I think they were trying to integrate
with that with with the power level,
one fire station trying to integrate with.
But the glasses, I mean, I will. I mean,
I need glasses.
So there's more prescription. Yep,
man vessels. Yep. Yep. And then they, uh,
their prescription.
And then there the transition length is
too. Yeah. But yeah,
mine is the battery life and it's it's
fine to be like, so you.
Or a product or you use the product and
you think about like, oh oh,
like probably. Yeah, that's like, oh,
battery. Like, OK,
if they can't shove more batteries in
there, yeah. Oh,
how have you already figured out how to
attach them to their battery? Yeah,
a little small manual. Um.
There's one that they do have to where a
guy can like have a battery pack and it
still needs to run a wire, you know?
And it's like, yeah,
I haven't thought of anything that just
clips on, you know what I mean?
You know what? Surely. OK,
so that's the smart game. Yeah,
that that's smart could be.
And and it's constantly lit up like it's
obviously.
And so it's constantly lit up and this
thing will last all about two weeks,
which kills me.
But of course it's not going to obviate
and all that, that's a lot of my kids,
but I'm just,
I'm just sitting here thinking this thing.
How does it get two weeks out of that?
Where's the battery even at? Exactly.
You know how is? I mean,
it still has to take all of that,
like you can send it to your phone or
whatever.
So I'm assuming it's just right there in
that.
So, but I think very much.
OK.
In the gas station trying to get or they
have talked about on integrating with.
Yes.
I would like to.
This was served for. I just want to talk.
I've played with one of the material was
first messed and there's a valley that we
were shot for a while as a salted.
But he had wine.
We brought up certain bottles on it,
but it was pretty.
Yes.
So.
It was.
I'm still on Microsoft with producing.
Yeah, that's pretty good, actually, it is.
So.
True.
And how's my glasses would probably be
pretty close to your glasses, but.
Should be on the home screen and then you
can sure to touch and and then if you go
to the apps you can you can see the fab
station.
If you open up fab station in there it'll
go through the.
The opening, all apps, yeah.
Yeah, it's such an idea.
I don't want to ask.
And then I want a conversation.
How easy is it to get the piece out of
the model to lay out? Or is that it's?
It takes a little bit of getting used to,
but now they've made it a lot,
a lot easier.
It's like device registration,
auto fab connection, retry.
I'm gonna log in with that station app
using the tablets like that.
Someone would work here.
OK.
This is.
I just can't believe Tremel gave up on
this.
Tremel was going down this road and just
gave up on it. I was like, come on,
as you were right there at it.
That's OK.
That's a moment.
I'll I'll get this charge.
I'll introduce you to Dave Lopez of
technical. He wants to talk about it.